Okay, I guess we're ready.
The State Board will come to order with the salute to the flag.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America and to the republic for which it stands, one nation under God,
So we'll begin today with the report of the superintendent.
Thank you, President Kuerz and board members.
Happy summer.
schools out.
We're in.
We've got a great meeting in front of us today so welcome everyone who's joined us as well.
I want to give an update on some things that have occurred since our last board meeting and report to you.
We launched the new app, the California Schools app.
With one click you can find any school anywhere and details about just about any subject you're curious about, information about the school's history, dashboard data,
It's another important step in our ongoing efforts to expand access and transparency.
I wanted to introduce to you the individual who developed the app with the team in our technology division.
Dylan Ryan is here.
Thank you.
And it's so simple, you won't need any help.
But if you did need his help, his home number is... No.
So that's a really important milestone.
And I also want to introduce you, reintroduce to some of you who knew her when she worked here previously.
Sarah Neville Morgan is our new Director of Early Education and Support Division.
She most recently, there she is.
Congratulations and you'll be seeing a lot more of her.
She served recently as a Deputy Director of Program Management for First 5 California and worked previously at CDE as a consultant from 2011 to 2013.
And speaking of early education, I recently thanked the governor in signing the budget this year that increases funding for early education and child care and after school programs and teacher recruitment and training and several other really key investments in the budget.
The budget continues the strong growth that I call the California way where our legislature, our governor, this board, my office, my team, we're working together in a very positive way to have positive change in education.
Some highlights in the budget include the long-awaited increase, $50 million for after-school education and safety programs.
We currently serve 500,000 students in almost 4,500 sites.
Also very pleased about $2.5 million that we specifically worked with the legislature on, Shirley Weber being one of the key proponents of this to help us.
$2.5 million for what I call equity team, it's called the equity performance improvement team.
Their grants at CDE will be putting forward to really focus on closing achievement gap.
providing extra focused assistance in that way and we're looking at a structure with five fellows and regional hubs of information and support.
The budget further expanded teacher recruitment and training, additional funding including five million for professional development for bilingual teachers.
And as you know, the demand in all of our schools across the state is growing rapidly for bilingual education, driven in part by the terrific success of Prop 58.
Aren't we happy about that?
That took down some barriers that shouldn't have been there, but they were for a couple of decades, and we got rid of them.
73% of Californians voted for Prop 58, and now we need to really gear up our bilingual education.
Speaking of bilingual education, a highlight of my last few months was traveling to Mexico City.
We had several highly productive meetings and a summit with top education officials in Mexico, including Secretary of Education Aurelio Nuno.
We talked about expanding CDE's exchange teacher program, which currently has 105 full-time contracts for classroom teachers.
from Mexico and other nations who come to California.
We also look forward to working with the Secretary of Education in Mexico for assisting us in helping more California teachers get to Mexico to build their language skills and enter programs to do that.
Many thanks to the CDE staff who helped make this trip possible.
Jasmin Ortega, Marcela Enriquez, and Veronica Aguila.
I don't know if Veronica is here or any of her team, but I wanted to publicly thank them for their
Bridge building, where we say more bridges.
How do we say it?
Queremos construir puentes, no muros.
We would like to build bridges rather than walls.
Summer Institute, Labor Management Institute, had another very successful program.
As always, we thank Shelly Mazur and the CDE Foundation for the work that's going on there.
Great team building between labor and management across the state.
Over 100 LEAs have now been part of the training and part of the good experience of this.
Back to school beyond safe havens is the next topic.
I just wanted to report our safe haven effort has reached now to 113 school districts in the state, representing and covering, providing more protection help to 2.7 million students.
We have parents, speakers, and workshops coming to a fall get-together to focus on the Safe Haven program.
We know that there's still a lot of anxiety out there, a lot of confusion out there about the President's deportation policies, and we want to help our students and families through that rough time.
Glenn Price, I'm just going to ask if he could give a minute to talk about the RE-ORG and the Fall Festival that we plan coming up in September.
Well, thank you, Superintendent Torlakson, President Kirsten, Board of Education.
Building on our state's work with implementation of local control funding formula, we're doing some realignment here at the Department of Education where we're restructuring our branches.
And if you check out the CDA web page, there's a new org chart there.
And we've realigned to three branches from four that we've been working with over the past, actually, quite a number of years.
And those three are performance planning and technology, which will be led by Kerrick Ashley, teaching and learning, which will be led by Tom Adams.
And Nick Schweitzer is not in the room right now, but he's well known to many of you, who will be heading our system support work.
So three branches that we're aligning to
performance planning and technology, teaching and learning, and system support, and we expect they'll be creating some great teams within those branches.
As the superintendent alluded to at the same time, we're continuing our work to really increase teamwork and collaboration within the department by building upon and extending the work of some existing teams and creating a couple new ones which we've dubbed citywide action teams.
So these are teams that draw upon the resources
of all of our branches to work on priority issues.
And there's four citywide action teams being launched.
The first is system of support.
So this will draw upon resources to support the development of the statewide system of support.
The second is integrated planning, which will continue the work of our preexisting LCAP support team, supporting work with LCAP development, implementation, and evaluation.
And of course, we hope will be the subsequent implementation of LEA planning through an LCAP addenda.
The third would be our one system integration team which is building on the work of the one system special education task force and looking at how we can create one system of education in the state of California.
And the fourth as alluded to by the superintendent is team advancement which is headed up by Brianna Mullen and that will be an inward facing team where we're looking at building collaboration and forms of support for our team here at CDE.
And a really exciting event that they have planned coming up, we've been doing a series of summits.
The last one was our spring refresh on April 20th.
And as we move into the fall, we're gonna be hosting here in the building, Back to School Festival.
We're gonna be transforming the lobby area coming into this room and creating a festival-like atmosphere here in the building where we'll be having interactive learning exhibits, highlighting the new realignment of the department.
some exciting activities and work going on so check out your calendars for that event coming up and the Back to School Festival will also feature as one of its flagship events the Beyond Safe Havens Forum that Superintendent Torlakson just described.
Thank you, Chief Deputy Glenn, and we're ready to go.
I predict that one of the top highlights of the summer will be this meeting today and our meeting tomorrow.
Of course, we're very focused on the ESSA plan and the public input to that plan.
Much has gone on in terms of 13 community workshops.
Hundreds of citizens contacted and provided input to the ESSA plan.
I want to thank Barbara Murchison and Joy Kessel for their tireless efforts and terrific work on getting us to this point today.
And now let's have a great meeting.
Thanks.
Thank you for that.
OK, I have several announcements.
The first one is I'd like to thank our student member, Olivia Sisson, for her service during the past year.
And this is her last meeting.
Unfortunately, just as we get to know these people, they go away.
And it's been a pleasure for us to have your service with us.
And your bringing of the student perspective is much appreciated.
We all knew and announced before that she had been early admissions admit to Harvard University in the fall where she intends to major within biology and minor in Middle Eastern studies, but we just found out that she is the valedictorian of C.K.
McClatchy High School in Sacramento, a very large school.
So,
I would like to now present you with this certificate of service.
OK, I'm also delighted to announce that the State Board of Education office has hired Pam Castleman.
Please stand up.
There you are.
Oh, OK.
As an education program consultant, her background is really extensive in curriculum and instruction, the area that she will focus upon.
She started her career as a history, social science high school teacher in Texas.
She was an assistant principal of high schools in the Semi Valley, district coordinator for instructional materials adoption, state assessments, and career and adult vocation education programs.
Most recently, she was Director of Continuing Education at the Ventura County Office of Education, working on workforce education.
At the State Board of Education, she will be involved in the computer science model standards work.
and other future standards adoption work, such as visual and performing arts, world languages, and model standards for ethnic studies.
And she will also assist with our new Joint Advisory Committee on Workforce Pathways, which will be meeting this Friday of this week.
So welcome to us, and we really look forward to your extensive experience in helping us.
So my other, yeah, we'll give her a hand.
So, other announcements I have are the internal board issues in terms of how we'll run the meeting.
We have Spanish interpreter services available all day today.
We have two public hearings tomorrow.
The proposed formation of a new unified school district from the Huron portion of the Coalinga-Huron Unified School District.
in Fresno, and then a petition for the establishment of a charter school called Sweetwater Secondary School.
There are agenda for the two following items.
These are addendum to our agenda.
These are additions.
Item 3, attachment 4,
Phase 4, public comment report for the draft ESSA state plan.
This outlines all of the outreach and public engagement work that the CDE and the State Board of Education have been doing.
And attachment 6, item 6, I should say, attachment 4, economic and fiscal impact statement for the California Education for a Global Initiative proposed regulations.
That's proposition 58.
We have regular consent items of items 7 to 17.
We'll be taking those up.
We also have proposed waiver consent items W01 through W19.
Any board member wishing to remove items from either of these consent calendars should advise Karen Staff Walters, our Executive Director, by noon today.
Housekeeping announcement.
You have letters from the public on your electronic folder.
There is a full electronic agenda for our meeting and a full print copy in the lobby.
I want to remind the audience that speakers should sign in at a table just outside the room.
Binders are on the table with separate pages for each item number and you need to sign in on the page that identifies the item number on which you wish to speak.
We will allow one minute for all items on the agenda for speakers, both today and tomorrow, except for items one and three, where we will allow a group of five speakers to sign up together and designate one speaker who will be allocated a total of three minutes on behalf of the group.
There'll be a general comment period for items not on our board agenda.
That's item 21 at the end of tomorrow.
If you want to hand things out to the board, provide 25 copies to Amy Bubico, who's sitting in the front there.
When you speak, please introduce yourself and the organization that you represent prior to speaking.
We have additional seating with TV monitors in room 1103 and also in room 1801.
And that's it.
And so I think we're ready now for item 1, which is developing an integrated local, state, and federal accountability and continuous improvement system.
So Cindy Kazanis is here for the department and she will present.
Good morning President Kirsten, Superintendent Torlakson and members of the board.
Cindy Kizana is Director of the Analysis Measurement and Accountability Reporting Division.
This is your standing item for the for the development of the accountability system.
An item that you've heard over the past 16 meetings and so we're building on momentum we've we've had over those meetings.
Today you're going to be asked to to approve two things.
One the suspension of the API and two the expanded definition of alternative schools.
I wanted to touch base briefly on the attachments.
And I'm not going to go to those that you don't have action on in depth, but just wanted to give you a high-level overview of some key points.
So the update on the California School Dashboard, while it was released in March, we still continue to have good usage of the dashboard.
We're continuing to get a lot of hits on the dashboard.
And we currently had inquiries from two other states asking us how we actually set it up and how we paid for it.
And so we're now coming to full circle
getting ready for the operational year of the dashboard, which will happen later this fall.
The focus of the fall dashboard will continue to be on making sure we have the most up-to-date data.
With that in mind, staff are working on processing our discipline files.
So we'll catch up with our years on discipline for the suspension rate.
We also are in the process of developing a report in our student-level data system, CALPADS, which will include the cohort.
So for the first time, districts will be able to see, as they're exiting their students next year at this time, who the students are that are in their cohort.
What this means is we will be able to produce the 2018 graduation rate in 2018, as well as the college career indicator in 2018.
We've typically had a, we've experienced a bit of a delay.
So with this new report and districts being able to see who's actually in the cohort will mean actually a great deal of progress as far as timely data and data reporting in terms of accountability.
Attachment two, we provided you an update on one of our two work groups that we've been staffing for the last couple of months.
This is the college career indicator work group.
And we had originally intended this to be a memo, but we thought it would be important to bring it in as part of the item to show you how important this work is and what progress we are making and what progress we intend to bring you in September.
Keep in mind that September we will bring anything that needs to have action on for the fall dashboard.
You will take those decisions as a whole.
So we intend, as the memo or rather as the attachment said, to add program attributes to allow for consistency and stability over time.
So as opposed to specific programs that would be included in the measures, we're looking at program attributes for the indicator.
We don't intend, just based on lack of data, to add any additional career measures, but we're talking about long-term additions for those.
So we hope to bring in September not only short-term, but long-term recommendations.
And then as far as dashboard reporting for the College Career Indicator, you all are familiar with page seven of attachment to this one pager that tells you if you're prepared or approaching prepared.
For prepared, there are A through E ways of getting to that.
And we hope to, pending staff resources, be able to show you on the dashboard how many of your students reach prepared by those categories.
So we hope that'll add a greater deal of transparency for our schools and districts, as well as the public.
So moving on to the action piece of this item.
At your last meeting, you adopted or rather reaffirmed that the board would add additional schools to the alternative school, what's considered to be alternative school criteria.
So this is the existing criteria that we looked at last meeting and the threshold has been 70% of the school's total enrollment is comprised of these high-risk groups.
You asked us to go back and talk to our task force.
So we had the first meeting of the task force in between our meetings and asked them if these were still the appropriate measures as well as looking at additional measures.
So we had, as you can see, an attachment
Attachment three, the membership of this group is very strong.
In fact, I think some of the letters even commented on the depth of knowledge of the folks on the group.
There are representatives from a lot of the major urban
urban districts as well as rural districts and actually in over representation of charter schools.
So we had a really great meeting.
We're very fortunate to partner with the Gardner Center on this.
They provided us great support and tremendous actually research and just logistics support.
So where we have landed are these seven definitions.
And just to, again, this is expanding the current definition of what the board has determined to be alternative schools, expanding from the 2003 definition, looking at students who are recovered dropouts, students who are credit deficient.
The task force had a very strong opinion that you shouldn't leave students behind.
And so they thought that the one year credit deficiency was too long to wait.
You should look at one semester.
students with a gap in enrollment, students with high level of transiency.
I wanted to comment on this particular one.
We are moving towards student level based reporting in DataQuest.
And what this will allow us to do with forthcoming reports is to actually report on stuff such as transiency.
So we're looking at a mobility report in future development of our DataQuest overhaul.
We also suggest adding foster youth, homeless youth, and emotionally disturbed students.
So there are some of these that we can't tell you how many schools will be added because we actually don't know who the students are that are being enrolled in these schools.
And so just like in May when you adopted that schools would have to reapply every three years, this is upon the school to take action to actually apply to be part of the alternative school system.
They don't automatically get put in there unless
they're actually part of the education code.
So just I want to make sure that you're aware of that nuance.
The last part of this, and this is one piece that we took to your special education advisory committee this past month, and it was about district-run special education schools.
So in education code, it specifies that county-run special education schools are automatically considered alternative schools.
There are, however, 79 district-operated schools.
And what the Commission on Special Education suggested is as opposed to automatically including those 79 schools in as alternative schools, they should also be asked to apply unless they meet a threshold that 70% of their students participate in the California Alternate Assessment.
So this diagram was not in your board item, but I wanted to make sure that you knew what this meant.
So of the 79, 30 of those have students, 70% of their students have taken the California Alternate Assessment.
That represents 22 LEAs.
So with that, this is the recommendation for the item.
I'm going to just skip ahead before you open up for discussion.
And I wanted to just tease you for next month or rather for next meeting, which is we do have a big meeting in September for LCFF and for the dashboard.
So in anticipation of that, we will be providing you a very lengthy memoranda.
in August to talk about the actions that you'll take.
You'll look at the English learner proficiency indicator, the college career indicator.
We have had our first of two discussions with small school representatives looking at how we can make the accountability system more fair to schools that are 250 students or less.
And then we're also looking at the three-year average.
There are a couple of decisions we know we won't be able to bring you in September, because we won't be able to complete the data simulations to inform your decision.
So those will be the academic indicator, along with the California alternate assessment and how to incorporate that into the academic indicator, as well as the chronic absenteeism data.
So it'll be a two-parter as far as making decisions, which is why the dashboard release is currently scheduled for early December.
It's still fall.
So with that I am happy to return it back to you President Kirks for any questions.
Other Board Member questions on this?
Board Member Burr.
Thank you, Cindy.
And just before my questions, again, express my appreciation to you and your entire staff for all of the hard work.
For people who are following along and reading all of this information, you can see how much work is going into this and data simulations.
And I really appreciate the level of transparency that you and Jenny and others are able to bring forward.
So thank you for that.
I just wanted to clarify a little bit about the college and career indicator.
The way I read the attachment, we're struggling a lot around the career questions of, you know, what should count, what shouldn't.
But most of the academic indicators that are in there around AP and the other things that are shown in that table about prepared, well-prepared, approaching prepared are available.
So can you just preview a little bit about what will be in the dashboard for the college and career indicator, meaning I know we'll have the status, right, how that will look, and also just clarify how we will continue to report and what new data will be available about grade 11 SBAC.
Sure, so this past year we didn't have the benefit of having status.
And this year, assuming that you all approve what we recommend or a version of what we recommend in September, you will see status for the first time in the status and change report.
And why this is important is this is the first cohort to have Smarter Balanced scores.
So our grade 11 students have finally graduated and we now have two years of data to use.
So with that, we have one year of data to use.
So with that in mind, we're able to produce a status report.
In addition, we will continue to report out the grade 11 scores, because there has been a strong interest from the field and I think from schools and districts to be transparent about how their students are doing academically in high school.
So that link will be available as well.
And then third, we will, in the detailed reports, which is what we're going to be working on over the next couple of weeks or month or so,
is how to report out how students are prepared.
Right now, what we've done in the detailed reports is just show a bulk number.
So everybody gets put into, this is how many students are prepared at your school.
Now we're able to show you how they met each of those pieces.
It is correct that we are challenged with collecting additional data on the career side, but I know that the group that we've assembled will be meeting this next Monday and hopefully they've got some new ideas or we can balance the discussions we've developed over the last couple of weeks since we last met with them to see if what we've put together will work for future collections.
And then on the other topic about the alternative schools, the listing of categories of students that will be considered for purposes of alternative schools, is there a threshold, for example, for foster youth or homeless youth or
Were we just going to consider if you're serving foster kids, you're going to be in the alternative?
No, that's a good point.
So this still has to meet the same definition as the prior high risk definition, the 70% threshold.
And the 70% threshold, I think you had asked about at last meeting, and we did take that to the task force.
And they at first struggled with it, but then they were very affirmative that this is, it's a privilege to be a part of this system.
These are high stakes,
high stakes, high stakes accountability.
And so, you know, to be to be out of the system and removed from the general accountability system and have these special measures for just your school was a big deal.
So the 70 percent threshold was something that they felt strongly about in the end.
And we are bringing forward these additional categories with that same threshold, with 70 percent of the student population.
So it doesn't necessarily have to be 70 percent of foster youth, it'd be of all students enrolled and how they got in.
Okay, Board Member Holliday.
It's a combination of... You're right.
Yeah, that's just wanted to clarify that.
Also, the Ed Code list of schools that are automatically considered alternative schools, that remains intact.
That remains intact, yes.
And if a school is not one of these schools,
in that list, then they have to apply.
They would have to apply.
And we've had a couple of applications over the last couple of months, and there was a question from one of our stakeholders, do they have to reapply?
And I think if it's a very recent application, we would consider them to have met, assuming they met the criteria.
would automatically consider them as part of an alternative school.
We will be sending out a communication this week, you know, following your decision to all schools in all districts and charter school administrators about the opportunity to apply if they meet this criteria.
That was another question.
You've got the PR approach in mind for it, right?
We definitely do, and we will be contacting anybody who has applied in the past and was either, whether it became an alternative school or for whatever reason was denied, we would contact them as well, especially.
And the schools that don't fit under the Ed Code list that have to apply, it doesn't matter whether they are district schools or whether they're charter schools or whether
That's correct.
It does not matter who runs the school, but there is a process in which you need to self-identify that you've met and that there has been, you know, certain approvals been made at the administrative level.
Thank you.
Member Philippe.
Ortiz-Lacon.
Thank you.
When it comes to the alternative accountability system, I definitely understand the need for it, but I also want us to be mindful as we implement.
If we start seeing that enrollment rates for 11th and 12th graders in the alternative system, I think that should give us, we should question why that's happening and why those particular grades.
It seems like the studies show that that is really where we're capturing students is that they're transferring to alternative in 11th and 12th grade.
So we want to be mindful of that.
In terms of the college career readiness indicator, one of the things that I still haven't seen is the number of students participating in AP courses.
Not only who's passing the AP exam, but who's participating.
And I think that speaks to access.
And we really should be mindful of who has access to these AP courses, who is enrolling in AP courses.
And I'm sure there's going to be some disparities that we would need to consider.
In terms of the data dashboard, I appreciate that we're considering the feedback of stakeholders and improving the functionality and in particular that we're improving the translation for Spanish.
But I also inquired about revamping the equity report display so that it really speaks to
equity, and I think that every single one of those tabs, the goal should be to align it to its purpose, right?
So, for equity, the goal was to align it so that folks knew who is not, where are the achievement gaps, who's not at the same level as the all groups category.
And that's still being lost a little bit in the current display.
So, I'm not sure if there's any plans to revamp that particular page.
Is there?
So we are taking forward these next couple of weeks some mock-ups, but I think what we've indicated in the item, as well as the attachment, that we want to make sure there's some stability in the system.
So I don't anticipate wholesale changes to the equity report.
There may be some nuanced changes.
I remember Holidays asked a couple of times about moving the narrative up to the top, so we want to make sure that we take that to the field and see what that looks like.
But there's been a lot of training materials produced and some in progress, and so we want to make sure that there's some stability in the dashboard as we go fully operational this fall, at least for the next year.
So I think as we keep getting out in the field and talking to
to parents and to teachers, and I know CCEE is anticipating doing a really strong outreach to parents on the dashboard in the fall, that we can, some of those things we need to make sure that we've bookmarked so when we're ready for a revamp in 2018 that we have the list ready to go.
But I think wholesale, you will see a lot of similarities as we currently have, especially for that landing page.
And then I just wanted to make sure that I represent this correctly.
We are not developing an alternative schools accountability system.
It is integrated in the dashboard, is integrated in our current system.
We will develop indicators that are appropriate for alternative schools, but it's not a separate system.
Yeah, I just wanted to comment on the AP comment that the board member McCollum made.
I wrote an article in EdSource about three years ago and we're working on a new one.
which on the AP performance of California students, it's really quite impressive and it gets no general media.
We're now fifth in the nation in the percentage passing with three or more and our Hispanics were third in the nation.
in terms of the percentage passing with three or more.
And our rates of taking AP are going up very rapidly.
So I think this is something that flies under the radar.
And so I think that the dashboard will enhance this and draw more attention to this.
It's really quite interesting how we're doing in that regard.
So that's a comment.
Yes.
Yeah.
So, I don't know if you looked by district or if it was statewide, but... I looked statewide.
I only have statewide numbers.
Okay.
So if, my concern would be, yes, of the people that are taking, the students that are taking the AP, maybe Latinos are surfacing and you said the third largest.
They are going up, yes.
But if we have a district with 75% Latino students, I'm wondering what percent of those students are taking AP because then we're filtering down to a percentage.
So from that percent, some of them or the majority may be passing.
But if that percent of participation is only 15% and you have a population of 75%, that's an issue.
And so I would want to see what percent are participating and then from the participants, what percent are actually passing.
Yeah, and we don't want to get into this now, but you will be able to, you have, I know you've been working with district data on AP.
We have student level data on AP, but I think what student level data, but I think what member Ortiz-Lacon is asking is, if I understand you correctly, is to make a crosswalk of those that are actually enrolled and complete the courses, whether or not they're passing the exams.
No.
I want to know how many are participating, how many have access to the actual courses.
And then from those, then we want to filter more and see how many of them are passing.
Yeah.
So that would be the numbers, that total numbers taking the courses was what you're interested in as well.
Yes.
Okay.
Board member Rucker was next.
Well, good morning.
And I also want to add my commendations to the work that clearly is going on to develop and continue to mature the accountability system.
But I also do have some questions and some concerns.
My concerns really revolve around the issue of granularity, but also on I'm falling in love with this word since it's been added to the Oxford English Dictionary, woke.
I think that we need to be aware of when we look at disproportionality, it's not just an issue that's related to special education.
So when we look at the college and career indicator, I understand we're still struggling with the career indicators, but let me suggest we're also still struggling in some ways to understand the academic portion of the indicator as well.
because it's not just the AP courses that are being considered and represented, but for students that are going to dual enrollment programs, the indicator still has not caught up with the variety of types of dual enrollment options that students have.
The focus on dual enrollment seems to still be on students who are enrolled in dual enrollment courses for academic pursuits, but there are options now that students have for dual enrollment
that are directly related to college and career readiness as well.
There are also options that are included for early college programs that are not because they have different titles or different names across the LEAs and there are different partnerships between many LEAs and community colleges that indicators doesn't quite take in that level of diversity because it's still not drilling down in a level of granularity that would show or share that.
The reason why that becomes important is because with each of the different diverse types of options for that dual enrollment, there's a greater diversity of students who have access to and are able to participate in those programs.
And that's not being really well reflected in this indicator.
So that's my first concern.
And then when we get to the other half of the indicator looking at career,
I'm really impressed with California.
I'm always impressed by the fact that this is a state where the law of large numbers makes us look really impressive.
So I'm impressed by the thousands of courses that have been identified that would fall into the indicator.
What doesn't impress me, however, is nobody knows what that means.
And so, because we don't really understand what that means, nobody knows how to disaggregate that information, how to look at the level of granularity on that information to distinguish
whether those courses are being classified as an academic course, if they're being classified to a particular industry sector, if they are different as an introductory course, if they are part of a sequence of four courses that lead to some type of prerequisite certification, that's not really made clear.
And but the fact of the matter is while we may say at this level in the atmosphere that we don't know what that information is, the districts that are reporting those classes or that place those classes on their master schedule do know.
And I don't believe it takes another category in CALPADS for us to figure that out.
I think there are ways to identify what's already in CALPADS to do this.
And the reason I'm suggesting that
and I'm surprised I'm about to say this, the University of California somehow is able to figure this out.
And so I suggest that we look at what other entities are doing to help them do this analysis in a way that we seem not to be able to do.
The University of California not only has figured this out, but through the Office of the President, they are even working directly with those school districts to help them
make sure they're appropriately classifying and identifying their courses, not only to meet the A to G, but to make sure that there are clear linkages among each of the post-secondary segments.
So I think that there's work that can be done that will address some of the issues that are clearly identified in the item that's causing a struggle on the CCI.
But I think that
Well, I'm glad to know we have thousands of courses that are out there because that does suggest there's a great amount of access and a greater level of awareness about college and career readiness.
What it doesn't say or what it actually highlights more to the point is we don't know how to explain what all those numbers actually mean.
And so as the work continues to mature the indicator and when you come back to talk to us in September, even when you develop the memo,
One of the things that I would really like to ask you to do is to help us understand how the system will mature to take those on.
There needs to—the discomfort, I believe, that I'm feeling, and I'm hoping I'm mirroring or reflecting what others would feel, is the sense that we don't know what we're doing still on this.
and we are getting into the point where this dashboard now becomes a part not only of important planning in the LCFF, but at some point becomes an accountability tool.
And I'm being careful to say tool, not weapon.
But if we're not careful on how we quantify this information and how the analysis, how districts are guided to use this information, particularly high schools, looking at this indicator, we are going to miss
not only the performance of students, but we are going to miss the kind of reporting about the work that students are doing as they leave high school that is important for doing planning.
Because even though we are doing these cohort, the cohort graduation rate, which is a separate but connected indicator to this, the fact is the planning that leads to improving the graduation rate begins before these students become a part of that cohort.
So I guess my point is on the college and career indicator, other schools other than high schools are the ones who will be better informed about what the indicator says because they're the ones doing the prerequisite work that informs what high schools can actually provide as a deliverable that's directly related to this indicator.
And I think that part of the system is not clearly as well spelled out or articulated.
And I'll stop on my comments on that.
Do you want to respond?
One thing I wanted to respond to, we did have a separate conversation about this with member Rucker, and this is very helpful as well.
We are engaged with, or we have a joint grant from IES, from the U.S.
Department of the Federal Government with McCall Kurlanders from UC Davis, and Professor Kurlander does have some
graduate students this summer looking at the course issues.
So while I think it's a bit dismal in our report and the item about we have all these courses, there's no consistency.
The state has not, we talked about this back in a memo to you in December of this last year about the challenges with courses.
and cataloging those.
We are doing a roadshow.
We have been doing this roadshow now, I think, for the last couple of months between our program office and the CALPADS office on how to better submit data on CTE specifically.
So, you know, we are trying to do the best we can with the resources we have, but that said, we are expanding our resources by leveraging things like, you know, the IES grant that we were so fortunate to get, which is a five-year grant, and we're just finishing up year one.
I do see a lot of promise with that and if we can incorporate any of their findings for the September item, we will try to do that.
If it's not in the item, we'll do it verbally.
But Professor Kurlander is on our task force as well for the College Career Indicator.
Yeah, that's why I made that comment because I thought it was really important for you to explain that.
Thank you.
No, it's a good reminder and we need to talk more about that in the future.
These kinds of partnerships are really invaluable.
Yeah, the IES is the Institute for Educational Sciences of the U.S.
Department of Education.
It's their research arm for those.
Board member Strauss.
So I wanted to continue the conversation on college and career before we go to public comments.
And first, thank you and the work group that's working so hard on this complicated issue.
I believe that the components of the college career and the issue of being approaching prepared or prepared
or well-prepared are really important.
And what we know about our work with API is as we've added indicators, it's actually helped to cause districts and schools to do things like add science in ninth grade because there was a consequence if you didn't or put students in algebra.
And so the things that we pay attention to in college career are really important.
And what we know about high schools, they're really complicated places and the trajectory for kids over a four-year period is, has lots of, it's an interesting ride.
And there are lots of issues, as Member Ortiz-Lincoe brought up, where students start to get in real credit trouble by the end of 10th grade.
So when you get to 11th grade, the kids that are in credit trouble often
are looking to continuation and alternative ed programs.
We also know that the issue of counseling advisement for AP access is really critical.
And I actually would like some time spent down the road on advising and working with counselors to help understand the philosophy of helping kids have options, not closing off options.
But the concern I have on the college and career is I understand the challenges on career tech and I really appreciate the work that you're doing with that.
But the components of the College and Career Indicator together are going to give us a College and Career Indicator rating.
But within it, I think we have to look down the line and I'd be interested if the work group is going to look at this as to whether we might want to in some of our revisions, think about pulling out some of that data so it's a little bit easier for people to see.
So the access issue of access to rigorous coursework,
the issue of dual enrollment that member Rucker brought up.
All the different components which are giving us a compilation of a single score are one measure.
But individually, there are other issues.
I know you're going to be working on a high school readiness issue coming up that's down the line in a project.
So I just wonder if there's any consideration and I guess I'd like to put on the table that in potential revisions coming up, as we've said, this is not in cement.
We're going to continue to work on the process.
I think it might be more helpful to think down the line about a college and career indicator about a student being prepared or well prepared, but also pulling out some of the data so that schools and stakeholders can use some of that to help inform practice.
So I wonder if we're thinking down the line about pulling any of those things out as
And again, not for a hammer or a weapon, but more for informing practice so that it's, you get the compilation of a rating, but you also get some issues of, oh, my goodness.
Because getting kids access to A to G, just saying that that's important, high schools are starting to create different pathways for students.
They're starting to drop non-college prep.
There's definitely, just like we did when we put students in science in ninth grade, as a result of saying that was a priority, the access to A to G is now raising the awareness for schools to increase that.
So I guess my point is, I think this is really important.
I think high schools are so complex that I'm wondering whether we're thinking about pulling any of the pieces out in the long run to help inform and share the information.
We will definitely add that to our list of things to keep looking at over the next couple of years.
Right now we are, I think as you've pointed out, we're focused on completion.
And in order to move to access and enrollment, it's a different conversation.
We would be different approach and we definitely can definitely look into that.
But also to your point, the accountability systems do change behavior and we're very cognizant of that.
We want to be cautious with how we proceed with that.
So we want to make sure we did the right level of stakeholder input and we definitely would involve our technical design group to advise on the technical aspects of how we would include that into the indicator as well.
But your points are well taken.
Thank you.
Board Member Sun.
So along the lines of the maturity of our indices and as we're developing and looking at this as well, I think somewhat to what Member Stroud was talking about, as we put more components into these indices and sometimes they can also wash
each other out as well.
So this idea of getting a holistic picture and then balancing it with what are some of the specifics.
And as we continue to develop, I don't think we should be closed to the idea of perhaps maybe we need to continue to tweak or prioritize or weigh.
I just don't want us to close ourselves from thinking about those as this system matures.
Board Member Holliday.
And to your last point about being careful to not influence decisions inappropriately.
In terms of access to AP, it's wonderful the numbers, the high statistics, but for many families dual enrollment is
a much more beneficial route for their child.
In my experience in schools is that children of families whose parents went to college, the AP is very much within their philosophy and their thinking, but for a lot of families,
whose parents were not in post-secondary education, dual enrollment makes a lot of sense in their way of thinking and in my way of thinking as well.
And we have to be careful about stressing AP when it could disadvantage students who really would benefit from dual enrollment in really important ways.
So good you're thinking about all that.
Thank you.
The other point I wanted to ask about was
back to the alternative schools.
The work on the indicators for alternative schools has begun.
It has begun.
And is it with the same task force?
Same group.
Right.
And I'm sure they're much smarter about this than I am, but my
experiences that change is the factor that has to be most prominent.
Growth, improvement or lack of improvement.
That is the key to, you know, wherever they are, how well are they progressing?
And I assume that that will be a strong part of their putting this together, right?
Thanks.
Board Member Sandoval.
Just to the alternative schools, thank you for all the work and the task force too.
I think that the proposed additions to the high-risk definitions make good sense.
They reflect clear thinking, responsiveness to the stakeholders, and I'm glad that at the Advisory Commission on Special Education there was time devoted to this because I feel that the commissioners made really good recommendations.
And I want to thank you for incorporating those recommendations and showing us the number of LEAs who are automatically part of that group.
And I also want to acknowledge the point that you made that this is one accountability system.
And we don't want to be confused about having a separate system for alternative schools.
So just I wanted to commend the task force and the work that you've done in this division in moving this forward.
Okay, public comment, but one more.
Member Burke.
And I hope this is an easy fix, Cindy.
So that's what I'm looking for.
In the college and career indicator, when I look at, you know, all of the different categories, I think just to this conversation about whether or not it's useful at the LEA level or especially at the school level.
Well, is there a detailed report or will there be a detailed report that says this is how many students meet this particular category?
Yes, that is our... Because I wonder if that kind of addresses member Strauss.
I just want to be clear that we always have these kind of high level things where people and we hope will be helpful to the public, helpful to parents, etc.
But for purposes of LEA planning and understanding what's there.
First of all, they're the ones reporting the data.
So they have it.
But secondly, that we're then turning back around and saying, yeah, here's a detailed report.
It's important for you to know what happened in this year with your students, what happened in the subsequent years.
Yes, I think this indicator is very different than all the rest of the indicators in that there are several components to it.
And so this is the feedback to your point that we've received is it would be helpful to see who makes this up.
So that is our intent.
Again, staffing and resources willing that we can put this out for the fall release.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacon.
I just need to ask a clarifying question because we, you know, I've heard it twice.
This is one accountability system for alternative youth and for our students.
But are we saying, because if it was one, we wouldn't be having subsequent meetings about what indicators that would be.
But what I'm hearing is that we want it to be one coherent system so that the indicators we identify will align with the state indicators that we have.
But it is one in the same way that we have LCFF and ESSA misalignment and now we're also going to incorporate alternative indicators for alternative youth that meet the criteria.
So it's one in the sense that it's all going to be in the same dashboard.
But it's not one in the sense that they will be meeting the same
state goals and the same indicators as the one that we're currently adopting.
Is that correct?
I want to make sure that we're having a very transparent conversation and what we mean by one system for alternative or high-risk youth.
I think what we see the dashboard as being is the major component of the accountability system.
It's our accountability toolkit.
And so this is going to be part of that toolkit.
I'm not going to have a separate toolkit for just alternative schools.
You will see this all in the same location.
The one dashboard.
Yes.
That's what we mean by one accountability system.
Thanks.
Okay.
I think we're ready for the public comment.
Would the following people please line up?
Diana Cruz, Hector Castaneda, Jordi McCorpuz, Zekia Armstrong, Doug McCray, Carrie Mazzoni, Sasha Horwitz, Roberto Viramontes, Diane Georgian, Liz Guillen, Mary Lee, Colin Miller, Martha Alvarez, Ralph Porras, Lisa Morris, and Kristi Sinclair.
Thank you Mr. President, Superintendent, and members.
Carrie Mazzoni for Opportunities for Learning.
We are in great support of the new criteria for alternative schools and we've been part of a group that has been working on this.
We want to thank the department for their serious consideration of our recommendations and we hope that you concur with the department.
Thank you.
Good morning.
I'm Diane Groucho.
I'm with the Coalition for Alternative Education Accountability.
And primarily, I just want to applaud the Department of Education, Cindy and Jenny, who just worked on this whole revision and the alternative county piece for an awful long time.
And we also want to say that we are in total support of the revisions as they say, as they propose.
So thank you very much.
Good morning.
I'm Doug McRae, retired measurement specialist from NRA.
For the June memo on growth model plans referenced in this item, I included a number of detailed observations and materials submitted to your electronic folder.
Briefly summarize, simple absolute growth models are often better than complex growth models like the relative or projected models, both for communication reasons and avoiding technical problems generated by that additional complexity.
However, accountability use requires separating elementary from middle from high schools for growth model data.
For all growth models, beware of the effects of mobility that can eliminate too many student scores from the analyses, particularly for underserved students like English learners and low wealth students, thus generating unsatisfactory results.
The material in the electronic folder also contains alternative simulations to further investigate appropriate growth models for California.
Thank you.
President Kersten, members, I'm Sasha Horwitz with the Link Learning Alliance.
As the board and CDE have developed out the college career indicator, we've been insistent that it should include a well-prepared tier that integrates college and career measures.
We appreciate the department's cautiousness in making sure that all the tiers are meaningful and reflective of actual measures of readiness, but we don't want the perfect to be the enemy of the good.
As board member Rucker said, we all recognize that academic indicators are not perfect, but that hasn't kept us from using them.
And since the dashboard is designed to capture status and change and also to make that information publicly available, we think it's important that schools have the information they need to make decisions based on that information.
And as board member Strauss said, this would incentivize schools to offer courses that prepare students for college and career.
Thank you.
Good morning, board members.
My name is Mary Lee, and I'm a parent ambassador with Families in Schools.
And I wanted to address the alternative schools, the indicator that you were speaking on.
And I did agree with several points that I heard board member Ortiz-Licón and also board member Rucker.
The information as we as parents have been able to follow from the task force and the commissions do not appear to really clearly address, to be able to be clear that our students will be able to fully access a truly equitable educational
system that will give them the career readiness that the traditional or A through G system will be.
And right now, we're really trying to hear how this information will be really clear for families and to be engaged in.
Good morning, Roberto Vera Montes with the Learning Policy Institute.
We thank the State Board and CDE for the creation of the College and Career Indicator Workgroup.
The workgroup will serve as the key anchor toward developing and enhancing a comprehensive system that measures college and career preparation among California's high schools.
We look forward to engaging with staff and other stakeholders on the refinement of the College and Career Indicator, including the addition of more robust career indicators and the inclusion of the well-prepared category.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Diana Cruz.
I'm a senior from Long Beach and a leader from California for Justice.
I started this about a year ago when students urged you to make school climate a priority and I shared my struggles as a former foster youth and my school climate was critical to not just keeping me in school but helping me achieve honor roll every year since.
And although I'm proud of the progress we've made together to help make LCFF help all students, more needs to be done, specifically with school climate surveys because they're about two things our state says that they value, equity and student voice.
A healthy and positive climate is the foundation to achieving equity in our education system and tools like climate surveys allow students and others to have a voice.
I'm here to ask the State Board to dedicate more time to discuss and support school climate surveys to ensure they are a robust and powerful tool for continuous improvement.
Keep your promise to students to make school climate a priority in California.
Hello, my name is Hector Castaneda and I'm a recent San Jose graduate and a leader with Californians for Justice.
Ever since you included suspensions and chronic absenteeism in the dashboard, we're seeing real impacts in our schools.
Our district created new LCAP goals to align with the five state indicators to prioritize school climate and engagement.
In the goal to decrease suspensions, it states that they want to establish and sustain healthy school cultures through relationship-centered practices.
In our LCAP meetings, district staff are now saying that improving school climate is key to decreasing suspensions.
This was possible because you listened to us, and there's still a lot more that needs to be done.
We know showing up to school is not enough for us to achieve as students, so I ask you all, is this the best that we can do?
If the State Board gives more attention and support on school climate surveys, more will be possible to make all schools relationship-centered schools.
Keep your promise to students to value their voices and make school climate a priority.
Thank you.
Hello State Board of Education.
My name is Zakiya Armstrong and I'm a recent graduate of Oakland High School and a leader with Californians for Justice.
Throughout my time in high school I had the privilege of having teachers who really cared about me and the well-being of my classmates.
My teachers will have one-on-one time and with each and every one of us inside and outside of class.
And if any student was really struggling, they make sure to adjust their teaching and give that special attention and even engage our families for support.
Just this year, I was struggling with my senior project, which determines whether I graduate or not.
I was having major anxiety about the SJ portion and started to think I was going to fail and wanted to give up.
But my teacher, Mr. Tucker, saw me in distress with one conversation, helped me become calmed and focused.
Thanks to him, I was able to pass my project and graduate.
I was fortunate to have a connection with an adult and knew they weren't going to give up on me.
However, this wasn't the case at Oakland High School four years ago.
In 2013, about 50% of students didn't feel safe at Oakland High School, and 77% of African American students were being suspended.
But my school transformed because of four years ago, school leadership and staff prioritized collecting, studying school climate and engagement data, especially those of African-American students.
When my school looks at student achievement, they look at suspensions and chronic absenteeism rates for African-American and Latino students.
And they don't stop there.
One of the biggest indicators is how students answer the California Healthy Kids Survey question.
At my school, there is a teacher or some other adult who really cares about me.
Because of school climate survey data, for the next three years, Oakland High is increasing the number of meaningful relationships with students by training all teachers in restorative justice.
Because of this aggregated school climate survey data African-American students like me are getting the attention and support we need to succeed.
I want this for all schools in California.
And I'm here to ask you to make that happen.
Having this data made a difference in my education.
This can't and won't happen without more attention from the state board.
Let's not miss this opportunity to value students voices and advance equity.
I mean equity.
We are counting on you.
I'd like to call the next group of speakers, please, who weren't previously called, Jason Henderson, Giselle Favaros, Angelita Ramos, Eric Premack, Ernie Silva, and the two groups of speakers from Pico, California.
Hello, my name is Jordy May Corpus and I'm a staff with Californians for Justice.
As you heard from our students, prioritizing school climate has already had a positive impact.
But like Hector said, this is not the best we can do.
School climate surveys directly capture the voices of students and can be robust tools for continuous improvement if the state does more.
This is why we urge you to support the School Conditions and Climate Work Group's recommendations, especially administering an annual survey to have yearly comparisons and timely data, disaggregation of data by student subgroups to ensure equity, school-level survey results so they can be used in planning and decision-making processes, and survey constructs of safety, connectedness, and school conditions to ensure alignment with LCAP priorities and metrics.
Also, we urge more support and resources for implementation.
It's critical that you all play a stronger leadership role to ensure high reporting of data by districts.
Ways the board can do that are addressed in our letter.
And we believe these recommendations will fulfill your promise to make school climate a priority in California.
So let's continue to lead together to improve student success.
Thank you.
Good morning, Martha Alvarez on behalf of AXA, the Association of California School Administrators.
I'll be brief since I have a supporting tenant who will be speaking for us with more comments.
But on behalf of AXA, we are pleased to support the staff recommendation on the alternative schools eligibility criteria.
We commend the different working groups providing feedback on these measures.
We think it's very robust, so we'd like to support that recommendation.
On the dashboard, we concur with the CDE staff's suggestion to hold off on any major changes to the dashboard until fall of 2018.
We saw with the LCAP, we had three different LCAP templates approved by this board.
It caused a lot of confusion at the local level.
It required a lot of training for administrators, so we encourage the CDE and board to continue on that path of making major changes until fall of 2018.
And lastly, on the college and career indicator, we concur with the board comments regarding the importance of ensuring it's a robust metric, a robust composite.
We look forward to reviewing the CCI working group recommendations, specifically the three-year plan, and we look forward to being part of this work.
Thank you.
Good morning, board members.
My name is Ralph Gomez-Porras.
I'm the superintendent for Pacific Grove Unified School District.
AXA's state president, past, and 26-year veteran bilingual educator.
I currently serve as the association's accountability task force chair, and I am pleased to be here on behalf of that task force serving more than 18,000 administrators from across the state.
We extend our deep appreciation to the State Board and the CDE staff for your continued efforts and commitment to improve the first phase of the new accountability system and thinking how we make this a successful system to support students in need.
We are indeed grateful for the many opportunities afforded to the administrators and other stakeholders to provide input.
During my time as the AXA president, I toured the state to meet with dozens of schools and district leaders and learn more about their local initiatives centered on equity and the goal of closing the achievement gaps.
Administrators firmly believe the support and opportunities presented by the multiple measures system and continue to support that in the service of the whole child.
We understand this is an evolving system and the state board is committed to making improvements over time.
Because September of each year will be an important time when the State Board will consider making updates to the accountability system and the dashboard, we urge you and the CDE to consider how each of the proposed changes interact with the other parts of the accountability system.
It is critically important that you take a comprehensive view on all of the changes that are being proposed and ultimately pursued instead of adopting them in isolation.
Without regard for the increased workload, it may result on individual districts and school sites.
ACSA continues to support a single coherent accountability system.
Regarding the California dashboard, overall, there's been a very positive feedback from the field with our initial interaction with the dashboard.
In my own experience in Monterey, using the data as part of this year's LCAP stakeholder engagement process, my district took the opportunity to educate parents and most importantly, students and other stakeholders about the key components of the dashboard, such as what the color coding mean and how the student groups that need additional supports and attention are evaluated.
Most importantly, of course, is how the system will be used to improve instruction to meet the needs of our most needy students.
While there are improvements that can be made to the dashboard, we support the proposed approach to focus modifications for the dashboard on functionality issues.
Regarding school conditions and climate, we strongly support the inclusion of school climate measures as local indicators informing the accountability system because we understand the tremendous value in ensuring students, parents, and staff feel welcome in a safe school environment.
In particular, Monterey County, we're working on cybersecurity and measures to counter cyberbullying and its insidious contribution to depression and suicide.
These indicators will give us the information we need.
As was articulated in AX's comment letter, we'd like to share preliminary concerns of administrators across the state regarding the school conditions and climate work group draft recommendations.
We believe the administration of annual surveys will come at a cost to conduct the surveys and other resources needed.
As part of the feedback we have collected from administrators, the consensus that the survey needs to remain a requirement for alternate years and that the use of a qualitative tool should be used locally to get input.
And by using alternate years, we'll allow time for progress programs and policies and practices in place to see positive progress.
Thank you very much for your time.
AXA stands in support of the State Board of Education.
Good morning, President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board, LeAngela Reed on behalf of the Small School Districts Association.
I just want to take a moment to kind of to thank SBE and CDE staff for the tremendous outreach to Smalls and the request for feedback relative to end size and suspension rates and the conversations that are going.
Our members feel very much a part of the process.
They feel that they are making a contribution and that they own this new accountability system because of the outreach that's occurring.
And it doesn't always happen.
We often talk about equity areas, but we don't often talk about equity relative to school districts or rural and so forth.
And so to have that conversation is tremendous.
And it helps us to move this dashboard forward.
And to that point, I just ask you, you know, we like in our accountability system to sort of finishing a house.
We're now down to the drapes and the carpet and the furniture.
And those are things that are the least important in some ways and the most important in others.
And that always take the longest.
But we have to continue to move forward and finish the house.
Thank you.
Good morning, Samantha Tran with Children Now.
I wanted to build on the comment that board member Ortiz-Lacon made regarding alternative ed.
We really appreciate the work that's being done to think about different indicators that are more appropriate in that setting, especially given the highly mobile nature of those students.
The one piece that we again lift up for the board's consideration that's aligned with current law and also recommendations by the LAO and PPIC is to think about how alternative education students are reflected in the dashboard related to LEAs, school districts, and county offices.
The schools themselves are unique and we need to be thoughtful about those indicators, but the overall
you know, indicators as it relates to graduation rate, assessment scores, chronic absenteeism, suspension, they're still part of the district.
And so right now they're invisible in the system because we've not only taken them out of the school system, but we've taken them out of the LEAs.
So having that policy conversation we think is really important and we hope the board will bring that to the table soon so that we can have that discussion.
Thank you so much.
Good morning, Sarah Lillis with EdVoice.
I first want to align myself with Ms.
Tran's comments about making sure that students in alternative schools are reflected in LEAs.
But beyond that, we're very eager for the September board meeting.
We recognize how important this first rollout is of actually implementing and utilizing the dashboard in local and state accountability.
To that point, we're concerned about things that are being deferred.
I understand stability is important to LEAs.
At the same time,
board members and stakeholders have raised issues for the last several years that have not been addressed that are fundamental to this accountability system reflecting the goals of LCFF and a unified accountability system.
So we would urge if it's about the equity report reflecting what we wanted to reflect or capturing interim and long-term goals in the dashboard itself, if it's not to be addressed in September in this first round, at the very least, we would encourage the board to direct staff to integrate a plan, a concrete plan for when those things will be reflected in the accountability system
and build it into the timeline.
So we would urge you to address some of those key issues now and not wait.
Thanks.
Hi, Brian Lee on behalf of Fight Crime Invest in Kids, Ready Nation, and Mission Readiness.
In this agenda item on updating the dashboard and continuing development of the rubrics, I worry that we're missing a robust discussion on data that's buried into item three, and it's how is the dashboard doing?
As you probably saw on there, of 181 districts identified through our LCFF system, two-thirds are just based on special need populations alone, just on disabled students.
On the other hand, for the LCFF targeted students, which is low-income students and English learners, at most 37 districts are targeted.
Is that working?
Is that getting at the goals that we really want?
And I also put to you, is this a problem with LCFF or is it an issue that the board can reckon with?
Certainly, LCFF put forward a framework for identifying schools in need.
However, the board has made two important decisions.
They've decided that what's in the statute that says failure to improve across two priorities means two reds.
And then it's decided what a red means.
So as you look at that, I think we might want to consider reconsidering all of that so we make sure that we're really identifying the student schools we want to and districts we want to identify.
Thank you.
Good morning, Liz Guillen with Public Advocates.
You should have the coalition, LCFF Equity Coalition letter in your electronic file.
I would like to echo the observation by Member Burr that a lot, a lot of work has been happening.
and the level of transparency that we've seen around the kind of information we only dreamed of years ago, we're able to wrap our hands around, which is really great.
I also, though, want to echo our CFJ student partners, and that is that we think we can do better, and we want to help us all do better.
And in that vein, I want to point out that the indicator for the state priorities, state priority around broad course access is one that we hope you will put back on the radar as part of a longer term work plan, since we know we're not getting to it in September, which is disappointing.
And we know that board members have spoken about the importance of identifying access to core courses like life science, social studies, art, music, PE.
And we think this is very important as part of the planning that begins well before high school.
Thank you.
Good morning, Colin Miller with the California Charter Schools Association.
We do want to just support moving forward on the ASAM criteria at this meeting.
We know there's a time crunch in terms of getting those schools identified for the dashboard in the fall.
But we do note that these are new criteria, particularly moving from one year to six months and the transiency data.
And as Cindy noted, we just don't have the data to know, you know, which schools are going to be applying and eligible under this criteria.
So we would request that you, as part of your action, have this come back to the board once you have that data to make sure that you've got it right, that you're not over-identifying schools or under-identifying schools that truly are intended to be alternative.
So we would recommend that you do that.
Also, as we move forward to looking at the criteria and the metrics, I would remind you that you do have a Charter School Advisory Commission.
We do appreciate that there are charter school participants on the
the ASAM committee, but we also urge you to use your own charter school advisor commission to vet some of these issues as they're moving forward, these big policy issues on charter schools.
Thank you.
Hi, I'm Angela DeRamos.
I'm here on behalf of California Teachers Association.
I'm also a fifth grade teacher.
The holistic multidimensional accountability system is a much needed change from the single number system of the previous years.
Throughout the development of the rubric and dashboard, we have consistently raised concerns about local indicators being relegated to second tier status.
We know recent reports are that very few local agencies have implemented local indicators.
In my own district, the push by admin is still very much on test scores.
We are suspending API, but old habits die hard.
We see resources already being allocated towards test prep on a test that's supposedly designed to avoid teaching to the test.
The timeline in attachment five speaks to a communication phase for local indicators, but much more is needed.
We urge the board to direct staff to develop options that would incentivize LEAs to implement the local indicators beyond the not met for two years provision.
The holistic indicators need to be meaningfully implemented and prioritized to highlight and measure what actually matters.
Student outcomes and the conditions of learning that form the foundation of an equitable educational opportunity.
We look forward to seeing greater urgency
in pursuit of this goal.
Thank you.
Good morning, board members.
I'm Ernie Silva with Sciatech.
We're, as you know by now, a network of dropout recovery high schools.
I want to just publicly thank the board and the staff for including us in the task force that's doing really important work.
And I want to respond to board member Ortiz-Lacombe's issues of
the appropriateness of including alternative metrics.
For us, we believe that equity demands that separate measures be included in the system.
Otherwise, our students fall through the cracks.
We also want to recognize the responsibility of schools and LEAs for serving the student population that we serve.
And what our school has done in moving forward is we've adopted an A through G pathway for our very low-income former dropouts so that students have access not just to career development and community college, but to four-year universities as well.
Thank you.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center, in very strong support of the revised exam criteria.
These discussions we've been having with the department staff, and I thank them very deeply.
They've met with us probably 20 times over the last five years.
These concerns go way back before the dashboard, and they've been doing a lot of work on this.
And we think the recommendations reflect a lot of thought beyond what they related to you today.
So we support them very much.
Like many of you, we continue to be concerned about kind of the data limitation tail wagging the CCI dog.
And I've long believed that we should have a process whereby individual schools or districts can come forward with a proposed CCI definition, if you will, that would meet the standard that doesn't happen to fit into the standard state definitions box and would hope that you would consider that.
Thank you.
That concludes the public comments.
So now we're ready for board member comments or a motion, whatever the board prefers.
Board member Burr.
Well, I'm prepared to make the motion to adopt the staff recommendation.
But I do have, I want to make one clarifying question.
I think it goes to this issue of one accountability system or and I would encourage our friends in who have pushed for this.
to stop using the acronym ASAM because that was a separate accountability system.
So just a friendly suggestion.
But what we're talking about now really is how do you identify schools, schools that are serving these populations that really are very challenged populations.
And we need to have metrics that reflect that, that was spoken eloquently.
But what we haven't talked about, and I just want to clarify this, is sort of the so what question.
When we identify the metrics and we say this is appropriate, you know, whether to your point, Member Holiday, it's a growth metric of how many additional credits have they gained or, you know, did they graduate within one year or whatever it happens to be.
I assume that that data is also going to be reported just like everything else in the dashboard by subgroups and that the statute that says if you're not successful with your subgroups on those metrics that we determine, then there are consequences.
There's additional technical assistance.
There's potentially intervention.
So I just wanted to ask that question because I think that's the piece we're kind of missing, that we will be treating them the same way for purposes of identifying schools that are in need of additional support.
That's correct.
And just a clarification on my point too, I think
in that same regard, so they will have a graduation rate indicator.
They will have a suspension rate indicator.
There may be metrics that are different, for example, that you use for graduation rate.
Maybe it's not a four-year, maybe it's a one-year, but that is the intent with the alternative schools indicator.
The other piece I wanted to make sure that everybody was aware of is these schools will count towards the LEA as well.
We are not going to keep them from rolling up to the LEA.
The LEA will have consequences, as you mentioned,
if they don't perform the student subgroups or the student groups that are identified under LCFF if they're not performing the same consequences as they would as a traditional school.
Okay, thank you.
So I will make the motion, but I think we still have... Yes, we have to reopen public comment.
Some of our people that wanted to speak were in an overflow room and could not get into the main room.
So we're now... Call the list, please.
The speakers are from PICO, California.
My name is Sena Flores.
I'm a parent and organizer with our PICO affiliate here in Sacramento, Sacramento Act.
Good morning, board members.
My name is Maria Ruiz.
I'm a parent leader from Los Angeles.
I'm happy to be here.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Lisa Thornton.
I'm an organizer with LA Voice, PICO Federation in Los Angeles.
Good morning, board members.
My name is Katie Nunez-Adler, and I'm with the PICO Federation in Oakland.
I'm a parent and a community organizer.
Hello, my name is Daniel.
I'm a student in Merced City School.
Good morning.
My name is Andre Spearman, and I'm a parent, PICO, California, Oakland.
And good morning.
My name is Sushong.
I'm also a parent from Merced.
Hi, my name is Carrie Rosado, Pico, California, San Jose, and a parent of Franklin McKinley School District.
Patricia Hill, Pico, California, Franklin McKinley School District, San Jose, California.
Good morning, my name is Frank Ponciano.
I'm a community organizer in our Pico Federation in the great city of San Jose.
Hi, my name is Maya Nunez-Adler and I am a student leader with Pico, California from Oakland.
We are here today representing Pico, California.
Pico, California has 19 federations across the state.
We are a multi-faith, multi-racial organization that strives to develop local leadership in our congregations, schools, and communities to work for racial, social, and economic justice.
Together, we represent over 480 interfaith congregations and 450,000 families of diverse economic, racial, ethnic, and religious backgrounds rooted in school districts across the state.
In recent statewide elections, PICO California and our local federations have led some of California's largest volunteer voter engagement efforts.
We talk to our communities to encourage them to vote their values and address issues ranging from ensuring quality education with the passage of Prop 30 and the recent extension of Prop 55,
to promoting criminal justice reform with Prop 47 and 57.
PICO California parents and students have made our voices heard with legislators, the governor, and here with you.
We are also working every day with allies and educators in our school communities and local districts.
We are deeply committed to and value these partnerships and the ongoing work to transform communities and outcomes for every student in California.
Sorry.
Today we're urging the State Board to support the following recommendations.
One, administer the survey every year to help make faster decisions on the most relevant and timely data.
Two, desegregate data by race, ethnicity, and other student subgroups to achieve equitable student outcomes.
Three, allow for school-level survey results so they can be used in planning and decision-making processes.
Four, require that surveys address safety, correctness, and school conditions at a minimum.
Five, examine connections between LCFF students and special needs students.
We are continuing to advocate for evidence-based practices and state-level indicators that will support comparability and continuous improvement around parent involvement in schools and districts across California.
Some key practices and indicators that we're continuing to advocate for
Measuring include cross-training with parents, educators, and students to support dual capacity building.
Relationship building practices between parents and educators to better collaborate.
School and districts have systems and structures in place to provide parents, caregivers, with the interpretation and translation services they need to be full partners and participants.
and the use of parent surveys as a tool to understand experience and efficacy of trainings and programs.
I'm here today because I want to say an important message about LCFF.
As a parent, there has to be more basic language and more understandable language for the community.
By doing this, will we see more strong community, more teamwork, and everything will be more clearly meaning about the LCFF.
Um, y digo esto porque tuve una mala experiencia con mi principal en la cual fue, en la cual fue mi primera vez que atendía mis cafecitos.
Um, tuve una mala experiencia, no fue muy bienvenida, y esto me hizo más carácter fuerte para cambiar todos esos aspectos porque no fue una buena bienvenida.
Um, y lo que he hecho, eh,
I had a bad experience.
And LCFF was the first time that I attended.
Oh, you're translating?
Oh, OK.
I'm sorry.
to inform myself about my school.
To my surprise, I didn't have a good welcoming.
For this, I tried to talk to other parents
And I involved myself in the district to change this culture of bad communication.
LCFF is a good tool, but it needs to be better for us as parents.
Thank you.
So again, my name is Zia Xiong, I'm a parent of Merced.
I'm a Hmong parent, and Merced has the third largest Hmong population of students in State California.
I just wanted to know that I brought my son today so he could see firsthand how education really impact him.
And as a parent advocate, I work with several school district in Merced, both with the superintendent, LCAP directors,
Several years ago, every time I go to LCAP meeting, there's only about two or three parents, and I was very concerned and was really disturbed by that.
By working with the superintendents and working with the community, we're able to change some of the culture, just meeting at the school district, to a community center, to Boys and Girls Club,
to at local schools where parents could be accessed to the information.
Also making sure that Hmong language and Spanish language are also interpreted during the LCAP meetings.
So with that, I think we make a lot of progress.
I believe in LCAP, that it's inclusive.
And growing up in America as a refugee, I didn't have the opportunity.
Now my son has the opportunity.
So I just want to make sure that the board and Superintendent, all of you support the continuations of LCAP.
And I'm going to lift this up at my local board as well.
So I appreciate your hard work.
Thank you.
And in closing, it is important for us to continue to advocate and be strong on LCFL.
We continue to advocate for equitable and holistic accountability systems.
We believe that powerful relationships between all stakeholders are essential to academic success.
Positive school climate and culture creates the conditions for academic success.
The involvement engagement of parents and caregivers as well as students in partnership with educators is essential to ensuring that we improve opportunities and outcomes for all students and especially low-income students, black and brown students, foster and immigrant students across our state in order to make the promise of LCFF a reality.
Thank you.
Okay.
Member Burr, maybe you can resume.
I would like to move the CDE recommendation that's shown on the screen here and printed in our agenda to suspend the academic performance index and adopt the eligibility criteria for alternative status.
Second.
Okay.
Any further board discussion on the motion and the second?
Hearing none, all those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay, it carries unanimously.
Thank you.
The board will then recess till 10.15.
The board will reconvene.
Thank you, President Kirst.
Yeah, I wanted to make some opening remarks, so I'll do that, and then you stay right there.
They're going to be very brief.
In this item, we will hear a presentation from the CDE staff on developing an integrated statewide system of support.
that incorporates all state and federal programs.
This work will focus on the how of delivering support for local educational agencies and schools that is tailored to their locally defined needs.
And finally, and the presentation seeks feedback from SBE and others on a proposed regional structure for coordinating supports and increasing access to and consistency of supports under the state and building support and capacity for counties of Office of Education and undergirding the critical role of LCFF.
So without further ado,
We're going to have several presenters here, and Karek Ashley will lead off.
Thank you, President Kirst.
Karek Ashley, Deputy Superintendent, Performance Planning and Technology Branch.
I'm here to actually introduce the main presenter for this item, Melanie Sheppy.
I hired her about a year ago to be my administrative
branch administrator for our branch, and she came to us from Oakland Unified as a former teacher, former school principal, and then for the last three months from that position, she was promoted to Director of the Improvement and Accountability Division, which, along with Stephanie Gregson, is leading some work here on the system of support.
So, I wanted to take this opportunity, this is the first time Melanie has presented to you as a State Board.
I have hired behind Melanie, sitting here, Shanine Coates.
You'll be seeing more of her as well.
She is now the Branch Administrator for the Performance Planning and Technology Branch.
So, without further ado, Melanie Sheppy.
Good morning, Board President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson, and fellow board members.
As Deputy Superintendent Carrick-Ashley mentioned, my name is Melanie Sheppey.
I'm the Director of the Improvement and Accountability Division at the California Department of Education.
Today, I'm presenting Item 2, Developing an Integrated Statewide System of Support for Local Educational Agencies and Schools.
I am seeking feedback, no action unless, of course, you deem it necessary and appropriate.
Carrick also mentioned that I was formerly a teacher and principal in Oakland Unified.
For my first presentation to you, I really wanted to include a picture of my Greenleaf scholars.
However, I had to play it safe and include a stock photo of kids.
But I promise, if you have me back, I will slip in some photos of my Greenleaf scholars.
At Greenleaf, almost 100% of our students were from low-income backgrounds.
We were selected to expand from a K-5 to a TK-8 after demonstrating significant success.
We were then selected to become a dual immersion school.
I share this because examples of schools and districts that find sustainable improvement so that each of their students can have an excellent education is what drives my work with creating an integrated system of support.
For my presentation today, I'll first review background from the June memo.
That's entitled Developing an Integrated System of Support.
The background will include the goal and characteristics of an integrated system of support.
Then I'll review emerging feedback and a proposed regional structure, as President Kirste mentioned in his opening remarks.
I'll end our time with discussion questions and of course try to answer any questions you have.
For our board discussion, we'll focus not only on the proposed regional structure, but also the goals and characteristics put forward in the June memo.
The June memo begins with an overview of the system support framework.
Within that framework, there are three levels of support.
Level one includes support for all districts and schools.
Level two is differentiated support.
And level three is intensive support with differentiation between those levels.
You'll notice that's also information that was brought forward in August of 2016.
So not entirely new, but definitely a framework for the system of support moving forward.
Beyond the framework, the system of support must be rooted in the key LCFF policy decisions.
Those include, as you know, that we need to use multiple measures of student success.
You heard today student speakers talking about how you can use multiple measures to think about growth and continuous improvement for school communities.
Resource decisions must be linked to identified needs and there needs to be a focus on districts or local educational agencies for local accountability and supporting change within schools.
The system of support's goal is to help LEAs and schools improve their ability to meet the needs of each student and focus on equity in building local capacity to sustain improvement.
To reach that goal, the June memo outlined several characteristics of the system of support.
The system of support needs to reduce redundancy across state and federal programs, integrate guidance and resources across state and federal programs, and assistance must also support LEAs to meet identified needs through the LCAP process.
The June memo also put forward key questions for the State Board of Education and local educators and stakeholders to consider.
After hearing your feedback today, we'll continue to engage with local educators and stakeholders.
around these key questions.
For the board discussion at the end of my presentation, I pulled out question number two and question number three for us to focus on.
You'll also notice that you have a handout with these six questions, plus an additional one I added to get feedback about the proposed regional structure.
Even though I highlighted question two and three for our discussion today, I more than welcome any feedback on any of the other questions or other parts of the June memo.
There have been emerging themes that have developed from initial stakeholder feedback on the key questions we just referenced.
Initial feedback opportunities to discuss those questions include the June CPAG meeting, where members discussed part of the June memo.
Also, comments on the system of support from the ESSA stakeholder sessions.
I was honored to be part of those in different phases.
And you could tell throughout those sessions, people were giving suggestions and ideas for the system of support.
Tried to pull those out as well.
meetings with the LCFF Policy Stakeholder Group, an internal work group my School Improvement Team created with West End, and of course, the first quarterly meeting between California Department of Education, State Board of Education, SSESA, and CCEE.
For more details on key themes from that specific first quarterly meeting, you can look at page four of the July item.
It was a great meeting to be a part of, and I'm glad that we're able to have the meeting after we've had the first quarterly meeting, or have this board meeting after that first quarterly meeting.
Now to address the bullets on the screen about some of the emerging trends.
The first prominent piece of feedback is something that we know doesn't work.
And we've begun to call this the wrong door theory.
This is the experience that an educator or leader can have when you're seeking specific feedback, and every door you knock on opens only to say, oh, I'm sorry, not here.
I can't help with that problem.
We know that our system support can't have this be part of its culture.
We know another theme that the board has made clear in previous meetings is that local educators and stakeholders need to define assistance.
Additionally, CPAG and others have expressed a strong desire for the system of support to focus on root cause analysis and building capacity.
A final early theme is that support must be coordinated.
So the July item builds upon the proposed goal and characteristics outlined in the June memo, and additionally puts forward a structure for a system of support.
The proposed regional structure is one single structure for supporting LEAs under all state and federal programs.
It would include regional leads, which would be critical to coordinating supports provided to LEAs and schools.
This is different than the support we created under No Child Left Behind.
Under No Child Left Behind, we created several different regional systems that provided support without a formal mechanism for coordination.
Under the proposed regional structure, one or more county offices of education would apply through a competitive process to be a regional lead.
Also mentioned in the July item, CCEE and CDE would have a formal role to build capacity and align resources.
I want to reiterate again, the structure is intended to coordinate and align resources.
It does not attempt to define assistance.
Again, to what President Kirsch said in the beginning, talking about the how, not necessarily the what.
In reading through the letters for today's meeting from stakeholders, they picked up on the intent that the regional structure is also about the how.
And they, of course, expressed urgency and a desire to talk about the how, but also to talk about the what.
Two more points I want to make before pausing for board discussion is that the proposed regional structure is not about starting from scratch.
You'll notice in the June memo and the July item, different examples of local resources and structures that are already in place need to be integrated into one system of support.
We don't need to start from scratch on everything.
There are good things that are happening out there that have bubbled up from local needs and resources.
And also that the proposed regional structure is about building county office capacity.
In initial conversation I had with stakeholders, they said, so is this something separate?
And that made me realize that as we continue to talk about the system of support, it has to be very clear how everything is connected.
And that might mean visuals or other ways to display intersegmented partnerships, but it's not about creating something separate.
So hopefully your feedback will also help us continue to design something that reflects that.
The June memo also discussed how the system of support needs metrics of success.
These metrics will assist us in improving the system over time and ensure that the system is meeting local needs.
For our discussion today, you'll see on the screen that I pulled out question two and three from the questions that we developed that we want to get more feedback from local educators and stakeholders.
I also added a question about how can we have the proposed regional structure be designed to support one integrated system.
With that, I would love to hear your feedback and answer any questions if you have them.
Thank you.
all regional structures or one regional structure or, I mean, you can't, you know, this is a huge topic when you start talking.
And so it's not just county offices of education.
So what are you asking feedback on?
The entire concept of a regional structure or a particular provider, the counties, which are just one of many providers?
So I would like feedback also on the goals and characteristics of the system of support, but also more specifically on page five of the item, it talks about proposed integrated system of support.
And in there, it talks about the roles of county offices of education, CDE and CCEE.
And it talks about under a regional structure, one or more county offices could apply through a competitive process.
And that regional lead would help coordinate the existing structures of support and identify where there are needs of support for local educators and stakeholders.
Right now, we have, like you said, several different types of support going out there.
And this is the idea of, let's formalize a regional structure that would coordinate those different pieces of support.
I don't know how many county offices would apply to be regional leads or what the right number is of regional leads.
If you all have feedback on that today or even direction of what type of feedback you want us to gather so you can have an opinion on that.
But really it's very high level and hoping that your feedback will then give our team more guidance to operationalize it and bring you back more detail.
And these would include non-government providers and providers and they would all be coordinated by the counties?
Under this proposed regional structure, county offices would apply to be regional leads.
Then the regional leads would be the ones that help coordinate and maximize all the different state and federal programs that are out there.
So, for example, a regional lead might have a lot of
great support going on through a nonprofit provider in their region.
And that nonprofit provider and that support would work with the regional lead to make sure it's coordinated and not duplicative.
And so in that region, they don't have other organizations or structures also providing that support.
Again, very high level, because I want to hear your feedback so then I could bring you back options or more detail.
And what funding source would underline, would fund this regional structure?
Great question.
Do you all have any ideas for feedback on what funding sources could support this regional structure?
I could also bring those back as options.
That's a great question.
Well, I'll let the board members proceed then.
I just want to start with one comment.
First of all, welcome to the board presentation.
And thank you for your energy and your and your preparation for this item.
I just want to tell you that we really appreciate your work in this area.
And I think your background in leading the work at a school and in a district level will really help inform the work.
So just to highlight, you had some key philosophy and guidelines that are underlying the rationale, and one that I want to reinforce is to make sure that you ask educators what would be helpful.
Now you have that in there, but I think what we learned while we had really good intent with the last assistance that county offices did, it was often this is what you will do
It's what the hammer, we say not the flashlight.
And it was with best of intents with what they thought were the right practices and it didn't sustain and it was not collaborative.
So I just want to reinforce that process as you develop this, that educators' voices of what would be helpful and processes and areas that they need should help inform the design of the regional work.
Board Member Burr.
Thank you.
Also, welcome.
We've had other conversations in the past about this.
And so I sort of wear two hats here, right?
The accountability, one of the accountability liaisons for LCFF and also the chair of CCEE.
So just as kind of background,
for at CCEE, we're also having some of these conversations about what do we want to be when we grow up?
What is the intention of CCEE as a support mechanism?
So, I appreciate the conversations that you're having to try to coordinate that.
But I want to echo a little bit what board member Strauss said.
I worry a little bit that, and I know you guys have tried really hard not to make it sound like this, but I live sort of in the past, that this is a compliant, it becomes a little bit of a compliance mechanism.
And it's a little bit of, hi, we're here from Sacramento and we're here to help you.
As opposed to saying, what do LEAs need?
And so one really specific suggestion I would make, Melanie, is that we, in all of the conversations, these quarterly meetings that you're having to try to coordinate across the state level agencies, CCE, CDE, the county offices, you have LEAs there.
So that they can be telling you these are the kinds of things that we expect we're going to need.
I was very intrigued by a letter that we got from the Orange County superintendent who apparently has a regional structure and just received $30 million around the multi-tiered system of support.
And I know we're going to talk more about this since
where our data is revealing that our students with disabilities is the subgroup that pops up as the one that, at least in our data simulations, we really need to be attentive to, recognizing that students with disabilities can also be one or more of the other categories of high-needs students.
So I would really want to understand how that system
Because that seems to me to be a good starting point, honestly, because that's what multi-tiered systems of support are about.
Everybody improving instruction in their first classroom.
So I want to hear a little bit more about that.
And again, just continue to look at this from the other lens, because I worry that there are multiple purposes trying to be served here.
My favorite friends at the federal level have a lot of compliance that they want for the department to be sure they're ensuring, which is inconsistent with our philosophy about continuous improvement.
So I sort of want to know how we're going to reconcile those kind of competing needs.
And I think to President Kirsch's question, can you really do that with one structure?
I don't know.
I really appreciate the attempt to
eliminate redundancy and not have LEAs kind of pulled, you know, from one pole to the other about, you know, here's what you're supposed to do for the feds and no, you don't have to do that for the state.
I just think we have to be really attentive and we have to be willing to say this is a very new approach.
This is an approach of working alongside the LEAs to help build their capacity to improve student learning rather than us coming in with a here's our recipe for what you need to do.
Member Ortiz-Lacon.
Welcome.
You can tell you're new because you have so much energy and I really appreciate that.
I appreciate that.
Some people keep on day two, five minutes before the meeting ends.
So I agree with what has been previously stated.
I know that this is very high level.
And you said that sometimes people knock on the wrong door.
Well, sometimes they they're allowed to go in just to find another door and another door.
Right.
And so I think that that's
As I was looking at this, I think this is a great idea, but there's going to be so many things that have to be considered, not only integrating at the regional level, but institutionalizing it at the local level.
Because so often when these regional approaches take place, a lot of it is just rests on one person.
And if that person leaves, then the whole partnership, the work, there's a lack of continuity.
So institutionalizing it at the LEA or at the county and LEA level will be critical.
I think for me, the goal would answer the question, how can the proposed regional structure be designed to support one system, one integrated?
And that would, you know, once we get down to the very basics, would be making sure people understand their role and their responsibility and having the power to execute that role and that responsibility, making sure that
somebody at the school level understands where do I go, who is my point of contact.
So formalizing through memorandums of understanding.
So there's all those little details.
But I think what's important for us to also keep in mind is that there's going to be some regional
clusters that will be larger than others and perhaps provide a better proposal.
And we need to make sure that we max, that there's a maximum to how big those regional clusters can be because the bigger you go, the less services and the more the difficult it gets layered and so people will not be able to navigate that properly.
But we also want to make sure that we keep in mind some of the smaller county offices and districts that may not have that competitive advantage when they submit that proposal.
So, a lot to consider and I have a bunch of little smaller things here and I'm happy to share those with you.
Thank you.
Okay, Board Member Rocker.
My notes over here.
Here we go.
Okay, so first of all, we've met before.
I had a chance to meet and work with you on a previous meeting in preparation for today's conversation.
So, welcome to your first presentation.
You're doing really well.
Thanks.
That's the good news.
The bad news is... Oh no!
I have a whole lot of questions.
And I tried to warn the staff earlier by saying, you know, the Oxford English Dictionary adds about three words a year to its dictionary.
And I pay attention to that because I'm a reformed English teacher.
And so that the word they added this year was woke.
And that's important to me because part of the reason why this document is not working for me is the reformed English teacher in me says, the reason why this document see, the reason why we say the document is operating at a high level, when you say that this is a high level draft, that means there's a lot of stuff in here you don't know the answers to.
And so but what the reason why the document and I'm understanding that there are gaps in what is intended to be written into this document to describe the statewide system of support.
It's not working for me right now because there's a lot of metaphors in this document and they're all mixed together.
And so let me give you an example of where the problem for me begins.
The basic unit of change is not at the school level.
The basic unit of change is the student.
Because the purpose of this system of support is to improve and develop the district and the school's awareness of where they are failing students.
And in particular, where these failures create the performance gap.
between African-American and Hispanic students and other students at the school.
So the basic unit of change is supposed to be how is this intervention and how is this support not only going to improve access for those students, but improve their performance because it's their performance that has to change to tell us that whatever you're doing for intervention and whatever you're doing for planning has worked.
The basic failure of what we have done in previous intervention models fails to take into accountability how we put the student at the center as the basic unit of change.
Now, unit of change is a term of art that comes from math and science.
And so the other part of that conversation about unit of change is dimension.
Multi-tiered systems of instruction are about the dimension.
And so this is where the metaphors start getting mixed up.
And so, as you look at what those levels of differentiation, those levels of intervention are, how are they connected?
That's not clearly defined or explained in the document among the levels.
It's clear that there's some intentionality while we want to have a single coherent system to do this support, it is very clear that the system is not intended
to be a one-size-fits-all, collect something from column A, column B, and column C, and then here's your plan.
It's clear that that's not the intention, but that's not very well spelled out.
The third piece of this that makes it difficult for me to follow is not only what is the unit of change, but what is the
Conversation piece.
Is it the LC, is it the LCAP plan?
Is it the district's multi-tiered system of instruction plan?
Is it the district's response to intervention plan?
It is not clear and that may be stepping over the line from the how to the what.
But what is it that's driving the decisions that will define what the intervention is?
Is it what the data should be telling us?
from our dashboard.
It is unclear what actually drives or becomes the foundational piece that defines the architecture of the interventions that will be done.
That's not very well spelled out.
The other piece for me that becomes of great concern is how does the system, it doesn't, there's no exit strategy.
So once you get, and I know that this is still at the beginning of the conversation, but when you go in,
You know, you need to kind of know where the exit points are going to be or what those exit strategies are going to be.
That needs to also be clearly spelled out.
For example, the collaborative may have a larger role in some schools at the beginning of this process and their role in intervention over time may become less important.
That's not really well articulated here and how the relationship among the providers with the LEA may change.
It's also, and then finally, and I'm going to stop here because there really is so much more that I can say, but I'm making the effort not only to stay, I'm making the effort not only to stay woke about what I'm, the students that I think we should be paying attention to, but also about the fact this is your first time and I want you to like me when I'm done giving this comment.
The third piece, the last piece, last and final piece, I did five fingers, so the last and final piece for me today is to talk about the evaluation.
How do you evaluate the process?
There should be some ongoing, integral, periodic, and final evaluation, not only about the performance of the providers, but what was the outcome of the program, what did we learn from doing the intervention,
And are there things that can be improved as we continue down this road?
And so I didn't see that being given consideration at all.
It's one thing to have an accountability system.
It's one thing to use the data in that accountability system to plan interventions for schools.
But one of our principal failures over time has been we fail to hold ourselves accountable for the outcomes of our intervention.
the state process, the date process, the use of the API.
We all can sit up here and say, well, those were a disappointment, but this plan doesn't clearly articulate to me what we've learned from those, I'm saying disappointment, not failures, what we have learned from those systems to make sure we're not replicating the same mistakes.
If we do the same things we've always done, and I see some of those same things, we're going to get the same outcomes we've always gotten.
Yeah.
OK, Bruce is next.
Thank you.
I think so much of what you said, Member Rucker, is so important and needs to be fleshed out as you move along through this process.
I'd like to simplify a little bit what many of the board members have said about sort of the attitude, the approach of the people who will be supporting our LEAs.
And that very simply is to listen.
in the beginning.
I think listening instead of starting the conversation with talking, but instead starting the conversation with listening is just incredibly important in this situation.
And taking the time to learn about the situation and the challenges and all that.
But what I'm also not seeing in this is the support that the providers, the district leads will receive.
It's obvious that there are any number of wonderful people involved in County Office of Ed who can share their wisdom with all sorts of people.
But what is the ongoing training process?
Maybe this is a CCE, CE whatever, the collaborative role here is to provide ongoing trainings and coordinate among the various regional entities and say who's being successful and why and what are their practices and that sort of thing.
There has to be an ongoing improvement process for these people just as much as for the LEAs.
Thank you.
Okay, who else?
Board Member Sun.
And this might be an echo of what has been said already.
So we know that we don't want to be prescriptive and we want folks at the local level to take that responsibility.
And because we don't want to be prescriptive and this is in the manner of assistance, then we need to very clearly focus on roles, responsibility
and ultimately the accountability for it.
And I love what board member Rucker said about the locus of change is with the student.
And so what are the various roles from the school to the parent, to the student themselves, to the district level
administrators, all those, what are their roles in that change?
And then what are their responsibilities?
And then who ultimately is accountable for that?
And so I think when we're developing the structure, I think that's where we need to focus, not on what support providers, what kinds of things that need to be put into this list.
It is more around clearly the responsibilities.
Yeah, I think you need a map of what's out there now.
I mean, you know, there's a list in the document.
And it's, as I understand it, mostly public agencies established in statute.
But I would call WestEd a provider out there.
I would call the New Teacher Center a provider.
I would call the many networks at Gates Foundation.
There are MOOCs out there that are very active in California.
and that come into California.
It's not just what's in our own borders, you know, that help teachers.
There's a mathematics one and an English learner one, both run by colleagues of mine at Stanford.
So it's, there's all kinds of things going on in
And I think we've never relied strictly on public agencies to do and statutory agencies to do this job.
So I don't, in having, so what, I don't know who's coordinating, I don't know how to coordinate something.
I don't quite know what there's all about.
I think you're on the Monday, on some phone calls we've been on.
And, you know, there's all kinds of agencies out there that are working on these things.
So, the public-private mix bothers me.
There are for-fee providers out there.
I don't know whether they should be considered or not.
Pivot learning is one, for example.
Are they exempt from coordination because they're charged a fee or something?
And it's just huge.
And districts have a lot of options.
And in this highly huge state, you need a lot of flexibility to blend them together.
So, you know, some public thing under counties, it just strikes me as counterintuitive to the way the world works in this kind of a state where we have lots of entrants that are coming in.
So that's, there's an agency that, there's agencies here that are non-profits
from out of state.
There's one that works on strategic resource allocation out of Massachusetts.
There's Jobs for the Future.
I mean, all of these are private.
I work particularly in CTE.
So if you're just coordinating the public and you got all this private action out there, then I don't know how you put them together
And I don't know whether counties are particularly equipped to do this public-private mix and interweaving.
So that's what has me on thinking about this in many ways, because it's not going to be a one-size-fits-all public system, that's for sure.
But it's not going to be all public money either in terms of how and public providers on how this comes in.
There's all, I think there'll be a growth in virtual providers as well.
I mean, all the studies show teachers going online, teacher groups going online.
in many ways.
So it, yeah, I'm, you know, sort of reeling because I can't get all this.
We have a digital library in Smarter Balanced.
It seems to me that's something.
So I don't know how these counties are going to, you know, get a hold of all of this and put it all together.
Thank you.
Again, Carrick Ashley.
So Melanie is a very quick study.
When we talked about the board item yesterday, and I told her if you get the question about funding, don't get tripped into going straight to the federal programs, right?
Good job.
So as you'll notice, the title of the item is about state and federal programs.
We pulled it out specifically from the ESSA state plan, which is the next item of which system of support has to be discussed in that item.
This really is about trying to do just like our dashboard and everything else, be California driven, not federally driven.
We do have, currently, regions of system of support now.
We do it through Title I, through the 11 successor regions.
We do have what's called county leads for Title III, our federal Title III program.
Those are also housed in some county offices.
We have other regional programs.
I think Afterschools has a regional program.
Excuse me.
So we have regional programs that we do have control over.
And then there are regional programs that are funded with state funding that we, Department of Ed, doesn't necessarily have control over.
But we've got CCEE.
We've got, as was mentioned before, the MTSS that's working out of Orange County.
So there are some things that we can control.
There are other agencies providing support that we have.
An inroad to, for instance, the superintendent sits on the board for CCEE.
We don't control it, but we have these quarterly state agency meetings to coordinate that work and to collaborate on that work so we can come to an agreement and a coordination so we don't have the duplication.
And then there's kind of a third set of providers.
You mentioned Pivot and others out there.
There are a lot of people providing those kind of services.
I think what we can do with those is to provide a framework of saying what we are doing with the agencies that we have control over or with we collaborate, this is the framework that we're working under.
And if you want to be a provider, a private provider in California, we would strongly suggest
that you follow this same sort of model that we are using.
They're obviously not obligated to do that.
But this idea of bypassing school districts and going straight into a school to give them large grants under school improvement didn't prove to be very successful.
So we're talking about building capacity at a school district level.
And so if we've got some guiding principles, some frameworks on how to do that to communicate that with these private providers,
Hopefully, they take our lead of where the state of California is going.
Not that we can control it, but perhaps we can help coordinate.
I'm worried about the phrase our model, but I'll have to, yeah.
Who is next here?
Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe, you haven't gotten in, so let me.
Okay.
Board Member Sun is next.
Yeah, go ahead.
Yes, and I really, really hope that as we're developing this system of support that we are moving away from buying reform in a box, that we're not just buying a program or buying this and somehow that's going to just cure the problem.
And because it hasn't worked before and it isn't going to work.
So what I'm seeing is that the support, the capacity building part of it is reinvesting back into the school to the stakeholders in the school to have time to have conversations.
to do for teachers to observe each other and and work with each other and plan together.
So it's not about buying something.
And I really hope that we kind of keep that at bay and allow folks to work together.
That is the key to making change.
Yeah, I think, Mike, to your comments about this kind of array of people out there that are trying to help districts or help schools, the key point is the one that board member Sun brought up earlier.
It's who's accountable for that.
And I think what the system that we're trying to talk about here and devise
says we're accountable, right?
And whether it's through our LCFF accountability, our integrated accountability, or what the feds expect from us, ultimately it comes back to us.
And we have to have some level of confidence that the support and assistance that's being provided is doing exactly what board member Sun said, building the capacity of teachers to improve their work with students.
So it may be that, you know, whoever is helping to manage this says, gee, WestEd would be a great person to come in or they're really working on CTE and it would be great to bring in jobs for.
But it does, if we're accountable, we have to build a structure to me in a way that says, yeah, we own this and this is who we're relying on to provide that kind of assistance.
The last thing I just wanted to mention about CCEE's work, and I know you're hearing this in your meetings, but, you know, and Superintendent Torlaks and I have been privileged to hear these conversations.
They have a lot of work going on right now testing out things.
They've got 10 or 11 pilot districts, one county office they're working with to do these kinds of conversations.
We've also just invested several million dollars in a number of peer-to-peer networks to try to again have LEAs help each other, nonprofit organizations help each other to improve their practice.
So I hope we'll be learning from that again to kind of refocus how we're thinking about support and assistance and to try to move away from the sort of categorical compliance checklist here, buy a box, do this recipe.
But I'm worried that these words, an integrated statewide system of support, integrated system, integrated system and regional structure,
You know, what if I'm out there and I got a really good and I'm a provider, but I don't fit into your integrated system.
I mean, this is back to date and state to me.
You know, I've been there.
And, you know, once you get government into saying, here's your integrated system, fit into this system.
And if you don't fit, you're not part of it.
strikes me as not a way to go about this.
There's a market out there.
I mean, you're... I know.
And it's not intended to be exclusionary.
It's intended to say there are a lot of resources.
How are we going to coordinate them?
And how are we going to assess, number one,
how they're doing with students.
What are their needs?
Because I'll say the opposite of the market driven.
I love the fact that we have cottage industries that sprang up, but that's what happens every time we have a state funded or federal funded program.
Remember our experience with SES providers.
which turned out to not be very good.
So I just think we have to sort of keep in mind all those things and not exclude people because there are lots of people that have very good expertise.
But we, again, as the State Policymaking Board, in my view, have the responsibility to be accountable for that work.
One thing we discussed at CPAG in the June CPAG meeting was how do we make sure we're getting the right resources at the right time to the right people and aligning those resources with their locally identified needs.
So I just think that adds a little bit more what board member Burr was talking around the coordination and what's our responsibility in helping that process of getting the right resources at the right time.
Sorry.
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
And President Curtis, I understand your concern, but I also think maybe integrated is not the best word.
It's more cohesive.
I think that if we don't have a system where we're trying to at least do some community mapping to figure out what's out there.
And we do know that there's private, nonprofit, public, but we do also need all of those resources to build capacity and expand our capacity.
So I think we need something.
In the absence of that, we're just going to have people doing work in silos and no one's really going to know what's actually working.
And we need to have a system in place where we could do some shared practices across the regions so that everyone has an understanding of what's out there beyond the limitation of my little parameter here in my regional area.
Going back to board member Rucker, I love that the unit of change definitely should be the student.
I think that we need some sort of logic model by tier.
So tier one, starting with the student, but what would that look like?
Tier two and tier three, because we are also in need of more clarity around what that support is going to look like.
And maybe in doing an inventory of what's out there, we'll get a better sense of what our capacity is.
I agree that there was no exit strategy in the next item, but there was also, you know, we had some numbers and it was hard for me to really distinguish if we go with intervention or support to this percentage of LEAs, do we have
25% that we could cover versus 18%.
I still don't know what our capacity is.
And unless we start trying to figure out what's out there and how we're going to align our resources, we won't have that.
And without knowing our capacity, we can move to identifying the bottom 5% or identifying the schools that are most in need and LEAs.
Thank you.
Board Member Rucker.
So then going back to the comments that I made earlier, and I'm really happy to add some dimension to the comment I made earlier based on the feedback you've since received.
A lot of the concern about this plan really is that I'm thinking what you heard really is about what right now is not in there.
And while the goal of doing this draft was to try to lay out an architecture to explain how the intervention would work,
and the different levels, who the entities would be that would be involved.
I think the point has been made that there does need to be some detail when you look at and try to thread out what the dimensions of this plan would be.
Not only how it operates at each level, what the form is, but there is going to have to be somewhat defining function.
So,
the form and function in writing out this plan becomes important because in the details of what you heard, particularly as it relates to selecting providers or identifying what the role of each of those providers would be, that really is about function and defining that.
But as Board Member Burr pointed out,
We are accountable for it.
But accountability, in my experience, once it gets past the student who has to take the assessments or participate and do the work, or the teacher who is evaluated for it, at some point in time, accountability starts looking like, well, I guess that was wrong.
There needs to be a different way of gauging accountability and implementing some level of accountability for the decisions that were made.
Because even though we have this dashboard that is creating
a great deal of transparency and giving us a truckload of new types of information.
This plan is still based on a lot of data-free decision-making.
And so there's still need, so the beauty of data-free decision-making is a wing and a prayer is all we need to hold ourselves accountable.
But at the end of all of those things, we still end up with the same frustrations and the same failures.
So if this plan is truly going to be data-driven, the added dimension that has to be in this plan is to define based on what data are the decisions for intervention being made.
And so that is something else that the plan doesn't truly articulate as part of the how, is how will decisions about the intervention and the types of engagement that will be recommended will be driven by the data about the school.
Thank you.
Superintendent.
Yeah, just a couple of reflections.
This item was intended to be thought provoking, provocative.
And it's a great discussion.
And it does need a lot more detail.
It is very complex.
And I think, you know, some of the words we need to work on defining those or putting more in context.
Perhaps again, integrated may not be integrated system of support may not be the right phrase.
Maybe it's more the coordinating connected.
and how do we more efficiently use, how do we share the great work that Sue Berger shared with you that's going on at the CCEE pilot programs, peer-to-peer best practices being developed, and how do you make sure that those opportunities to enjoy those discoveries and those synergisms
is available around the state and that it's covered in the rural parts of the state and the valley parts of the state and big areas and rural areas.
So I just thought the discussion is very good and focusing on capacity building, looking to the board and to you, President Kirsch, as we would go forward and a couple of you as board members have some more extensive lists of ideas and details.
Could we have some liaison or two from the board to work or come to a couple of the meetings that Melanie and the group will be looking at so we can be sure to take into consideration not only the questions in debate today, but further thoughts you have about refining this and adding workable detail.
And just one other connection point, we have just recently, I mentioned in my earlier remarks,
the legislature granted 2.5 million dollars for an equity team or looking at how to close the achievement gap.
And we're looking at deploying that five fellows over a period of three years in a regional format.
And so how would that, you know, coordinate in and fit in or create some additional synergy along with the CCE projects and others of that like?
So just a suggestion is going forward.
Maybe Melanie, you can give us a time frame when you wanted to bring this back again.
I think next meeting, but looking at the time context, we would be open to working closely with the board.
Okay, board member Sandoval.
Thank you.
I appreciated all of the board comments that I heard and I just wanted to address one of the questions on how the proposed structure could be designed to support one more integrated or cohesive system.
And I think just focusing on students and the root causes of their struggles is really essential, has to start there.
And then coordinating solutions to the challenges in a manner that is as transparent as possible so that we can all learn
from the problem solving strategies.
And I think that's going to help us ensure accountability to each and every student.
And I think I'm delighted to hear about the fellows and this work looking at equity because I think looking at disparities across groups and how we can help solve problems that we're seeing in our schools.
So I just wanted to offer that.
Okay, are we ready for some public, we have public comment on this item, then we could resume our discussion.
Somebody call the roll for the public comment.
We have the following speakers for public comment.
Please line up.
Christina Olmsted, Deborah Sims, Leila Fahimuddin, Sandy Mendoza, Liz Guillen, Martha Alvarez, Ralph Porras, and Lisa Morris, or Liza Morris.
Good morning.
I'm Christine Olmsted, the Associate Superintendent of Instruction for the Orange County Department of Education.
And here on behalf of Alma Harris, our County Superintendent of Schools in Orange County, as well as Tim Taylor, our Butte County Superintendent of Schools representing rural California for us.
And my colleague Susan Huckanin is in the room with me today as well.
And we just wanted to come today to let you know that this regional system of support, what it looks like and what it turns into is working for the work that we're doing and that you've entrusted us to do with the $30 million that you've given us to scale MTSS statewide.
And so being able to depend on our region leads and our county office leads to be conveners for the trainings that we have to do to get consistency across the state with a multi-tiered system of support framework is one avenue.
Definitely hear everything you're saying.
It is not a come in and buy a program.
We are working with districts to look at their own resources
and we'll give you an update later when you're ready.
Good afternoon, good morning.
My name is Deborah Sims and I'm the Director of Strategic Systems and Innovation for Pivot Learning and I'm here today representing our CEO, Dr. Arun Ramanathan.
We're pleased that you're addressing these key policy issues related to the development of a statewide system of support.
Pivot Learning has joined together with other nonprofit technical assistance providers committed to improving the outcomes for our state's diverse population and to provide recommendations on this proposed system.
Our organizations work in communities across California.
Equity, excellence, and accountability are our core values, and our approach is underscored by partnering with working with LEAs and stakeholders to create and strengthen coherent systems, to build capacity, and to improve craft knowledge, all in efforts to significantly increase student success.
Time.
I just, as I'm leaving, I'd just like you to refer back to the letter that we've sent you with our three guiding principles for you to consider around working with our nonprofits.
Thank you.
Good morning, members.
My name is Leila Fahimuddin, and I'm with the National Center for Youth Law's Foster Ed California Initiative.
We work in close partnership with local and regional collaboratives of school districts, county offices of education, child welfare agencies, probation agencies, and impacted young people and their caregivers to coordinate supports and services for system-involved youth in order to improve the educational outcomes for all young people.
We, along with our colleagues at organizations such as Pivot Learning Partners, Families in Schools, and others, have a track record of providing effective technical assistance and capacity development to local LEAs in meeting their LCFF goals and priorities for their most impacted students.
As the board and department continue to develop the integrated system of supports for LEAs, we ask you to be sure to include non-profit equity focused organizations like ours that bring trusting relationships with LEAs, practice expertise and resources for marginalized youth to the table.
Our students stand to benefit when our systems have the ability to leverage both public resources and the high quality diverse non-profit resources in their communities.
Time.
Good morning, Sandy Mendoza with Families in Schools.
We have joined with colleagues to provide recommendations on the state system of support.
We are working on the LCAP process with communities around the state and we appreciate the opportunity to share our perspectives with the board.
An effective system of support will provide LEAs with opportunities to make sure the system fits with local context and is based on partnership and respect.
We recommend that the system create a process that assures quality, yet supports diversity and the breadth and providers to meet the variety of needs of LEAs.
While we are supportive of the idea of regional leads for local assistance and support, we think the language around partnering or subcontracting should be encouraged rather than left as permissive.
As noted in our letter, our organizations work in partnership with LEAs and have relationships built on trust and respect.
We believe that the state system should take an inclusive approach that leverages the depth and breadth of expertise in California.
The capacity of LA's county offices and the CCEE will be strengthened by a system that opens doors and provide with providers who have strong track records.
Thank you so much.
Good morning, Marta Alvarez on behalf of AXA.
I'll keep my comments high level given that we have a speaker right after me with more details.
We have heard from the field the importance about making sure that this system of support is customized and individualized.
We want to ensure that we think about the what.
So we have been engaging administrators in this conversation thinking about what they need, what capacity building looks like for them, what are the skills and knowledge and leadership that they need to develop to become better professionals to be able to make the right decisions on behalf of kids.
So we're thinking about the what, then we're thinking about the how would we provide the support from the state, county, CCE, all the different entities, and then moving on to the how would that be provided and who provides it.
And so we would like to welcome the opportunity to participate in these conversations with you at a greater
We have a lot of comments we have received.
We have not focused on the regional structure because it's a new item just released less than 10 days ago.
But we do have comments.
One last thing I'll say, a repository of best practices.
Before we talk about people coming in and providing support, how can we allow for districts to be able to go search, how to reduce suspension rates?
We'll talk about establishing that dashboard.
Thank you.
I'd like to call the next group of speakers.
Christy Sinclair, Jason Henderson.
Giselle Viveros, Angela Del Ramos, Eric Premack, Lorraine Richards, Carrie Hannel, Mary Perry, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz, and Shelley Spiegel-Coleman.
Good morning, members of the board.
Ralph Gomez-Porras, Superintendent for Pacific River Unified School District, AXA Past President and Chair of the Accountability Task Force.
I wish to note that our task force does encourage an active two-way dialogue between the administrators and the state board to help create viable solutions, and we do certainly welcome that.
As with many of your members, we are still digesting details and have more questions and answers at this point, specifically questions on how this proposed regional structure would become operationalized and the timing for soliciting applications from interested counties that want to serve as regional leads.
We are concerned what the role of the CCEE might be in supporting the regional leaders in those areas of the state where the counties themselves might need additional coaching and support in order to be able to serve the individual school districts.
Since prior informational memos have indicated there are at least 180 school districts who would receive support under the LCFF, we believe it's important to consider specifically where the concentrations of most of these districts are.
Unless there's a balanced representation of these districts being distributed across all regions of the state, it will be important to consider if there will be a proportionate number of regional leads according to where the districts of support are needed.
It would be helpful for the field to receive additional information on potential roles and responsibilities of each of these entities that might be involved in providing support and assistance to schools and LEAs, such as the CDE and the CCEE.
It's important to consider how the state agencies will work, coordinate, and collaborate with the county offices in order to leverage the state's limited capacity and appropriate use of limited resources.
We appreciate that the assistance and support offered to the schools and LEAs will be customized and tailored to the unique needs and the potential challenges of our LEAs face.
The differentiated instruction assistance, excuse me, and targeted support is critically important if we expect to close the achievement gaps.
In prior past surveys for administrators, there has been an overwhelming support expressed for ongoing coaches for new and continuing administrators, a support network, and professional development for the new curriculum frameworks.
Our members have also provided consistent feedback that they need assistance in forming leadership teams who will focus on student performance and data analysis.
This is even more important now that we have the dashboard with multiple data points on the various state and local indicators.
Administrators also believe that all decisions need to be made in collaboration with the school and district leadership and local stakeholders.
As part of this integrated system support, AXA is particularly interested in ensuring the effective use and optimization of the optional 3% reservation of the Title II federal funds to develop the expertise and capacity of the school leaders.
We know these funds translate to approximately $7 million statewide, and leveraging these funds for professional development, a cohort model, PLCs, and or job-alike networks should be considered.
On one final note, I'd like to echo Member Burr's comments.
I would say beware of the shades of SES in the PI days.
Having lived through that, I can tell you it's awkward at best and it was a questionable solution.
As always, AXA, individual administrators across the state, and our task force stand ready to engage in more extensive two-way discussions with you all.
We encourage that and hope to see you at a future date.
Thank you very much.
Hello, Liz Guillen with Public Advocates.
Continuous improvement is such a central part of the work of LCFF.
And in order to make it work, we have to be further along.
And it's disappointing that there is no real sense of urgency, at least that we have seen from the reading.
We urge you to set a timeline.
within the next two board meetings by November to ask staff to bring back a real actionable plan for how the system of support will be formed.
Right now we have student leaders and parent organizers outside hoping to share the message that LCFF is working or that things are better than they were before.
This is a critical piece of that.
And we would really like to work with you, of course, to develop the system.
But as you have been grappling with trying to figure out what the framework is and what's being proposed, we also have and we'd like to see it solidified more.
Thank you.
Good morning, Carrie Hennell with the Education Trust West.
We'd like to associate my comments with Liz Gaines from Public Advocates and appreciate the discussion about the vagueness of the plan that's been proposed.
We agree that it's awfully thin on details at this point and it's far too vague.
While we appreciate and agree with the desire to avoid a one-size-fits-all approach, the problem at this point is that by refusing to lay out any firm commitments in the plan,
you are inspiring very little confidence in the public that things will actually be improved and that the LCFF promise of equity and improvement will actually be realized.
We also appreciate and acknowledge the description in the agenda item about the dashboard and how by itself it cannot
facilitate continuous improvement at the local level, that we need additional local data.
The lagging data, the multiple measures are fine for accountability, but in order for the continuous improvement to happen, would appreciate some discussion about how the state will provide access to further data, how it will support that local access to information and continuous improvement, and how it will ensure that this continuous improvement happens, and just that we hope that it will happen by empowering locals.
Thank you.
Hello, I'm Mary Perry and I'm here with the California State PTA.
And as most of you know, we certainly know a lot about the diversity of this state and the importance of dealing with local needs.
At the same time, we also know that it doesn't make sense for every single school and district in this state to reinvent the wheel.
And this regional and cohesive system of support makes sense to perhaps thread that needle.
I'd like to suggest that family engagement provides a very tangible topic within this system of support and maybe one that could be a pilot to move along the lines of immediacy that some of my colleagues have mentioned.
The fact is there is research that clearly links
Effective family engagement, when you engage families in the learning of their children to real school improvement, you're mobilizing your child's first teacher, and it can make all the difference.
At the same time, we know that family engagement strategies are one of the missing pieces for school districts in our state.
Good morning, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz representing the California Association for Bilingual Education and Californians Together.
I have one comment and one recommendation.
Any statewide system of support should have at every level personnel or staff that possess experience and expertise in addressing the educational needs of the students in every subgroup.
In doing so, the support provided would be appropriate.
and for these students, and hopefully result in identifying the tools, strategies that are most effective when dealing with the educational needs of these student subgroups.
CABE has extensive experience in working with LEAs in providing support, and we stand ready to assist you in this effort.
Thank you.
Good morning, Shelly Spiegel Coleman with Californians Together.
Some of you may not know that prior to my work with Californians Together, I worked for 27 years at the L.A.
County Office of Education.
I lived through Sate and Date.
I drank Sate and Date, right?
I really appreciate board member Rucker's unit of change, focusing on who the students are, because that was not the focus of what we did before.
And so when we talk about who are going to be the providers and who are going to be the leads, we have to think about, we know who the students are going to be that these providers and leads need to provide help for.
And so what providers have expertise in English learners that are in small numbers, in a small district in small numbers?
What providers have expertise for English learners in a school district that have multiple languages and not a large group of a single language?
What providers have expertise in a large urban district that has large numbers of English learners in one or two major languages?
That's what we have to build into this system.
We have to build expertise to be able to address those needs.
And the unit of change is the students.
Thank you.
Hello, Lorraine Richards, California Teachers Association.
In considering the development of the statewide system of support, CTA urges the board to ask, how will the developing statewide systems of support be accessible to local stakeholders who are not school administrators or board members?
While we agree there should be no wrong door for LEAs,
to enter to access resources or support available through the statewide system of support, we urge members to ask how the agencies responsible for providing support will, one, clearly and publicly identify the point of contact for accessing the system, and two, providing an open door to students, parents, educators, and community stakeholders such that the access is not appropriately restricted.
Thank you.
Morning, Terry Burns, California School Boards Association.
First of all, associated remarks with those of AXA.
We think that the regional system of support has, is very promising.
We think it's important that there is consistency across providers with the concept that they go out and first start talking to the district, see what the district thinks the concerns are.
and then work through problems in that regard.
We also think it's important that it be a market-driven system that for whatever reason, bad interpersonal relationships between that county office and the district, whatever,
that a district can look towards a regional provider that works for them.
That way nobody gets stuck with an undue bill because they have to go to this provider and they can do the relationship stuff that is so important and plays on a one-to-one basis.
So, thank you very much.
Good morning, LeAngela Reid on behalf of AXA, excuse me, on behalf of SSDA want to, sorry Martha, I'd like to align myself with the comments of AXA and CSBA.
Sorry about that.
Martha's now awake.
I just want to reiterate the point that I think that the first thing that has to happen is there needs to be two questions put to the field.
One, what do you think you need to be successful?
Because even if they don't know, it will give you, it will create an indication of what's thought, what, where they're, they're going as far as process.
And then two, who do you go to for information resource?
Everyone has someone locally identified that can, we can start there with those folks because they know the local history, the local battles, the local dynamics.
When you send someone in, they are doing to, not doing with.
And so it's important to, to start from local level and build out.
Thank you.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center.
I share Dr. Kirst's skepticism about relying on one exclusive type of agency to do this very complicated work.
It's of particular concern for charter schools where
We have very good relationships and working relationships with some county offices and some county leadership and extremely hostile relationships with others.
So when I hear board member Burr say, hi, we're here from
the county office and we're here to help, I actually work with charter schools where we have, hi, I'm here from the county office and I hate your school and I hate charter schools and we want to see you shut down.
And so the notion of relying on those agencies to provide this kind of support in some regions would be deeply troubling and we would encourage you to think twice.
Upping the periscope a bit, there's a lot of talk here about instructional
assistance and that sort of thing.
My experience from the Satan date stuff was that a lot of these problems stemmed from inept governance, inept leadership, very poor labor management relationships, and much of the failure of that, of the date stuff, was to focus on instruction when the fundamentals underneath instruction were very unsound.
And just keep that in mind.
Thank you.
Good morning, my name is Jeff Mercado from CCESA.
As we know, the counties will play a central role in this system.
We look forward to that and all 58 counties are committed to really improving capacity and be able to work to move forward with state agencies, state boards, CDE, CCE to work in collaboration to really develop the system and get feedback from the field.
A couple of things to point out over the past year, the counties
took the role of being that first line of support for the dashboard and the revised LCAP template very seriously.
We came together, worked closely with our partners to then develop four comprehensive trainings to have all 58 counties spun up and ready to go to then turn around to the field and be ready
In that vein, we have the MTSS work being done by Orange County and Butte.
And we're also entering a partnership with the Carnegie Foundation and the Improvement Collective to really build up the capacity of county offices around improvement science.
And we're looking forward to doing that work with the CCE and the state board staff and the CDE as well.
So we look forward to really doing this work with LEAs, not to with in partnership and to really build our capacity to help facilitate the discussions to really impact student outcomes.
Thank you.
Okay, that concludes the public comment.
This was an information item for this meeting, not an action item.
So I think we'll take another break and then go on to number three.
So let's reconvene at 20 of 12.
Board members, we're going to have the lunch and you go get it and so on.
So this will be the break and then lunch you can have when you want it.
There's also cupcakes in here in Olivia's honor.
And we didn't have a cake, but we had cupcakes.
Okay, the State Board will reconvene.
Please take your seats.
We're now ready for item three, which is the update on the Every Student Succeeds Act, Federal Act.
And before we take up the item, the State Superintendent wants to make an addendum to the last item.
Thank you, President Kirsch.
And appreciate again the rich debate and the necessary questioning of different details we need to develop.
So talking to my staff during the break and talking to President Kirst and Karen, we'll work very closely together.
We have to date on this.
We need to get more details.
We invite board members to channel their information and questions through Karen and we'll again stand ready to report back at the next meeting to get some progress report and
I think November, aiming to November for a more comprehensive full report that would be ready to act on.
So with that, just wanted to say appreciate the good debate.
Okay, before we're ready for item three, I want to make a comment on the perspective the board has been using in looking at the various suggestions we've been getting with respect to ESSA.
And that is that we have our own specific state statute concerning school accountability, the LCFF.
And this was enacted, the LCFF, in 2013 before ESSA was even a proposal under consideration in Congress.
For this reason, we have been consistent in emphasizing that state policy should be the foundation of our deliberations around ESSA.
And I want to underscore what I've said before.
The state plan is essentially a contract with a federal government.
We have approached this as not spelling out unnecessary detail in the plan for several reasons.
First, there is lots of detail in the state law that we've been implementing for several years that sets the framework.
Second, the more details we include in ESSA, the less flexibility that we have to adjust what's working and what isn't based on local feedback and what the data show.
For everything spelled out in detail, we would need the federal government's permission to adjust rather than being able to respond to stakeholder feedback as we have in the past in revising the ELICAP and the dashboard.
I would remind people that this state operated under the No Child Left Behind law from year 2003 until 2017-18.
That's a long time.
You may or may not like this administration, but there'll probably be another administration in the future.
So holding this as a contract with the federal government
I think is a plunge into the unknown as to who you're going to be dealing with back there.
So, we would, I understand that stakeholders would like to see more details in this plan, but it is not a vehicle to create new law or regulations that bind the state of California.
We want to respond to the prompts and the Secretary of Education will tell us if our responses are not detailed enough and we haven't answered fully their questions.
Finally, a lack of specific detail in the plan does not mean that we will not flesh out the detail as we move forward implementing these programs under our state laws and our state policymaking system.
Describing this general approach I have done, I hope, allows us to implement a program in a matter that is maximally responsible to the needs identified at the state and local level and also compatible with the Secretary's of Education's need to enforce the ESSA law.
So, with that as an overview,
We will hear first from Barbara Murchison and other CDE staff on specific topics.
We'll go through the round of CDE presentations and then we'll take initial SBE member questions and comments.
Then we'll move to public comment and then we'll move back to SBE discussion and comments among the members.
So Barbara, thank you for coming.
Thank you for having me.
Good morning President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson, board members.
I'm Barbara Murchison as a state lead here at the Department of Education.
The purpose of this item is to provide you and the public with an update regarding progress in the development of the Every Student Succeeds Act or ESSA state plan.
The CDE recommends today that the Board approve the revisions to the ESSA State Plan proposed in Attachment 1.
The CDE will bring a final draft of the State Plan to the Board for approval in September 2017.
So recall at the January meeting you approved the set of guiding principles on this slide.
The principles state that our plan will support the creation of a single coherent local state and federal accountability and continuous improvement system with state priorities and direction leading and opportunities in the ESSA leveraged to assist in accomplishing state goals and objectives.
The principles also reflect our commitment to updating federally required applications and plans, to reinforce and align with state priorities, and to use ESSA resources to support the implementation of rigorous standards and the principles of equity, local control, and continuous improvement that drive our LCFF-based system.
Plan development has been driven by these principles and it's great that with today's conversations, we're getting much closer to the realization of the single coherent system that we've all been talking about since ESSA became law.
Our goal today is to get as close to the final draft as possible so that we have minimal changes when we bring the plan to you for approval in September.
Here's our current timeline.
You'll note that there are no asterisks on this slide.
I've worn out that button on the keyboard.
We intend to submit the plan to the US Department of Education on September 18th, and we'll be bringing it to you for approval at your September meeting, which is currently scheduled for September 13th and 14th, just a few days before the submission date.
Also, statute requires that the governor have 30 days to review the plan before it is submitted, and it is our understanding that that plan should be the plan that is being submitted to ED.
And we also want to make sure that all of the stakeholders who have worked alongside us to develop the plan have ample time to review the document before your September meeting.
For all of these reasons, we intend to take your direction today and use it to develop a new draft plan.
We will make this new draft, which we hope will be pretty close to the final draft, you can see I'm still a little wary of saying final, but close to the final draft, available to you and the public as an information memoranda in early August.
We do have another meeting with the California Practitioners Advisory Group, or CPAG, next month.
And during that meeting, they'll be able to weigh in on any outstanding ESSA-related issues.
But again, we are aiming to get close to final today.
Since ESSA became law, we've discussed ESSA state plan development at eight of your meetings and at eight CPAG meetings, one meeting per month since April 2016.
In addition to all of these meetings, we've conducted four formal phases of stakeholder engagement.
In spring of 2016, we conducted phase one, where we partnered with county offices of education and our colleagues at the California Comprehensive Center to conduct webinars and statewide regional meetings.
We asked Californians what they wanted for their schools and how best to support students and teachers.
We also used a survey to collect feedback more widely.
For Phase 2, last November, we made available several sections of the draft plan in a toolkit, including videos and a survey, and asked the public to share their feedback on those sections.
In Phase 3, in February, we once again collaborated with county offices to hold regional meetings.
During these meetings, we asked the public to provide feedback on specific policy questions to help inform your decision-making.
More information and links to the reports for each of these phases of stakeholder engagement is available on our webpage and the link is provided on this slide.
Which brings us to phase four.
Since we saw you in May, we've been very busy conducting phase four of SSA stakeholder engagement, which included the 30-day public comment period.
We brought the plan to the CPAG, and members spent more than four hours providing feedback on each section of the plan.
CPAG feedback is provided in attachment one and helped inform our proposed revisions.
We deployed a variety of engagement strategies during phase four, building upon the successes of phases one, two, and three.
Key to phase four was the expansion of our partnerships.
We've worked closely with our county office colleagues since the beginning, and they have continued to be steadfast in their support.
A good example, you recall at the May meeting, President Kurz suggested that we might want to have a regional meeting in the Bay Area.
And a few minutes after that discussion, when we broke for lunch, I went back up to my desk, and there were two emails in my inbox from Bay Area county office staff volunteering to help us out and partner with us.
It's that kind of support that makes this work possible.
So thanks again to all of the county office staff, too many to name here, who have partnered with us throughout our plan development journey.
For phase four, we expanded our partnerships to include work with professional associations and the LCFF equity coalition.
This expanded our audience to include specific groups of stakeholders.
We also built a toolkit of resources to make it easier for stakeholders across the state to understand and provide feedback on the state plan.
So this slide shows the meetings we conducted during Phase 4.
As you can see, we held 11 in-person meetings.
Two of these meetings were hosted by our LCFF Equity Coalition colleagues with support from the California Endowment.
Participants at these two meetings were primarily parents, and it was a privilege to hear their perspectives.
We very much appreciate our Equity Coalition colleagues for making these meetings happen.
We heard from people in earlier phases that it was challenging for teachers and parents to get to meetings during the day.
So this time, we hosted meetings in the evening as well as the day meetings.
Our colleagues at the Sacramento, San Diego, and Los Angeles county offices got a double dose of Essa and Barb, hosting both morning and evening meetings at their county offices.
We also hosted three webinars, one in collaboration with the Small School Districts Association, and another with the Association of California School Administrators, or ACSA, and the California School Boards Association, CSBA.
These were great opportunities to hear the perspectives of specific groups of stakeholders, and we appreciate these organizations for co-hosting these online meetings and getting their members engaged in providing feedback.
At the center of phase four was the public comment toolkit.
We know we can't be everywhere, and during phase one, folks explicitly told us that it would be helpful to have a set of resources so that they could hold stakeholder meetings at a time that was convenient for them and their local communities.
Also, there is so much material to cover in the plan that we were typically able to cover only three sections during one of our two-hour meetings.
The toolkit was designed to support people to learn more about and provide feedback on whichever sections of the plan were of interest to them.
It's hard to see on this screenshot, but what we have is a web page where we've broken the plan out into 11 separate sections.
And for each section, there is a short narrated PowerPoint video, a short two to four page plan section summary, which presents the plan content.
And again, it's a relatively technical document, into more user friendly language.
and that same plan summary document translated into Spanish.
The toolkit also has facilitator instructions, the PowerPoint that we used across the state, and most important, the link to the public comment survey.
So we made available the introduction as well to make the 11 sections, but here are the 10 sections for which we asked folks to provide feedback.
And here is the question we asked for each section.
It's the same question for each section.
The question was designed to be accessible to all types of stakeholders and to get at the question of equity that was discussed during your May meeting.
So for each section of the plan, we asked folks in the survey, please share your ideas about how this section of the ESSA state plan could be improved to promote equity and support your students and schools.
We wanted to take that question.
out to the field.
So here's a little bit of overview information for phase four.
We were a little bit worried that with the timing, school getting out, the beginning of summer, all kinds of graduation, May 22 to June 30 is not necessarily the best time to engage folks.
So we were really happy to see that we got some pretty good numbers in terms of who had responded.
We had 466 folks.
who responded to the survey.
More than 600 people participated in our regional and online meetings.
And we received more than 100 letters and emails around the as a state plan.
And you'll see in your addendum attachment four, there's a breakdown of which types of stakeholders were engaged.
An analysis of the feedback collected from the CPAG and during Phase 4 meetings was provided in Attachment 1.
And an analysis of all the feedback collected during Phase 4, which includes all of the survey responses and all the correspondence we received, was provided in Attachment 4.
So attachment four, which is the summary report for phase four of SS stakeholder engagement, was just completed yesterday.
And I do apologize for that less than optimal timing, but typically staff takes a month or two to read, analyze, and summarize SS stakeholder feedback after one of these phases of engagement.
I really need to take a minute to acknowledge the work of my colleagues in program offices across the department who sorted through
The 700 or so pages, I don't know if you've seen it yet.
There's one in the lobby.
I think there's one here.
There's one up in the board office.
We've collected more than about 700 pages of raw comments.
within a week, and a week that included the 4th of July, no less, right?
So folks have been working really, really furiously to pull all this information together so you would have the benefit of all of this phase four stakeholder feedback to inform your decision making today.
But still, because I know that most folks haven't really had the time to review Attachment 4, I want to take a few minutes to go through some of the highlights.
Remember, Attachment 1, which was posted on June 30th, included an analysis of feedback from the CPAG and feedback from the 14 meetings, which represented hundreds of people.
Attachment 4 builds upon Attachment 1 to include the survey results and correspondence.
It's important to note that not all sections of the plan receive the same amount of attention during the meetings.
When people registered for the meetings, we asked them to indicate which three topics they were most interested in, and then we discussed the most frequently requested topics at those meetings.
So some of the topics were discussed at every meeting, and some of the topics were not chosen to be discussed at any of them.
So we had different amounts of feedback on each one of these items.
Assessment, accountability, and school support and improvement are topics that received a lot of feedback during the meetings.
And the feedback received later in the public comment process was not substantively different than the feedback received earlier.
So as you can see on this slide, staff does not propose additional revisions beyond those in attachment one for these three topics.
Deputy Carrick-Ashley will be here to discuss these sections with you in a bit.
The next few sections on the slide were discussed by the CPAG, but not discussed at any of the 14 meetings, so there is more new information in the survey results and correspondence.
For access to educators, staff proposes to provide more clarity in the California Terms and Definitions table in the plan, especially for intern, misassigned, and out-of-field teachers.
We've heard from folks that there's some confusion about that and some concern about that.
So we want to go back and take a closer look at that and provide clarifications.
For school conditions, we propose to further expand the language in Attachment 1 to be more clear about specific supports.
For school transitions, we propose to add more information about supporting the transition from early education to the K-12 system.
to change K-12 to P-12, wherever appropriate in the plan, to reference the role of the LCAP addendum in articulating transitions, and to revise the section to reflect recent policy changes in two of the higher education systems.
I had the pleasure of presenting to the Intersegmental Coordinating Committee, and I shared this section of the plan with them.
And they're like, oh, but we don't do that anymore.
So I was really glad to be able to talk to them so we can make sure that our plan reflects most current policies with our other segments.
We're not proposing any additional changes to Title I, Part C, Education of Migratory Children Beyond Attachment 1.
For Title I, Part D, we propose to make the purpose of the program more clear, because there's been some question about that, and to reference the alternative accountability indicators and tools.
For Title II, Part A, we propose to add more clarity around specific types of professional learning and the need to address the teacher shortage.
Deputy Tom Adams will be here in a bit to talk more about all of the proposed revisions to this section.
For Title III, we propose to add new language about guidance, tools, and toolkits to support English learners.
And we don't propose any additional revisions beyond what's in Attachment 1 for the remaining sections of the plan.
So again, we do apologize that you weren't able to get the complete report earlier, but we're happy that you have the complete report now.
So moving back to Attachment 1, where most of the proposed revisions reside, we really have three types of revisions, three things we really need to accomplish.
First, many of those proposed revisions are in response to stakeholder feedback, but within the policy framework that you established earlier this year.
We heard you very clearly when you directed us to write the plan at a relatively high level, affording the state maximum flexibility to design programs and activities that are aligned with our LCFF-based system.
As President Kerr stated at the outset of this item, this is fundamentally an application for federal funds, a contract, and it does not serve us well to get way into the weeds with the United States Department of Education.
Second, we want to take your direction coming out of today's conversations regarding accountability and school support and improvement and integrate them into the next draft as appropriate.
And finally, we need to revisit the state plan peer review criteria and make sure that the plan meets those criteria to the greatest extent possible.
Back in March, at the same time that the new template was made available, ED issued peer review criteria for Title 1A,
Title III Part A, and the McKinney-Vento sections of the plan.
Now that ED has returned plans to the states that submitted their plans early, we have a better idea about how they're using that peer review criteria.
And we've also been able to speak with a couple of peer reviewers to learn from their experiences.
What we've heard is that peer reviewers have been directed to look for completeness.
There is no partial credit for incomplete answers.
It's just binary.
And there is no additional credit for providing detail above and beyond what is required.
One reviewer suggested that we treat the plan like a deposition.
Answer the question completely, but once you've answered, stop talking.
So let's look a little bit at how aligning our current draft to the Bureau review criteria might work.
So here are a couple, and I apologize, that's not easy to read, but that's a long one that provides a really good example.
Here are a couple of the peer review criteria for the accountability section of the plan, Title I-A of accountability, and I'll read them.
Does the SEA describe the academic achievement indicator used in its statewide accountability system, including that the SEA uses the same indicator for all schools and all LEAs across the state?
Yeah, our current draft does do that.
It's pretty explicit.
These are our indicators, and this is how we're going to use them.
Then we get to the one right after that, which you can see is much more lengthy.
I won't read the whole thing because there are a lot of ifs as opposed to shalls.
But it says, does the description include how the SEA calculates the indicator, including that the calculation is consistent for all schools in all LEAs across the state, a description of the weighting of reading language arts achievement relative to math achievement, and then the rest are ifs, so I'm going to stop.
This calculation requirement isn't in the plan template.
So our current draft of the plan, it's likely to be in the section of law, but this section of the plan does not clearly say, describe how we calculate.
We can, we clearly calculate it, and we will.
But this is an example of how we go in, how we'll need to go back in and revisit
these peer review criteria more closely to make sure that we are addressing exactly what ED would like to see from us and be as complete as possible with that.
Here are a couple more for school conditions.
Does the SEA describe how it will support LEAs receiving assistance under Title I Part A to improve school conditions for student learning?
Our current draft does talk a lot about our LCFF-based system and how we're very interested in school climate and how school conditions are something that is just a big piece of our LCFF-based system.
But when we get to the second one, does the SEA's description include how it will support LEAs to reduce incidences of bullying and harassment?
The current draft doesn't have that answer to that specific question.
So this would be another example where we would take a look at the peer review criteria and build it out to just very specifically say, this is how we are doing this.
So that's what we mean when we propose to align the Title I Part A, Title III Part A, and McKinney-Vento sections of the plan more closely to the peer review criteria.
We don't anticipate that it will result in substantive changes.
In fact, it is likely to help us to adhere to the meet not exceed policy that you all have put forth.
Down at the bottom of the slide, you can see it because I think people have.
We looked at the peer review criteria in March and we started crafting our plan based on that.
But clearly, these sections of the plan, like our Title I sections, have undergone many revisions since then.
So it's just a good time to go back, revisit.
and make sure that we're meeting those expectations.
So, for folks who have more questions about the peer review criteria, they are available.
There's a link to them on our CDESO webpage, and there's the direct link provided on this slide.
So, here's our recommendation for today.
We're going to need to amend the motion to account for the proposed revisions in attachment four, but we can do that when we get closer to the end of the item.
And again, those are relatively minor revisions, but we want to make sure to do this properly.
We're recommending that the board approve the revisions to the ESSA state plan proposed in attachment one.
So I have some good news.
After reviewing the public comment, staff has determined that the plan sections on this slide need only relatively minor revisions.
Most of these sections did not receive a whole lot of public comment, indicating that most Californians are comfortable with the drafts.
Given their relative completeness, we have not prepared presentations for the topics on this slide today.
To be clear, although we're not going to be presenting on these sections, we will be asking you to approve the revisions for these planned sections as described in attachments one and four.
Staff is here if you have any questions or want to discuss the proposed revisions for any of these sections.
So we're not going to be talking about these much today.
We're going to focus on the ones that have gotten a lot of public comment and where we have made some significant advances.
But staff is here ready to provide additional information as needed so we can get these sections updated as well.
We've prepared presentations for the planned sections on this slide.
The first five topics have received a lot of public comment and there's been progress made on several fronts that we want to discuss with you.
Carrick will present the first three topics on the slide and Tom Adams will follow with the next two.
Title IV, Part A, the Student Support and Academic Enrichment Grants, did not receive a lot of public comment.
But there are some relatively new developments with this program that we want to discuss with you.
And Chief Deputy Glenn Price will be here to share that part of the presentation.
So with that, I'll invite Carrick up to start talking about assessment, try and move some of my
I'll leave that one in case you need it.
Good afternoon.
Carrick Ashley, Deputy Superintendent, Performance Planning and Technology Branch.
So assessment, this won't be, this section won't be a long presentation.
Assessment was one of those sections of the ESSA state plan, draft plan that, you know, was fairly well defined already.
But you may remember from our May discussion, we did have a discussion over a native language assessment, which we'll address here in the next slide.
But as far as stakeholder feedback, we received over 300 comments.
The respondents included different people, teachers, principals, administrators, professionals, and so forth.
The public comment pretty much mirrored what we also heard from our CPAG, our advisory group.
Some of these comments included support for expansion of CASP to be more reflective of the full breadth of curriculum.
The comments include a lot of comments on the California Spanish Assessment or CSA, support for using that assessment in accountability, discussion about the eligibility requirements for who would take the assessment, the purpose of the assessment, and whether students would take both CSA and Smarter Balanced.
Those were all comments that came in through the public feedback process.
Most comments were consistent with CPAC comments.
So taking all of those comments, both from our discussions with CPAC and our discussions with stakeholder feedback, we're going to revise the plan.
The proposal is to revise the plan with this paragraph.
It's actually a sentence, just a very long one, here that's on the slide that I'll go ahead and read.
California will engage in conversations with stakeholders and experts in the field of language acquisition, measurement, and accountability over the course of developing the CSA with the goal of obtaining direction from the state board regarding the use of a valid and reliable CSA in accountability.
So that's the full extent of the proposed revisions in the assessment section.
We can come back and take questions later.
The other section or the second section that we're going to talk about, we've skipped over accountability in the list and we're going to school support because again, we just had a separate board item on the system of support.
But that stakeholder feedback, as you will see, talked about more information about the roles of CCEE and county offices.
I think we had this discussion at the last item that we just went on.
A focus on needs assessment and root causes, root cause analysis, which is also something that you as a board discussed in the last item.
creating a coordinated system that is responsible, again, to local needs and resources, something, again, that we discussed.
It's like we wrote the slide after item two.
And then, of course, addressing the timeline for the evaluation and the exit of improvement status.
All of those things were discussed in the last item.
And there's no proposed revision to that section at this time.
Accountability.
We need your help.
We still have some decisions to make on accountability.
And so this will take up most of the presentation in terms of the sections that I'm presenting to you this afternoon.
I just want to make a couple of comments before we get to the actual slide here of identifying the lowest performing 5% of schools, Title I schools, which is required by ESSA.
And that is just to
acknowledge some of the things that have brought us here to this point.
One, a commitment by this board to make this a thoughtful, deliberate process in developing a system of accountability.
A commitment to giving stakeholders multiple opportunities
through that deliberate and thoughtful process to have comments into that system, including groups like our CPAG group and our technical design group.
A commitment that this system is going to be state driven and not federal driven.
A commitment to having a single integrated accountability and support system.
You've made a commitment also to the continuous improvement process by designing a system that does both status and growth.
And finally, a commitment to a system that believes that all schools can improve, all districts can improve and should improve.
with a specific intention of narrowing achievement gaps.
So as we talk about, even as we talked in the last item about systems of support, that's about providing resources to a select group of LEAs.
But this system, as we've talked about it, is designed to address every school, to address every district, because everyone can get better.
Every subgroup can get better.
But we do need to pay special attention to certain subgroups that need to grow faster than others because of achievement gaps.
So with that, we're going to start into this identification of lowest performing 5% of schools.
We've talked about this in previous board items.
This will be based on attachment two in the board item that you have.
You can also, I will sometimes refer back to two memos that have been provided to the board.
There was an April memo on this topic, as well as a June memo that was extremely dense with a lot of colorful little dots.
which is a reflection of how complicated this can get very quickly.
And because of that, fortunately for me, I have others that will help me with that.
Cindy Kazanas is here, as well as Jenny Singh, whose office is the
the main architect behind the data simulations that we've seen.
And because the state board staff and CD staff have worked so closely together, I would even offer David Sapp to assist as we're going through.
So if there's anything that I haven't quite explained correctly, fortunately, I've got some very smart people who are behind me and close by, Cindy, Jenny, and David, who can help.
Let me explain something perhaps better or even correct something that I've not quite got right.
So starting with this identifying a 5%.
So based on the eligible schools, remember the lowest 5% is based on schools that receive Title I funding.
That 5% is approximately 298 schools.
Sorry, did I skip over a slide?
Thank you.
298 schools is what makes up currently 5% of Title I. Now, this will change slightly next year.
And when we release the new dashboard in the fall, by that time, we'll have a new count of Title I schools.
So the 5% could actually change a little bit for purposes of the simulations.
And what we've presented to you, it's based on 2015-16, which is 298 schools in Title I.
That would make up the 5% that we have to identify.
So in the June memorandum, we did have, again, three options presented as part of that memorandum.
Three options included this idea of identifying it based on all applicable indicators.
treating them equally across all, whatever indicators are applicable to an individual school, treating them all equally.
That was option one.
Option two was to use all applicable indicators, but do this weighting of one over another, perhaps weighting
something higher than the others, or weighting something lower than the other indicators.
And then the third option, what's referred to as the waterfall, is just to start with one indicator, see if you get 5%.
If you don't, go to a second indicator, add in some more schools, go to a third indicator, which is also a weighting.
It's just a different sort of weighting.
So after all the discussions that we've had with you, the indications we've gotten from you and from the feedback from stakeholders, CDE is recommending that we use option one, which is the all applicable indicators, and to use those all applicable indicators in an equal fashion, not weighting one greater than the other.
This is consistent which was recommended by the technical design group as well as receiving the strongest public support.
So at the May meeting, many of you made comments that what we would like to do is to link that 5%, which is based on Title I schools only and identifying schools, with the commitment that we've already made in LCFF, which is identifying LEAs or school districts.
for support and assistance.
And so we did have attempted from that May meeting to link the two processes in order to meet that goal of having a single local, state, and federal accountability system that's based on continuous improvement and it's not a separate system.
It's based on LCFF and the eight state priorities.
So,
was not the slide I was expecting to come up next.
But I'll go ahead and go with it.
So the idea of identifying and linking these two, whether it's schools or districts, we want to work through districts to ensure that the supports that we provide also are aligned so that the assistance that we're giving to schools are the same as what we're giving to districts and the resources available to them.
And we're trying to build capacity for LEAs so that they can turn around
and provide support to all schools, not just those identified, but all schools within their district.
And again, to work all of that within the LCAP process.
So the baseline methodology.
So in trying to come up with a linking process of this 5% and LCFF, we have proposed a two-step.
What we are proposing is a two-step process that would do that linking.
The first is what we would do, which we refer to as a baseline methodology.
And that is that we want to make sure that whatever process we use will make sure that we identify
what here we're calling the very low performing schools.
That would be the schools with all reds or all reds and one orange.
I would prefer to refer to them as schools in the greatest need of assistance.
And so that's probably how I'll be referring to them in the rest of these slides.
But we want to make sure, because what we looked at in the data and I think what you saw in the memos is the idea that
If we just take the schools from the LCFF districts that have been identified through the state process.
we're going to miss some schools that are very low performing.
So we need, and we talked about this at the last board meeting, we need a safety net, if you will, to make sure that we address the needs of very low performing schools or schools in the greatest need of assistance who may not reside currently in a school district that is identified for LCFF support.
So first would be to identify through this two-step process.
First, we have on this slide, as you can see on the left side, it is the ones that are identified by our student group performance through our state law of LCFF, where there's a student group that hasn't met two or more of the indicators.
And I think we had 181 districts identified through that process.
The second step of that process was to identify these very low performing schools, schools in greatest need of assistance, all red or all red and an orange, that aren't residing in one of those 181 districts and use that as a criteria to say,
You may not have made the list, if you will, of those eligible for this system of support.
because of LCFF, but we are going to make you eligible on a different basis, and that is by having one of these schools that's in greatest need of assistance.
So when we looked at the data, that added an additional 25 LEAs to the 181, which gets you to the bottom of the slide, means we have 206 LEAs now who would be identified for level two support.
181 identified through the state process,
Another 25 that would be identified through this new process, assuming you would approve it, which is to take a look at the schools that are in greatest need of assistance and add those districts where those schools reside along with those identified through the state process.
So I actually already talked about this slide, which is the definition of what it means to be a school in greatest need of assistance.
And that is all red or perhaps all red and one orange.
And make that a second criteria in identifying LEAs.
I should have been pushing these slides here more.
I've gone through a couple of them already.
So based on the data simulations, 181, as I mentioned, identified through LCFF.
That's per the criteria that you've already adopted back in September.
59 schools in need of greatest assistance are located in those LEAs.
And then, as I said, an additional 25 would be added to the 181.
And out of those 25 LEAs, 31 schools are identified as in need of greatest assistance, getting us to the number of 206 LEAs that would then be eligible for this support.
I should point out that there was
error in attachment to.
I want to say, I wrote it down here, page four in the third paragraph, we made reference to the number 90 there.
And because 90 shows up so much, it slipped its way into that paragraph where that number really should be 34.
So if you're paying attention, if you're following in that attachment to on page four, third paragraph, where you see the number 90 in the third paragraph, that really should be the number 34.
So what we are recommending is to you today that would then end up in our as a state plan is this idea of this baseline methodology in which we do the safety net of identifying those greatest schools in need of support and add those to the LEAs that were identified that have been identified through the state LCFF system.
So we started having to identify 298 schools.
And if we apply this methodology of the various schools that need greatest assistance and adding these additional schools in, that identifies 90 schools.
That still leaves us 208 schools that we need to identify further.
So that process that I just identified for you does this linking of LCFF to the 5%.
But again, we still need to identify to meet that 5% requirement 208 schools to make up our 5%.
So there are an additional three options that we could use to do that with.
Option one is we could take those LEAs that we've identified in this linking process by using LCFF and the baseline methodology, take those districts, those 181 plus the 25, and select the remainder of those 208 schools from that pool.
And so what that would leave us is a 5% that made up of, completely made up of the 206 LEAs that are identified through LCFF and this linking process.
That would be option one.
CDE could set some criteria to do that.
Perhaps it's all reds and yellow.
We could identify what colors would be included in that process to identify the remaining 208 districts.
Option two is not too dissimilar from option one, but option two
says instead of setting a firm criteria by which CDE determines completely who those 208 schools are, provide some flexibility to those 206 LEAs that are identified for assistance and allowing them to have a place in that process to identify their own schools to make up the remainder of that 5%.
Then there is option three,
I should mention, bottom of the slide, option two probably would, probably not probably, would require us to get some sort of a waiver from the US Department of Education because the state is supposed to identify these schools, not LEAs.
Option three would be
Disregard the 206 districts that we've identified for support and just identify the lowest 5% across all districts.
So what this would do is, once you do that, you could add them to the pool of the 206.
We are not recommending option three because it's the one that's least likely or the least aligned to LCFF.
It would basically almost triple the number of additional LEAs needing support.
And again, it puts more emphasis on the all students group versus the student subgroups.
What we are recommending is that the board, again, approve the all applicable indicator.
approve the baseline methodology that would link the two, the LCFF and the 5%, and then provide us some direction on those three options that I just provided to you in terms of identifying the rest of the 208 schools to make up the 5%.
So.
We'll have discussion, I guess, after.
I've got a couple more items to go through.
Along with this is this, we do have to talk about participation rate.
That's also a part of the accountability section in the SSA plan.
As you remember, under NCLB, there was a requirement to make sure that all schools and districts tested 95, no less than 95 percent of their students in English Language Arts and Mathematics, and that was part of the accountability system.
The old AYP, I hate to even mention it, but I do in that in the old system, if you didn't make the 95% participation rate, you failed AYP automatically.
94.4%, you failed.
So, fortunately, under ESSA, they give that responsibility to states on how to implement the 95% participation rate in the accountability system.
So it's us to make that determination of what to do, how to put it into the accountability system, and then how to respond to school districts that don't make that 95% participation rate.
So in discussions,
that we've had, we talked about the idea of putting some sort of a symbol or an icon as part of the dashboard that would symbolize whether the school or the district made the 95% participation rate and we put that icon or that symbol on the dashboard.
So with that, we would then make in response to that, we do have to have some response to it.
And what we're recommending is a differentiated response, not an automatic fail of some sort of a system.
But if you failed it by a small amount, perhaps there would be a light touch, a letter to the district, maybe get something back that says why they didn't make the participation rate.
Perhaps if it was, you know, not 85% or, you know, quite a bit lower, you know, perhaps we would have them drop some sort of a, you know, what are you going to do to encourage it next year?
It might depend on whether they had a lot of parent opt-outs or not.
Because that's a different solution than one that didn't have many parent opt-outs.
So what I'm suggesting is a differentiated approach to how and how we would respond to those schools that don't make the 95 participation rate.
So as we've had public comment, it was about half and half.
Half kind of liked the idea, yeah, put a symbol up there, address these issues on a case-by-case basis, and that's good.
The other half said, we don't think a single symbol does enough.
So we went back, did some talking about this.
And perhaps what we want to do is multiple icons that would represent different things.
For instance, you can see the bullets here.
You can have one icon to identify whether both the school and each subgroup met the 95% participation rate, or a second icon that would identify whether they met it school-wide but not met for each student group.
Perhaps a third icon that would represent someone who made somewhere between 85 and 95, which would be less severe consequence than perhaps somebody who made less than 85%.
So basically make up different icons to give parents in the community a little more information rather than just a yes or a no.
And so that is what CDE is recommending, that we use multiple icons.
I don't think you necessarily want to get in the business of defining what that icon is, whether it's a diamond or a smiley face.
But the recommendation is that we use multiple icons in the dashboard, again, to let the public know how a school did in terms of participation rate.
Then the last thing in the accountability section that we need to talk about are long-term and interim goals.
So there is a requirement in the state plan to identify both
Long-term goals and then interim progress toward those goals.
Again, this is a conversation that we've had, I think, at a couple of meetings now.
You'll see from down below that we are required to do this, setting long-term goals and interim progress goals for the assessments that we have, the cohort graduation rate, and the assessment for English learners, the progress that English learners are making.
So the California model, what we're calling California model, the five-by-five color grid, if you remember, already really has long-term goals built in.
Through the color-coded process, we've talked about how we would like our goal is for all schools to reach a green or better in each of the indicators.
And that the green performance level is certainly a logical place to do that.
But there are several different green boxes, if you remember cells, if you remember.
And I think we've got a slide next that shows it, yes.
So as you can see, the one that's kind of almost right in the middle there that has the orange outline to it, that's based on, again, status and growth.
those schools or districts that are high and have maintained that high status.
The recommendation is that we use that as the long-term goal, both the high and the maintained of that high, and that we would consider any of those greens to the right or certainly the blues as being exceeding that goal.
The one that probably
we probably should talk a little bit about is the one green cell that is just above that green goal, that would be our long-term goal, and to the left, which is very high status, but they've declined recently.
So the very high status, but declined.
So that could go either way with that, whether we consider that meeting the target or not.
With public comment, as we went through this, we've had, let me get to that.
I think that comes later.
But I'm going to go ahead and say it now.
Through public comment, the public comment that we've gotten on this is that it would be much, much more simple and much more understandable and much easier to explain to public and to parents if,
all green indicators were considered meeting that goal and not leave one of them out simply because most recently they've declined because that one is a very high status.
So that was the comment that received back that it would be very difficult to explain to people why they are very high and haven't met it.
And then there's the timeline for this long-term goal.
Sorry, let me make one.
So that's the long-term goal, our recommendation of green.
And then the interim progress goals, the system is, again, the system that you've designed and built based on status and growth in these cells.
already allows, once we set that long-term goal for school districts, individual schools, school districts, charter schools, county offices, to take a look at that long-term goal, see where they are currently, and then they can set that goal for interim progress of how they're going to get
to that long-term goal.
And that, of course, if you are in a lower status than others in a certain subgroup, they, of course, within the same timeline, would have to make greater growth.
And that addresses the issue of narrowing the achievement gap.
So the system's already built once we establish a long-term goal for districts and schools to be able to identify what their interim progress is.
And built into that system is the idea that lower student groups would have to make greater growth.
to meet the goal within the timeline.
We talked last time a timeline of five to seven years after looking at the comments that we got from, not comments, we got comments other states got from peer review process that saying five to seven is unlikely to be successful.
That what they want is a single digit, not a span of years.
And so we are recommending that that timeline be seven years.
So in the end of seven years, we take a look at it and reestablish those goals.
So again, I think I've hit all of these on the long-term goal.
The five to seven, these are the public comments.
I should say on the public comment slide that some of the comments we made was that, ooh, more time is better than less time.
So which is why we ended up with the seven years.
Five years was just not enough to kind of get used to the system and try to meet our goals.
And so the comments from most folks were that seven years would be better than five years.
Longer, better than shorter.
And then we talked about interim progress.
Talked about all blue-green cells as the recommendation.
And we talked about the timeline of the recommendation of seven years.
So that's the end of the accountability section.
Am I turning it over to?
I'd like to introduce Tom Adams, Deputy Superintendent of Teaching and Learning Branch.
for that clear explanation of such a difficult, complex thing.
Okay.
Good afternoon.
I'm the Deputy Superintendent for the Teaching and Learning Support Branch.
Just for your information, what that means is really I have the welcome additions of special education and expanded learning to my branch.
And so I'm really happy that Kristen Wright and Michael Funk, both those division directors, are becoming part of my team.
And definitely we're all looking forward, we're looking forward for all of us working together.
Just a note here.
This is probably my 19th year of presenting before the board.
So unlike Melanie Shope, please forgive me if my presentation is of low wattage and waning enthusiasm.
Look, my topic is ineffective and my wife told me, you know, you're so appropriate for that.
This is great following Carrick after I feel lively now.
So, Title I, Part A, Access to Educators.
So, ESSO requires us to actually deal with three categories in terms of educators, inexperienced, out of field, and ineffective teachers.
This is important because as you talked at your last board meeting, one of the most important issues is equity of instruction or equity of educators for our students.
And in terms of our public input on ineffective teacher, there was common agreement on the need for a consistent statewide definition.
But I just want to add what's not on the slide here.
No one was calling for anything tied to test scores or some type of value-added model that maybe was part of the debate a few years ago.
No one actually went there.
There was in the discussion a desire not to disrupt good practices that are happening at the local level.
In that sense, there are people already have issues, have addressed the issue of ineffective teacher and how to remedy that at the local level.
But they all recognize there is a challenge in terms of creating a consensus of the definition of ineffective teacher.
Constraining us, or maybe not constraining us, but being our North Star way of
really thinking about this, though, is we had to think about it in the context of LCFF and Greatness by Design.
Greatness by Design, as you know, it has a lot of good recommendations in there about educator equity and ineffective teachers.
So we have, we do have a very good document on guidance to local school districts on how to remedy those situations and how best to do it.
Local control funding formula.
That should be LCFF, not LCCF.
Imagine a bureaucrat getting his acronyms wrong.
But the key there is I think we all suffer from, or at least I can speak for myself, I do suffer from post-traumatic NCLB syndrome, right?
And I do want to have one system of accountability
the LCAP and be able to have a unitary system of support.
So, we want to make sure that ineffective teacher built upon LCFF priority one, which is to focus on whether teachers are either misaligned or teaching without a credential.
So, California in the state plan will meet that requirement by reporting at the school and district levels data about the various credential statuses recognized by the state or the California Commission on Teacher Credentialing.
And let me just repeat that.
It's about really when it comes down to the credential status.
And why is that?
Because that's the system we have in place.
One of the things we want to do here in California in this as a state plan is one, reinforce our LCFF and LCAP system.
And two, build it upon the systems that already exist there in place, which is our credentialing process.
So these multiple data points then will provide a more complete picture of the educator workforce at school, district, and state levels.
Data could also provide the basis for development of local plans for equitable access to teachers.
One of the things we want to make sure is that credentialed teachers and where they are in terms of if they're
pre-credential where they are, make sure that they're evenly distributed across the district and equitable distributions to the different schools in the district.
And so in that sense, it's important for us then to note that by focusing on the credentialing process, we are using that to ensure educator equity.
Okay.
So, then it becomes the issue of supporting effective instruction, Title II Part A. Because as we know, it's one thing to have, to examine the credentialing process and where people are.
It's another thing to actually have opportunities to keep our teachers on a cycle of continuous improvement.
And so we have two opportunities in terms of state work level, in terms of Title II Part A. There's statewide activities at 5% and leadership activities at 3%.
And that should be school leadership initiatives.
As you know, we talked a little bit about California system and support earlier.
Just to reinforce equity, we want to be in terms of the public comment when we went out there.
As well as similar to today's discussion, we want equity to be the focus.
However, public comment wanted us to provide more details to match the aspirations.
They wanted to support existing efforts and partnerships that we have with county offices and the California Subject Matter Projects.
I kind of think of this as our friends telling us, hey, don't forget us.
Remember all the good work we've done already, so we want to keep doing it.
They wanted us to address new areas of professional learning, such as restorative practices, social-emotional learning, and working with traumatized youth.
Public input also wants school leaders to know evidence-based practices and how to support teachers in their work.
And this is something we've also found in our standards implementation process as well.
And public input wanted us to include a plan to address teacher shortages in science, math, special education, and bilingual education.
So some of the proposed revisions.
An equity planning process for Title II Part A, the 5% set aside for statewide activities.
And here we go with the regional support structure.
LEA leadership teams would collaborate to address equitable issues within their districts and schools and focus on LEA-led solutions.
Let me say that again, LEA-led solutions through intra- and inter-district collaboration.
So as much as it would be a regional support, there would also be this opportunity to go thematic and address issues that may not just be addressed within your own regional resources.
And we want to make sure that is coordinated with the proposed California school leadership system.
So that gets to the 3% set aside.
This is a subgrant and it's to develop expertise and capacity within the statewide system of support to strengthen school leaders' abilities to address inequities by supporting teachers and engaging students.
This is something we also found that was important if you look at our standards implementation process in the different content areas.
One of the key features in all the four content areas that we have built out so far in terms of their aspirations of where we need to go is to improve the professional learning for administrators.
And here we're not just talking about the single charismatic principal coming at a school site.
We're really talking about leadership in the broadest sense that it's shared and that it's collaborative.
Other important revisions include supporting the standards implementation via the curriculum framework rollout, something I've already mentioned before.
Affirm the continued support of the California Subject Matter Projects and their vital role in innovative professional learning.
Just a note here, remember a lot of our frameworks rely on writers and developers who are connected to or part of the California Subject Matter Project.
And use Title II Part VIII funds to improve equitable access to teachers.
That's going to be an important part now that we'll be collecting data.
Actually saying, okay, now what do we do with this?
How do we make it work well for our students?
And lastly, plan to increase the number of teachers in teacher shortage areas such as science, math, special education, and bilingual education.
It shouldn't say a plan, it's more we will create a plan.
And we'll note that in the ESSA plan.
That is my final slide there.
I'm happy now to turn over the microphone and podium to Chief Deputy Superintendent Glenn Price.
Thank you, Tom.
Thank you, Carrick.
And thank you, Barb, for awesome presentations.
And I'd like to continue the discussion into the area of Title IV, Title IV Part A. And I think this is a really important opportunity for the state of California to take this tranche of federal funds and invest it in support of our state priorities.
And there's been a couple of changes in Title IV Part A since we last met in May, that even though it's a smaller part of the ESSA State Plan, really necessitates some board discussion and guidance as we move forward.
So Title IV Part A is known as the Student Support and Academic Enrichment Grants Program.
And it aims to increase the capacity of LEAs in three areas.
First is well-rounded education, safe and healthy students, and effective use of technology.
So some of the things that ESSA talks about in the area of well-rounded educational opportunities line up quite a bit with priorities that we've been working on in the state of California.
College and career guidance, STEM, including computer science projects,
foreign language, environmental education, and other activities that can support a well-rounded education.
And safe and healthy students, also some key activities cited that really line up well with our work in California, particularly around in Priority 6 of LCFF, drug and violence prevention, school-based mental health services,
preventing bullying and harassment and other areas in a similar vein.
In technology, looking at a variety of efforts, we're limited there to 15% in one of our options and 25% to what can actually be invested in infrastructure, but there's a significant emphasis on the use of technology in our classrooms and schools.
So three important areas, and this program was newly authorized when ESSA
excuse me, when ESEA was reauthorized.
So, some important transitions in the funding kind of history, recent history of Title IV Part A. When Congress first authorized ESEA or reauthorized, they included 1.6 billion and everybody in the nation kind of stood up and cheered and said, yay, we're going to get some funding, significant funding in this area.
But then when it came time to the Omnibus Budget Bill, Congress only allocated $400 million in fiscal year 2017.
And it's allocated, importantly, as a one-time allocation.
And it's probably also important to remember, even though Congress hasn't received well the President's budget plan, that for that plan for 2018-19, there's a proposal to eliminate totally funding for this program.
There's two ways that the funding can be allocated to the state of California.
The first would be to do it as a formula grant, and the second would be to do it as a competitive grant.
And I'll talk briefly about those as we move along.
But to keep in mind, in terms of the overall
overall funding amount of that $400 million that would be allocated nationally.
We sometimes think, you know, in California, whatever is allocated nationally will get about 10 to 13 percent.
And that's the case here.
We'll get exactly $46,418,059.
Of which 95%, whichever option we pursue, needs to be allocated directly to LEAs.
4% can be used for state level activities and 464,000 or no more than 1% can be used for administration.
The thing to keep in mind, and I won't dive too deep in the weeds on it around Title IV Part A, is that there is also the opportunity to transfer Title IV Part A funds that can be transferred to other titles, both at the LEA level and at the SEA level, we can transfer the state-level activity funds.
So as we went out for stakeholder feedback, as Barb mentioned earlier, there wasn't a ton of stakeholder feedback around Title IV Part A. And the important thing to keep in mind, too, is that the stakeholder feedback came before the passage of the omnibus budget bill and it came on the prior draft of the plan when we didn't know yet that there would be the competitive option.
So stakeholders were reacting to what was in our plan, which was based on the formula option only.
There was a call, as in many other areas of the plan, for more detail, for historical context, and some questions around how these grants would be implemented.
A significant call for inclusion in guidance materials, ideas for how LAs might use the funds in different areas.
and for including them in a birth to age 8 continuum.
There was, you know, comments around how we might target the funds and support using them potentially for support for professional development.
So we'd like guidance from the board on which option we should pursue for Title IV Part A. And there's two major ones.
The first would be to do a formula allocation.
And how this would work is that LEAs would receive allocations based on their share of Title I Part A funds.
So how many
Title I students they have in their districts.
There must be a $10,000 minimum grant and grantees who receive more than $30,000 would need to conduct a needs assessment every three years.
The way that the regulations are structured, if the formula allocation were pursued,
LEAs at the LEA level would need to spend 20% on well-rounded education, 20% on safe and healthy students, so these are the categories of funding, and no more than 15% on technology infrastructure.
Under option two, a competitive grant, which is the recommendation that we're making, we would seek to award and prioritize the awards based on greatest need, geographic diversity, those are required.
We could also set additional priorities per our state priorities for the competition.
And we would also be required to ensure that $10,000 minimum grant
It would be a one-year term, but the funds could be spent over a longer period than that.
And importantly, we would only be required at the state level to maintain the percentage of funds being allocated.
So at least 20% at the state level on well-rounded education, 20% on safe and healthy students, and no more than 25% on technology infrastructure.
This would allow LEAs to come forward either individually or as consortia with proposals focused on a particular area.
And then at the state level, we would make sure that we were hitting on these categories of 20% for well-rounded 25% for safe and healthy students.
So we're recommending that the board provide us guidance to pursue the competitive grant as part of the next version of the ESSA state plan with the parameters that I described.
The reasons there are that we feel that this would really support LEAs and their schools to engage in some real innovation and creativity around how they might come forward with ways to address the needs in their districts.
It will provide us as a state the opportunity to really collect lessons learned and sustainable strategies that we can infuse into our technical assistance.
And it will allow us to calibrate this work with our developing statewide system of support that you discussed under Board Item 2.
So we're recommending Option 2 under Title IV Part A, but bottom line is we're looking for guidance as to which option that you would like to pursue going forward.
So Title IV, I got the, as Chief Deputy, one doesn't get many perks.
But I did get to select which part of the presentation I would do.
So I got the short one.
And I think that concludes our presentation around the ESSA State Plan.
It's obviously a very pivotal moment for us as we move forward.
And we are, as Barb mentioned earlier, asking for your approval of the revisions contained in Attachment 1 and the minor ones contained in Attachment 4.
We'll bring back a draft to you in September 2017, but also be putting out a draft at the beginning of August for public comment and review.
So with that, turning the mic back over to you, President Kirst.
Okay.
And so in our following our typical order, we have, I would like to call on our
a federal liaison member, Ting Sun first, and she and I are the federal, the liaisons for federal aid.
We didn't have much business in the first three years or four, could wrap it up in a half an hour, right?
And so you would, I think, react first.
And I'd like you to just react, I think the best way to organize this is Carrick's, Carrick Ashley's presentation on accountability.
And we'll have a go around on that.
So, and then we'll go to title.
to Tom Adams' presentation, and then we'll go to the Title IV presentation because mixing them all together doesn't make much sense.
So could you make some comments from your position as federal liaison first, and then I'd like to go to Board Member Sandoval, who is liaison to special education next, given the amount of comments and letters about the data simulations
and how the special ed students figure into the identification of LEAs for support under LCFF.
So those two first, and then we'll go around the table.
Go ahead.
Thank you, President Kirst.
First, of course, I have to commend the CDE's work on pulling this data together.
and the analysis of various options under that Title One accountability.
I know it's a lot of work in a very short time.
And I recognize that the huge challenge of trying to jigsaw this LCFF with ESSA.
And so there was a lot of work in here.
I am comfortable with the proposed all indicators approach.
It's the most consistent with our approach to the LCFF.
by not giving weights on particular indicators.
And it seems to have the best, the most public support during that comment period.
I also appreciate the proposed baseline methodology.
I think it again lines with what we are developing under LCFF.
And under state law, we provide that assistance to LEAs and we look at all eight LCFF priorities as areas in that process.
So I think that's a good starting point for identifying schools and also focusing on how those schools get support.
I share, however, a lot of the concerns from stakeholders that focusing only on LEAs might leave out some very high need schools.
And I understand that this was a key point in some of the SBE discussions at our last meeting.
Identifying a group of very high need schools that are essentially struggling on all relevant indicators seems to be an important LEA criteria under LCFF.
So a district that is doing reasonably well overall, but has one of these schools clearly could use some support to figure out how to do better in meeting the needs of its students.
I think that makes sense.
The baseline, but we all know that the baseline methodology is not going to get us that 5%.
And I think that's where we've become very uneasy.
I know that while CDE thoroughly laid out the range of options for us, and I do see pros and cons of options one and two.
It doesn't seem to be a perfect solution.
And I think we're going to, we have a very, very challenging policy discussion and decision ahead of us on that.
I appreciate how important it is to many stakeholders that while we're identifying schools, then we're concerned that these are going to be labeling and shaming schools.
I think we do need to change our mindset.
And I think this has been repeated over again, that this is not the program improvement.
Oh, you're just a terrible school type of attitude.
This is about which schools do we need to provide attention and support to.
So,
But again, I go back to the limitations on the data that we currently have.
And this is where we go beyond.
I think most people are comfortable with the baseline methodology, but when we go beyond that.
And so I have to say that, you know, in
thinking about this over the last week and how we identify schools and what that next level is.
I am very uncomfortable with the fact that we don't have enough data at this point in time.
Indicators are not fully online.
There was, in reviewing the materials and the letters from the public, there was a lot of focus on specific numbers.
And I certainly was there making my charts, trying to figure out how to identify schools and what does that mean to different schools, to different LEAs.
And at the same time, we also know all these numbers are going to change as we continue to develop the R in that word of maturing, this maturing system.
So and interestingly enough, as we are looking to submit our ESSA plan, we know that in three months after the plan submission deadline, we're going to have updated data in the fall.
And that might provide us with additional and different information.
So rather than deciding on the detail of the methodology today,
I would prefer, I would propose that we decide on a general framework now and then flesh out the specifics of what we're, once we get more information in the updated dashboard.
And I one of the questions I have for staff is how how can we do that in the ESSA plan and then also provide us with a little bit more time as we gather more data so that we have some room to do some tweaking and some modifications as we get additional information.
So I don't see the benefit of committing to a September plan in a specific approach to the 5% based on the limited data that we currently have.
And I believe that the school identification for doesn't even start until the fall 2018.
So
I'm proposing that rather than come up with very specifics, that we come up with a framework within this ESSA plan and then give us some room to be able to look at more data moving forward.
So I'll stop there for now.
But I thought it would be important to put that out there at this time.
And then I want to hear from my fellow board members.
Just let me, as other federal liaison, clarify that the ESSA plan does not require us to identify the specific schools in the plan.
The ESSA operates in 2018-2019 cycle.
The LCFF, however, is in the 2017-2018 school year cycle.
So we have the option of passing now on identifying the remaining 3% and putting then in the plan the process we would use
Lots of districts have spoken to us in schools saying, you're using old data, that we would like much more current data.
And to identify schools using old data specifically has been an issue.
So that's, I think, part of the rationale that board member Sun is using.
Carrick Asher.
Let me just comment quickly and then I know you want to get other board comments.
So that's understandable and it certainly makes sense.
So I think if we have direction from you and approval on using baseline methodology and the all indicators, not waiting any, then I think we can bring back for you after we have data from the fall dashboard, updated information about where these schools and districts lay and we can have a more informed conversation then.
So I think we can work with that in terms of the SSA plan.
Okay, so that's your comment and then I made one and now Board Member Sandoval, why don't you go and then I'll start around the table.
Thank you.
I just want to acknowledge the thoughtful comments and responses to this particular item from our stakeholders.
And I read the feedback with great interest, especially as it relates to students with disabilities and discussions about this particular group.
because it's very clear, it's an alarming clarity that students with disabilities are consistently the lowest performing.
They are now and have been for many, many years.
And I think the promise of LCFF and us moving towards one system that is maturing as we speak is that we have an opportunity, I think, through multi-tiered systems of support to serve all of our students, to meet them where they need to be met,
And I was reading just the assertion that somehow the support system would be driven by students with disabilities and their performance.
And I think that the system that we are transitioning into
I don't see that happening.
I don't feel that somehow the resources will be diverted to other students because of including our students with disabilities into this one system.
And I think that what we've learned is that this bifurcated system does not serve our students well.
And that's not just students with disabilities, but any of our students.
So, I also want to remind us because this statistic has stayed with me for the last couple of years and it hasn't shifted very much.
70% of students with disabilities are a member of at least one of the LCFF groups.
So we're talking about the same students.
And I don't want to minimize the concerns at all.
But I also just learned that for foster youth, for every four foster youth, one of them is a student with a disability.
So we have to remember that we have to set up systems of support for all of our students.
And the intention is not to ignore the needs of students in the different LCFF groups at all.
And I think that our state systemic improvement plan prioritizing improved supports for all students is a shift in that direction.
I also see that what's happening in higher education, our partners in higher education colleges and universities with teacher preparation programs and credentialing.
Preparing our teachers to meet student needs in a general education environment is going to serve our students, not only with disabilities, but all of our students.
So I think that we have to move beyond the isolation of a previous system and focus again on one system that serves
all of our students.
And of course, this increased emphasis on differentiated instruction to meet the needs of all our students where they're at.
So I just want to make sure that we remain focused on a single system that's student-centered and that gives all of our teachers the support that they need to meet students' needs in a general education environment to the degree that we can do that.
Okay, thank you.
So I'm going to ask each board member if they want to comment.
I'll start with Board Member Holliday since I'm looking this way.
Carrick, were you the ineffective teacher that was... No, we're just now on... Oh, I'm sorry.
Wasn't this part of the...
It's part of it, but I'd like to do it topic by topic, sticking just with accountability.
Try and settle that, then go to the teacher.
I apologize, is the ineffective teacher part of the accountability section?
No.
I'm sorry.
No, go to Olivia next.
Okay.
I would make one other comment on the updating the data.
Talking about our Smarter Balanced Achievement results, educational researchers stress the longer trend line you have, the better your data.
This is a new test where we have two years of data.
If we could get a third year,
we would much better able to see the change factor there in that.
And so that's another argument for, to me, for updating the data, which is more of a technical longitudinal argument, but that I want to throw into the mix.
Board Member Strauss.
So first, I just want to thank First President Kurz for framing the issues that we are faced with in developing our ESSA plan and linking it to our LCFF plan.
So I thought those really helped to set the context.
And so I just want to thank you on that.
Also, I think it's just important to reinforce that our goal to go for a single coherent plan as best we can is, I believe, is the clear message in all of the work trying to connect it.
We know when we had NCLB and we had our
API, and we had AYP.
We're trying to do a better job this time.
And so, I do think it's a challenge because LCFF focuses on LEAs, which is important, and we're being challenged to also identify low-performing schools.
So, I actually really appreciate the challenging data runs that CDE has been doing and working with our staff as well to try to figure out what's the right way to go about this.
And actually really support the blended approach, if that's the right way to say it, where we identify the LEAs, but we don't leave out the most struggling schools.
Because I think under the LEAs in some districts, particularly based on housing patterns and things, you'll find a pocket of, say, low performing or more impoverished area.
in a higher performing district so they get masked and they get hidden.
And I don't think that any of us want that to happen.
So I really like the idea of identifying first LCFF, the districts that qualify for additional support, and then making sure we don't miss our most struggling schools.
So I support that methodology and that support.
The other thing is that, and thank you Member Sandoval for making the comment about our students with disabilities and how many of them are also English learners and low-income students as well, and that they often represent many groups.
And I think that while it may trigger the support
As service providers start to help LEAs, I feel like that may trigger the support, but LEAs may have all kinds of issues as they unpack their data and their root causes of what's going on, and it shouldn't limit the support.
once they're identified to say, well, your students with disabilities we're identifying, but your English learners are an issue as well, or your African American males, they're a problem and you need to give them support.
And so I don't think we mean to limit our support
certainly school districts and schools are identified.
But I think as I just want to make sure it's clear, at least an intent by this board, that the SERP support supports the LEA and the schools as they identify the variety of issues at their sites levels and their district levels and that the support providers should be able to specialize and differentiate the kinds of needs that are identified based on the data
and all their LCAP surveys and all their climate surveys and those things as well.
So, I don't believe it's the intent, at least I would say as a board member, it's not the intent to limit the support once you're identified for additional support.
That you're, you ought to be able to do your own data analysis.
And I think CCE is learning that as they help pilot districts and counties unpack the data that there are lots of complications
That they need to look at, particularly in the context of the that they're serving.
And so I just want to make that clear too, because I think there's a concern that while students and disabilities may trigger the identification.
there's other causes there as well and other needs that obviously need to be addressed in order to support the work.
So I thought, I think that's really important as well.
So I guess in summarizing the idea of a coherent system as best we can, not missing the lowest performing schools as we try to blend the methodology to me is a really important approach to consider.
So first, I just want to say thank you again to Cindy and Jenny, especially for all the work.
If you read the information memo, as Kerry described it as dense, it was a very complicated process to put it together.
And I really appreciate looking at it through the lens of LEAs, because that's the way we organize our schools in this state.
And that's the level at which change has to occur to get to the student-centeredness.
I really appreciate the approach.
I just want to support Member Sun's suggestion, and I think that we can talk conceptually about which structure we want to use, the baseline, you know, option three or option two or whatever, for purposes of public comment, so people understand what the concept is.
But in the absence of up-to-date data, we would be, it's a fool's errand in my view.
And I think we've been trying at the state level to model this continuous improvement and learning from what we have.
I'm not so sure the feds do.
Just as your point earlier, I want to underscore President Kirst, that we had NCLB for 17 years with no changes or very modest changes.
And we've made a commitment to be looking at our system all the time to be making changes.
So I think to the extent we can build in any level of flexibility or any foreshadowing that we will be doing addendums, we will be doing amendments as we learn more, we should do that.
We should not lock ourselves in to something that we can't change over time.
The other thing, and this is building off Member Strauss, and certainly I really appreciate Member Sandoval's comments.
In reading the letters, I was actually shocked by some of the letters that we got.
That there seemed to have been a fundamental misunderstanding that because the funding formula
is based on three groups for supplemental and concentration grants.
Those same three groups are going to come out the other end for purposes of support and assistance.
And if they didn't, then something's wrong with the system.
But that ignores the fact that we're looking at all kinds of subgroups, up to 13 subgroups, any of which can either trigger the support and assistance.
And as Member Sandoval eloquently said, many of which are represented in our students with disability group.
So,
Anyway, it just sort of made my head spin a little bit that there was, we just hadn't communicated that very well.
And I think just to reinforce what Member Strauss said that eligibility for assistance does not limit the kind of assistance that you're going to be providing to the LEAs.
as we talked a lot about in the last item, we hope to provide this assistance based on a very careful analysis of what the needs are at the LEA level.
Again, to use Member Rucker's student-centeredness comment, that's what it will be based on.
So this notion that somehow all the resources would be directed to one group, I just think sort of misses the mark.
And I want to make sure that we all, at least me, understand that that's the intent behind this.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Thank you.
I understand how difficult it is to sometimes convey all information and your everyday conversations into a memo.
And I have to say that I had to read the memo three times to get a better understanding.
And I have like notes upon notes trying to connect.
and identify the criteria for the first filter, then the second, and what the options were.
So, you know, if we could just be a little bit more mindful, I'm in Sacramento, I'm here, and I still had to really read it over and over, and I think that people would have a hard time understanding what is actually being proposed.
But once I got a better understanding of the material, I think that even if we try to delay the conversation because there's going to be additional indicators and more data, we're still going to wrestle with the same things that we had for the last two years.
And so we could delay the conversation because there's going to be additional information, or we could really try to target and have a very intentional conversation about the areas where there's still misalignment, there's still confusion,
and there's still a sense of vagueness about what is our capacity, what do we have to offer, how are we going to offer this.
The proposal that we have now identifies, so there was the 181 plus a 25, and I do appreciate that we're looking at lowest performing schools that didn't fall within the targeted or the phase one LEA cohort.
But if we identify LEAs based on LCFF, that's a one-year determination, so every year we'll be identifying them.
If we identify them because a school triggered that identification, does that put them in a three-year timeline for identification?
Because it was a school that triggered the identification under ESSA.
So there's those differences in the timeline.
There's also, and I do believe that we need an additional filter that does take into account the three student groups that are identified under LCFF.
And I think option two allowed for that.
So we still need to identify an additional 208 schools as of now that could change once we
run the data again.
But maybe a second filter would be looking through the three targeted LCFF subgroups.
One more thing, I felt that we made a mistake by not pulling out ELA and math from the high school as a state indicator.
having that embedded into the College Career Readiness Indicator, then sort of phased out the information or the identification of schools based on suspension and graduation and LPI, which doesn't apply to all students.
So we started with two indicators, none of which are ELA or math.
So I think that teasing those
Those data points from the Career College Indicator would give us a better understanding and a better sense of how we could identify schools that are lowest performing.
They're currently embedded into an index.
And I know that there was some pushback a little bit.
I felt that some of us wanted to make those state indicators, but then we went with putting them, embedding them into the College Career Readiness Index.
And when I read this memo, it made me understand that that was a mistake that we made, in my opinion.
Thank you.
Kara, could you address the first thing on these different cycles of time for LCFF?
And, you know, that's an, they would have to be, LCFF is identified, you know, on one cycle and the ESSA school's not.
Can you, okay, legal question.
It's not necessarily a legal question.
David Sapp, Deputy Policy Director for the State Board of Education.
So under the proposed approach, and this turns on what's also included as part of the recommendation and attachment to is the frequency for identifying schools under ESSA, the
The recommendation and attachment to says to make it every three years to clarify that because the current draft was not specific as to it would be every three years necessarily.
So if that is approved and basically it's saying you're only identifying the lowest performing schools every three years.
So this additional criterion for pulling, you know, identifying an LEA that has one of those schools but isn't identified under LCFF, that would occur only every three years if we're identifying schools only every three years.
We would still have under state law, the local control funding formula, the application of the criteria based on student group performance at the LEA level is annual.
So you would basically have the annual application of the criteria that the board approved last September and then starting in 18 and then every three years after this additional look at districts that may have one of these low performing schools.
I think that's one of the
one of the challenges of this idea of identifying schools over time of, you know, do you do it once every three years and really focus the improvement resources?
Do you do it more often, but then you have really diffuse in terms of what support is available, but then the overlay of, okay, what is, if we're focusing on districts as the, or LEAs as the way we support schools, it's gonna have to interact with our LEA-based accountability structure under state law.
So, there are sort of two different cycles that we're talking about under this blended approach, the baseline methodology that's described in attachment to.
The LCFF cycle is every year?
Correct.
Starting this fall.
So when we have, so we will have one cohort every year and then we'll have another one every three years.
And they will have, according to the recommendation, seven years to reach those state goals.
Now, we'll identify every three years, they'll have seven years.
We don't have a criteria to exit.
Do we know what happens if they don't exit?
Because I'm thinking capacity.
So now we have one, three, so our capacity model will have to go.
you know, at times it'll be that we'll have more capacity, other times we'll be stretched thin, and I have a hard time not putting all the system pieces together.
And I think that when we do, and again, we could wait till we have other data, but these questions will still be the questions we're struggling with a year from now, six months from now, because we've been struggling them for two years.
So, I want to make sure that we have
that we're very aware of all of the details that this requires because we need to align this and we need to make sure that our schools are actually receiving support.
In particular, if we're going to designate whether they're targeted or comprehensive, and I would like to see a designation in the dashboard, but if we're going to designate that they're receiving targeted or comprehensive, and we didn't speak much about targeted in the memo, then I think we owe it to them to actually give them support.
And what does that look like?
So to the question of the exit criteria, the May version of the plan that was what went out for public comment did include a section on the exit criteria.
So there are specified exit criteria in the current draft that went out for public comment, which is the criteria that are ultimately used to identify the lowest 5% of schools or the school identification would be applied at the end of that period of time to see
did they improve and get out of that sort of level of performance.
So those are the current proposed criteria in the plan.
I don't believe there's a recommendation to change that at this point.
So those criteria would be applied.
I think one challenge is we don't know
what those criteria are because you need to determine what the initial identification criteria are in some way.
So, but the sort of the basic structure, it was laid out in the draft plan.
It's just we didn't have the specific identification criteria.
And I think that's what the board is talking, you know, is grappling with right now about, okay, we have a baseline methodology, but what about the remaining 5%?
Board Member Rocker.
Okay, before I begin, I just wanted to ask, is the issue on the 95 percent participation rate part of the... Yes, that was part of, anything part of Carrick's presentation is what we're discussing now.
Okay, so I want to start with that since we didn't have a lot of comment on that.
I agree with the recommendation that the staff has made concerning the 95 percent.
participation rate.
In my time on the board, we have actually had LEAs come to the board with a waiver, begging forgiveness because they did not meet the 95% participation rate.
And the reasons for not meeting the 95% participation rate is, as Carrick pointed out,
an error on the part of the people responsible for administering the assessment plan.
I'm only aware of, at the school level, only a few school sites that came into problems or encountered problems on the participation rate because of parent opt-out.
And so the fact that we now have the flexibility to ensure that schools are not automatically sanctioned for the participation rate primarily because of parent opt-out, that's a wonderful thing.
But the fact is we do have LEAs that abuse their authority and their flexibility about how they identify and assign students and move students around to avoid having to test them based on their subgroup or based on who they are or what their likelihood is to hold the school back in some way.
So I think the flexibility to explore what exactly the 95% participation rate does or does not do
in providing or identifying a sanction to the school is a good thing.
So I do believe that the recommendation from the staff is important.
Turning to the other areas, it's very hard not to talk about, to talk about just this item in a vacuum without reflecting back on the conversation we had with two other items we looked at on this board agenda already.
today, particularly as relates to the system of support of prescribing that or even understanding how we're going to define some of the other elements in the criteria for our indicators in the LCFF.
So I think I also agree with and understand Board Member Sun's recommendation about how to do the identification, but I also have the concern that remains that I expressed in May.
It is not enough
to make sure that we are identifying the lowest-performing LEAs because the reality is we will miss districts who have high-flying, high-performing schools, but there will be pockets inside that same district where the school site itself is among the lowest-performing schools in the state.
So if this recommendation is going to hold a district like that accountable for their failure, because that is not a successful district.
That is a failing district.
They're not failing because they don't have high achievement scores.
They're failing because I'll be honest with you, they're engaging in very racist, very separatist policies that allows them to ignore the needs of the students at that very low performing school.
So, if this accountability recommendation is going to capture that very bad and very racist practice to make sure that that does not continue, I wholeheartedly support that.
That said,
Let's be very clear, while we have had the single objective of creating a coherent, integrated accountability system, because of the different timelines, this is not going to be a single system.
It is not going to create a great deal of coherence because if you're on one list because of the three-year identification and another list because of the year-to-year identification, that's not going to be very coherent.
And the only reason it will be integrated is because there will be common data elements that contributed to the identification of schools.
And I think, as Dr. Kearse has already pointed out,
Over time, with the arc of information that we will continue to receive about schools and as our accountability system matures, there will clearly be trends of performance that emerge.
And I actually believe over time that coherence is something that will happen more because of confluence.
Those two data elements and those two trend lines will somehow down the road coalesce
And we'll start seeing a subset of schools that appear regularly on both that three-year identification and the one-year identification.
But let's be clear, what we are recommending with what we're hearing for the accountability system is not going to create the coherent integration that we say is our goal today.
I think that that is something that will actually develop
fully as the system itself matures over time, but that is actually not what will be implemented and be felt in the field.
Yeah, Board Member Byrd.
So what's the solution?
Because if we want to maintain our principle, which I do desperately, I would ask for a waiver from this if I thought we could get away with it.
But I think, so there's a couple of ways we could go about it, right?
We could change state law.
We could say state law, we're going to do it every three years, then we can make it coherent.
We could ask for a waiver on the timeline if we thought it made more sense for us to go with our every year.
So it's not insoluble.
So I don't want, I think it'd be helpful not to, you know, perpetuate that we're going to have two systems just because we have separate timelines.
So I'd like to know what your solution is, Kerrick and or Dave.
While they're coming up and thinking about their solution, the point was made that for support, three years is a lot better than one year.
So the idea that this is a federal problem, they seem to have it, in my early judgment, more right than we do.
And so, you may want to propose a waiver, but I, you know.
Well, David Sapp, State Board Deputy Policy Director.
Again, I think, I would just caution, there's, we did get feedback actually from stakeholders in some of the letters that identifying only every three years, it's a point in time.
And so, if you have volatility, you know, if you have a movement from year to year in terms of, you know, you drop just a little bit and then, you know, just because
that year of identification influences who's identified for support within the cohort, and it might just be a function of which year the cycle is up and not necessarily where the support is most needed.
I think that that's a tension even within the three-year cycle that, you know, and I think that
We would have to talk about how one might propose or revise the plan to get at this proposal that Member Sun put forward about this is the basic approach.
We're going to get more data in three months, flesh it out, submit a supplement.
So the board would be able to consider the updated data in the January meeting.
basically.
And the policy decision isn't going to get any easier necessarily, but I do think it would provide more complete information.
What it would also potentially allow us to do is get a better sense of the year-to-year.
You know, what does it look like over time at the school level and to the point of is it, Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe, is it every three years?
That's sort of the current recommendation with the additional
more current data, multiple years of data, we may actually see that you could look every year at school sites and over a three-year window maybe get much closer to 5% just using the baseline methodology, for example.
So I do think that the additional time and more complete data would give staff time to really work through those options and come back to the board, I think, with a more
a more likely, accurate, and predictive picture of what is going to occur in fall of 18, it's still not going to look exactly like what will happen in fall of 18.
Well, let me say on that based on what you said, David, if you don't mind.
I think that the likelihood that there will be some common LEA names on both lists under the identification, under the state plan for ESSA and on the identification we will be doing this fall for the LCAP, it is very likely.
that there will be some names that are common to both lists.
And I think over time the differences between those two lists as the systems mature will probably create more likelihood that the two lists will look more similar.
But I also think that the annual identification will also create volatility in the list itself from year to year.
that there will be some districts that fall off the list just because I had a good year or some districts that will change.
Because remember, one of those times when we do have that annual identification, we are going to be moving the ends.
We are going to be making adjustments on the scale and on the cut points, particularly for the academic indicator.
So that's going to create some change in that annual indicator, in that annual identification.
Anyway, so I'm very comfortable with doing that, but I do think if we are going to try to create some coherence, particularly in the field, the identification timeline would go a long way to creating that coherence if they were closer together and how often or the period of identification.
So, Carrick Ashley, Deputy Superintendent.
So, thank you for those comments.
And those comments, as you were speaking, I had a woke moment.
That consistent with what President Kirst was saying at the very beginning of this item, in the state plan, I would suggest that we keep it with three years.
We can always decide internally we want to look at it every year and we look at it every year.
But if we put it in the state plan that it's every year, then that's what we're held accountable to.
Okay, then Board Member Ortiz-Lacon and then Board Member Sun.
Yeah, I also had, I don't know if I understood this correctly, I'm under the influence of Benadryl, but I understood that we are going to leave it to the LEAs to, because they have access to the 5x5 and they'll know what the long term, the timeline is, the state determined timeline and that goal that we determined, that they will set their own interim goals.
And my question would be, where is this documented?
How do stakeholders, educators, parents, students know what those goals are?
I think that I want to trust that everybody obviously wants to narrow achievement gaps.
I haven't seen evidence of that historically.
But I would like to know if this is going to be a transparent process of accountability.
If we're not setting those targets, then where are those targets?
Where do we go?
Where are those targets documented and those goals documented?
And who's monitoring that?
Right.
So, we would expect that to be documented in their local control accountability plan.
If we set a long-term goal, which is proposed today, and the timeline, local school districts can certainly do the math in terms of identifying what their goals is.
The downside of us, we could certainly
do that, math.
But I think it was member Holiday that mentioned the last time we had this discussion that these are kids and not machines.
They don't necessarily make the same progress every year, right?
So leaving that, what that annual progress is toward the eventual goal, we would leave that to school districts and we assume that that would be documented in their, either their local accountability plan at the district level, perhaps a school plan at the local level.
I don't have the templates in front of me to see exactly where and how that's also documented in the annual update.
I assume that within those three years, that three year cycle, if the county offices see that year one, no progress, year two, minimal progress.
Now we're halfway there.
I'm just trying to understand who raises that flag and says, hey, you're actually halfway there and not there at all.
Who does that?
That's an expectation that happens at the local level.
That's an expectation that happens at the school level.
It happens at the district level and it happens with their local governing board as they approve that plan.
And then in discussions, obviously, with the county office who eventually has to approve that plan.
I think maybe we could come back to this because I don't think this relates directly to the plan, does it?
I mean... It's the interim goals.
Okay, you're right.
The state could calculate it though, you say, and just distribute it to the local districts or not?
I'm, you know, is that an option?
I'm just trying to get the options down.
Right.
I think what we need to do is to provide some guidance to local school districts on how to do this, on how to put it in their plan, how to make the determination, how to measure it and respond to it.
Not necessarily calculate the math for them.
Yes.
Okay.
I was just trying to clarify.
I kind of want more than guidance.
I want an expectation because it's very clear that that's what it's intended under LCFF and under ESSA is to narrow achievement gaps.
So just putting guidance out there doesn't tell people this is an expectation and part of the accountability and what we're looking for is exactly this.
So I think that we need to strengthen the language around that.
Okay, Board Member Sun.
I just wanted to just add this in support of the timeline aspect of things too, is also the, for us not to make a hard decision yet on that additional step of identifying schools and getting more data is, we have the one year and we have the three year difference, but we also have small schools.
And so when you're identifying schools,
that is very, very volatile from year to year versus districts.
That's a very different dynamic that's happening there.
So we only have one year of data, some of which is very old.
So giving us at least an additional cycle gives us a little better picture of that dynamic and how that plays into things.
And then perhaps that would be a stronger recommendation from CDE at that point, once we know more.
And the CDE has said that they're going to look particularly at small, at small districts as well in the LCFF.
So, and how this bounces around and what that might mean for how we, you know, rethink at some point the color coding.
Okay, any more on this?
If not, we can go to the presentation by Tom Adams.
So, let's see.
I'm going to start here and go around that way.
Start with Ting.
Yeah, and then I'm,
So, I'll call on everybody.
Yeah, so consistent with that, LCFF should be the foundation of our approach to ESSA.
It makes sense to me that we build the element of LCFF priority one relevant to teachers for our definition of ineffective teachers.
I agree with the CE recommendation to look at additional information that it not be just one metric in that definition.
We clarified in November, at our November 2016 meeting, the local indicator LCFF priority one does not apply to charter schools because the Williams requirement included the LCFF priority do not apply to charter.
So what I would...
I think it's important to approach ESSA and it's invalidating the charter law at each state.
So I would like to include, in aligning with our state rules then, I would like to include those that apply to charter schools, including some of that credentialing flexibility.
So I would like to plan revision in this section to clarify the definition of
reporting approach that will account for statutory flexibility afforded charter schools under the state law.
Under existing state law.
Right.
To make sure it's aligned.
Board Member Williams, do you want to comment on this?
I'm counting on team to know exactly what needs to be done here and I support it.
Okay.
Board Member Sisson?
No comment?
Okay.
Board Member Sandoval, do you want to comment on this?
Board member holiday I would that's what I was Confused about before I was in the wrong section But that's exactly what I was going to talk about the issue with the charter school situation and providing that flexibility in here and the other thing is that
Down the road, I do think that we need to be able to define more effectively and identify more effectively teachers who are not serving students well.
And obviously, the word ineffective is meant to talk about teachers who are not serving students well.
It's not just about credentialing.
It's not just about teaching out of
out of subject area.
It's about not teaching well and identifying those teachers and providing them the support they need to be successful in the classroom.
And I would hope that eventually down the road we would be able to address that more directly.
Okay.
Board member Rucker.
Well, the assistant, the associate superintendent spoke a little bit about the transferability issue as he talked about Title IV.
But as it relates to the part that Tom talked about, in Title II Part A, funds can be transferred out of Title II Part A as well and go someplace else.
I'm not, and so even though it wasn't really addressed in the public comment, I wasn't clear what that decision or what is the recommendation about the use of those funds.
Is there going to be any flexibility for LEAs to be allowed to transfer those funds?
Is that some intent that's going to be looked at in there?
And you're talking about Title II transferring out of Title II.
Yes, transfer because the statute allows funds to be transferred out of Title II Part A and Title IV Part A. So I'm just talking about Title II right now.
And so I want to be clear because there is flexibility to transfer those funds into Title I that has an impact on how much money we're actually sending out to schools either from the state if the state decides to do that
or how much money LEAs then have to transfer around and move.
The reason I'm also asking about that is as it relates to this section and dealing with access to teachers and writing up this part of the plan, there are some elements in Title I Part A concerning the required and allowed reservations for services for students experiencing homelessness,
for children in local institutions, parent and family engagement, and equitable services for private schools that also has an impact on some of the doc statements that were made in the plan concerning access to teachers.
Because for particularly for where it relates to the contracting with private schools, private schools can participate in training opportunities provided under Title II that the LEA is looking at.
So I'm not clear
how the movement or transfer of those funds and how the contracting with the schools would be laid out.
Again, not something addressed in particular in the public comment, a highly technical element in our plan, but it has to be considered in order for me to understand whether or not the recommendations that were being made by staff are important and the right way to go.
those particular things for me are germane to that decision and would inform that decision.
The other piece that I wanted to talk about, again, not addressed in the public comment, but Title II Part B contains a lot of grants for a lot of different programs, and I'm not
clear if the state has laid out in particularly well what the state's role will be in either administering those grants or helping LEAs to compete successfully for those grants.
And so I think it's important for us to pay attention to that information as well.
Again, not addressing the public comment, but it is a part of the state plan
that I think does, I think that we should pay some attention to.
And then finally, in Title 2, Part C, it says any programs implemented under this title becomes a mandatory subject of bargaining in California.
So as it relates to Board Member Holliday's conversation about teacher effectiveness and teacher evaluation, that may be a conversation we want to have here,
But any conversation we want to have about teacher evaluation becomes a mandatory subject of bargaining based on the requirements in Title 2, Part C. So we, so I'm actually glad that the plan chose not to drop, to walk into that particular topic or conversation because that's a different can of beans for us to look at particular, given the timeline we have right now.
Board Member Martíza Khan.
This is only effective educator?
Yeah, this is Tom Adams' suggestion on... Sorry, Tom, you were like five hours ago.
Okay.
I'm like working in five minute increments.
So no, I'm actually very interested in hearing the conversation and public comment on this topic.
I don't have much to say now.
I just had one question.
We had some letters, Dr. Adams, on the issue of intern credentials and whether they should be
And there were some letters on public, in our public, not in our public comment, but in our letters about whether that should be considered ineffective.
Did you weigh any of that in the consideration when you developed this part?
Yeah, well, okay, let that be and then I'll make my comment and then I'll answer them all.
Okay?
Okay.
Yeah, so I hope you're cataloging these, right?
And so that you answer them all at once.
So we did get letters suggesting other criteria for ineffective teachers such as
teacher turnover, teacher absence.
And we really don't have any statewide data on those things.
And so we're facing a September deadline.
And even though those are interesting, there's no ability for us to propose those in the plan.
Moreover, some of them raised some questions about privacy issues.
We'd have to get into how many times you're absent and so on.
And it's a complex area.
It's interesting.
I think we would learn more from turnover and absence and so on.
But it's coming very late in the process.
So I don't see how we can do that in this plan.
But I just wanted to register that.
we're interested in.
And it seems to me that California Teacher Commission might also have a role in collecting this data, since they collect a lot of this other data.
So it might be more in their ballpark.
So that's my only comment.
on this particular, on the ineffective teacher issue, other than I'm not sure I want to turn over a robust definition of ineffective teacher into the federal government in a contract at this point.
Some states went down that road with waivers and some of them weren't happy with where they ended up at the end.
So, with the federal monitoring on that issue.
So, Tom, can you comment on that?
We raised several different questions here.
So, is this on?
So, Tom Adams, Deputy Superintendent and also Mr. Ineffective.
No, to get back to this question of the intern credential, the distinction between the intern credential and the emergency credential as we lay out there is that there is actually an intent and you're actually in a program.
And so it's usually district or university program that you're in.
That's why we pull that out.
And that was, you know, so there's, it's not just someone there, warm body who's taken the CBES and has an emergency permit.
So that's why we pull that out.
So, and we don't necessarily consider that ineffective just because there is a program in place and there is progress to be made, but we will still count it as a separate category.
So, and then
Patricia Rucker, board member Rucker, to all of your questions, yes.
No, I mean, you just raised... I can't follow your answer until you, you got to help me with part A, part B, part C. Yeah, so, I mean...
So first of all, thank you for pointing out the Title 2C in terms of other states.
And Part 2, Part C, go over A, B, C. What are those?
What are those three?
I don't, I can't remember.
And they're obviously, go ahead.
So Title 2 Part A is what we talked about today.
And that's really about getting into the system of support and what we want to do.
Remember, the ineffective teacher definition is actually under Title I. Okay, so then it's this issue about that came out about the charter schools.
What I'm hearing from you, and I just want to make sure this is clear, is that the federal law does not put any more requirements on charters than state law does.
Correct?
Okay.
And then on Title 2B, in terms of those various... What does that do?
Okay, so as board member Rucker pointed out, Title 2B does list a number of certain programs and what she wanted to know was what is going to be the state's role.
That is, to be honest, I don't have a ready answer today.
I mean, we will clarify that before the September meeting and we will talk with the board staff about this, but I don't have a ready answer today on that.
Well, and the main reason I'm asking that is because we're about to do an adoption on history, social science, and one of the grants that are available concerns civic education.
It's an opportunity to fund and support the rollout and implementation of this new adoption, possibly as this process goes forward.
And it's important to think that through and not ignore that opportunity or to make sure we facilitate that opportunity.
for our LEAs as well.
So that's the reason why I asked about it.
Because there are a lot of different grants that are, but they are competitive grants and our locals might need help to apply for some of those things if the state is not going to apply for them.
Right.
Okay.
I see your point there and definitely well taken.
Part C. Part C. Whether the issue of being subject, if we go further on it and the idea of it being subject to collective bargaining.
Part C. Title II Part C specifically says that any program implemented under this title, meaning under Title II, would be subject to the collective bargaining requirement in that state.
If the state has a collective bargaining law and in California we do.
Okay, that's in the federal law.
That's in the federal law.
So.
I'm not sure.
I mean, you're making a point.
That's what's there.
Well, the reason I was making the point is because before me, board member Holliday spoke to the fact that the definition of ineffective teaching is ultimately about teacher evaluation.
And at some point down the road, we, meaning this dais, should be walking into that conversation.
I'm glad, and I was saying that to make the point, I'm glad we chose not to do that in this plan because in our state, teacher evaluation is a mandatory subject of bargaining.
And given the timeline we have for submitting and approving the plan, that's not an opportunity that, that's not a conversation we can have in this forum with that requirement.
That was the point I was trying to make.
And my point earlier and pointing to greatness by design is we already have guidance for locals on that.
We've produced a very good document that's well supported both in terms of research and educators.
So why would we need to go further than that if we see it as primarily a local issue?
Okay, I guess that, okay, now we're on to
Title IV.
And let's have people raise their hands.
I'm not sure everybody wants to comment.
Glenn, could you come up?
Okay.
So Board Member Holiday first and Board Member Williams and then I want to speak.
Go ahead.
Board Member Burr.
I'm sorry.
Did you call on me, sir?
Yes, I did.
So the recommendation
Chief Deputy is to have a competitive process for the award of the funds.
Is that correct?
That's correct.
And so do you have an idea about what percentage of LEAs would receive funding and what percentage would not based upon a competitive bid process?
We haven't set the prioritization or the grant amount levels yet.
And we haven't even played out really any scenarios yet on what that might be.
So I couldn't answer that at this time.
I do understand how a competitive bid process would potentially be a very effective use of the money for those schools who win in this process.
no doubt had a bit more time or wherewithal to create a plan that would make the best use of those funds.
But I do feel sorry for the school that has a group of students that they really need to help and that they won't get anything and they won't be a part of this.
So I'm not really supporting the competitive process, but I'd be happy to hear more about it.
Well, just to comment, Board Member Holliday, and I totally hear that.
I think we probably all share that, those two different polls.
One thing to keep in mind and was persuasive for me in thinking about the option two is that
If we went with the formula allocation, the vast majority of LEAs in the state of California would receive a $10,000 formula allocation.
Because there has to be a minimum grant size of $10,000.
So, and not to sneeze at $10,000 at all.
A lot of great things can be accomplished with $10,000.
But some LEAs may consider it to be more hassle than it's worth.
And it wouldn't spread very far in a lot of those districts.
So that's, I think that's another factor to keep in mind as you're weighing that.
Okay, who is next then?
Board Member Williams.
Could you put up the slide, please, that shows what it might go toward?
Yeah, what it supports?
Well, the one behind.
No, you've already skipped over it.
Oh, they're well-rounded education, safe and healthy students, effective use of technology.
Right, and the further detail on that that I read was from the legislation under well-rounded educational opportunities.
And these are also, the legislation also indicates, including but not limited to these items.
guidance and counseling programs, music and arts program, STEM, including computer science subjects, accelerated learning programs, history, foreign language, environmental education, promoting volunteerism, and other activities that support a well-rounded education.
That's well-rounded education.
Safe and healthy students may include drug and violence prevention, school-based mental health services, supporting a healthy active lifestyle, preventing bullying and harassment, mentoring and school counseling, school dropout and reentry programs, and school-wide positive behavioral interventions and supports.
And just again, at either an LEA level, if we do the formula allocation or the state level, if we do the competitive grant, we have to do at least 20% of the funds in each of those categories.
And when you say LEA, does that include charters and districts?
Would, if it was, if it was a formula, they would get $10,000?
That's my understanding.
So, I'm going to differ on from Member Holliday on this in the sense that I hear what you're saying and I hear, you know, $10,000 to everybody is, you know, is, you know, feels fair.
On the other hand, it's especially for, in particular for a district, it could be, it could just be absorbed, you know, very quickly without it really having much of an impact.
And while every single focus for this I think is important, which includes civic engagement kind of things, but also given that, you know, that I have worked on NGSS,
now for a long time.
That's a discipline that is still struggling because it was so very complicated.
The conceptual shifts in NGSS were so very different and so very complicated that they're still, districts are still struggling to get all the professional development they need in that and to
you know, to build it up so that they're ready when the state summative assessment becomes operational, which is just two years from now.
And not to mention now we're going to start on computer science and so, you know, it would be terrific for any district that's interested in that.
I'm just speaking from, you know, from the areas that I've been working in.
Any district that would be interested in starting off on that, this could be very, or charter, this could be very helpful to them.
I like the idea of competitive,
competitive grants, this is such a small pot that there's something that when you have a chance to focus on something and get an application together and you say we've been wanting to do this for a long time, you know, now it's time for us to take care of this or this is an area we love and now we can spend this money on it.
It has a way of focusing the effort.
of an organization because they develop a plan, they go for it, they want it, they know what they're using it for, and it doesn't just sort of melt in with everything else.
So I would support the competitive approach to it.
There could be one option, and you tell me if this is an option, it could be that you could wait
potentially weight, add a weight to the competitiveness of like how would you evaluate grants if you have more grant applications and money?
One way would be to give extra weight to those serving the largest numbers of low-income kids or the three subgroups if that's a possible, a legal possibility to make sure that you're giving an extra boost for those districts or those charters.
That, in fact, is a requirement is that some prioritization occur for service to low-income students and also geographic diversity.
The State Education Agency and the board could also add another criteria that it would like to further.
And one additional point, Board Member Williams, to your point is that LEAs can also come together as consortia under the competitive grant.
If there were a number of LEAs that wanted to pursue a particular area of activity and support each other around that.
Okay, who's next?
Board... Oh, Patricia Rucker.
Okay, so I agree with Board Member Holliday about not having the competitive grant, even though the minimum grant, even though it would mean that a minimum grant to a small LEA is only about $10,000.
Competitive grants tend to favor urban districts and very large school districts and disproportionately cut out districts in geographically remote regions, even if you try
to do the geographical spread, urban districts are favored in a competitive grant.
But that's the first reason.
But the second reason that I would prefer to make sure all LEAs get a piece because Title IV Part A funds, districts have the flexibility to transfer those funds
into five other titles.
They can transfer into Title 1A, Improving Basic Programs, Title 1D, Prevention and Intervention Programs for Serving Students Who Are at Risk, Title 2A, Supporting Effective Instruction, Title 3A, English Language Acquisition, Title 4, if they want to for Student Support and Academic Enrichment, or Title 5B, the Rural Education Initiative.
So what it does in giving all of the districts a part of this money is it allows them to prioritize the use of those funds to any of the titles under ESSA and allows them to identify their local priorities.
If we truly are going to create coherence in what we're doing to implement a school intervention program,
then let's create and maximize the flexibility for the funding that passes through the state education agency and to the locals and allow them to use the funds to address their local priorities rather than have them chasing after money and creating a situation where truly most competitive grants will find us facing a situation where the money follows the student.
Those points are really well taken.
Just a quick comment to your first point on the urban districts being favored in a competitive grant situation.
The way that under a formula that the funds would be distributed would be based on Title I allocations.
So while the vast majority of districts would receive a $10,000 grant,
those districts with large numbers of low-income students would receive larger amounts.
So, the... Oh, I understand that.
But at least if you give some to all districts, all districts are participating instead of having some districts who don't stand a snowball's chance.
The, you know, I would, the snowballs transport, I think, could be mitigated by the SEA and the department by first adhering to the federal mandate that there be geographic diversity, but also building in requirements that certain amounts of the competitive grant be allocated to small and rural districts as a possibility.
Board Member Burr.
First, ditto to everything board member Rucker said.
I don't support a grant program because I think of the competitive disadvantage to the majority of districts that would be looking at the money.
And I just feel like this, it's a small amount of money overall.
It's for one year.
It's a lot of effort at the state level and at the local level to get a piddly amount of money.
And it perpetuates categorical mentality instead of reinforcing LEA's priorities.
So I don't support the competitive grant.
I'm a little conflicted because I do think that when you have a competitive process, it allows you to really be methodical and think about what you're pitching.
And it could serve as seed money since it's only one year to set something up and infrastructure for something.
for additional funding that you could go on your own as a consortium or a school district.
Maybe a hybrid, and I think you were alluding to that, where there is a set-aside that is guaranteed for smaller districts, where we know that there's going to be this amount given to small districts versus this amount that's given to larger districts.
My question would be, that wasn't even my point, but I think that a competitive could be good.
I think that we need to do some sort of a hybrid model where there is a set-aside for smaller districts or rural districts.
But in looking at your priority areas here, the well-rounded, safe and healthy students and effective use of technology, and then I was looking at the areas of priority for the department and for the State Board, and one of the student groups that we mentioned, or we talked about early education and it's
probably one of the first times that we've actually really given attention to early education.
And so it says that we would prioritize underrepresented student groups, English learners, homeless youth, and that transition from early to primary grades.
But I don't know exactly how that would fit under there because what you mentioned didn't seem to make a connection to this student population that we're hoping to engage.
And I do think that we need to be more intentional
about solidifying the pipeline because so much can be done if we just address the issue from the beginning.
And, you know, meeting the needs of students from the beginning.
And I want to make sure that I don't say issue because poverty is a challenge, but it's not a determining factor.
And earlier the conversation almost hinted at that, that if we have poor districts, then automatically they're going to be failing districts.
I think that if we have poor districts in terms of expectations, then we're going to, you know, have low performing districts, but
Poverty is a challenge, it's not a determining factor.
So I just want to point that out because that kind of came up in a previous conversation.
But yes, how are we going to prioritize early education under those three buckets when what you outlined didn't really hint to early education?
And those categories, if you will, or those priorities could be included as part of the RFA process.
We'd be mandated as part of the RFA process to ensure geographic diversity and prioritization for low-income populations.
That's a stipulation of the federal law.
But we could also add in other state priorities such as the ones you mentioned as part of the RFA.
OK, I guess I'm, pardon?
OK, well, I'm going to inject mine then, because we're coming around, so I got to turn.
Yeah, I really am not impressed by any of those.
What happened here is the federal government had 20 or 30 categories, and they decided to consolidate the categories.
And they chose these after some bargaining.
So I would throw in an option three, which if you go back a slide, I think we could do, which is transfer this money.
Well, yeah, no.
both LEAs and state may transfer these funds to other titles, that we transfer these funds to Title III for English learners and Title II for teachers.
And then you can do, and then we could discuss a grant.
I think both of those are higher priority than these three, which we're not going to make any inroads on anyway.
We don't really have any programs that we're reinforcing these with.
You know, we don't have a
well-rounded education, you know, thing that's in the general fund.
So, you know, let me throw that out that we don't, why, why do we just go with their list that we had of consolidated things?
And I think those, I don't know why they chose those at the federal level, but we don't have to choose them.
So why not option three?
Well, it's certainly an option to consider.
Just one wrinkle to think about as you consider that, that may impact your thinking, President Kurtz, is that what the state can transfer into the other titles are the state level.
Only the state level.
We can't transfer the grant funds.
No.
So the LEAs, as Board Member Rucker mentioned, can transfer their funds to the titles that she enumerated.
Well, we can only transfer the state level activities, the 1.8.
Which is the reason why I'm recommending give the money to all the LEAs and let them transfer the money to where they want and choose the programs they want.
That's the reason why I'm recommending give it to all the LEAs.
Can we do that?
Yes.
Yeah.
So the formula, if they transfer it to another title, let's say, for example, they transfer it to Title II, they'd have to use it in accordance with the Title II.
If they didn't have the competitive grant, then they could transfer the funds.
And if they choose to transfer their Title IV Part A funds into Title II and use it for professional development, they're allowed to do that.
That's their choice then.
So that's, in effect, an option three.
Well, that's option one, make it a local, give it to everybody and let them choose what to do with it.
Or option two, make the competitive grants.
Okay.
Now, Board Member Holland.
And I think an individual standalone charter school is certainly at a disadvantage in this competitive process compared to, you know, a large CMO that has a number of charter schools.
And that's a problem.
And besides, I think we should continue to
emphasize the importance of taking action against bullying and against these other and by sending money to each of the federal money to each of each school and saying here are the categories yes you may transfer into another title and that sort of thing but at the same time it does place emphasis on those key things and those are important and they may not be as important as
some of the other priorities and there may not be a statewide process and program associated with them.
But, you know, if I'm running a small school and I've got this funding and, you know, I've got some creative ideas about how to attack the bullying problem.
I think I want the money.
Board Member Sun.
I just want to do a quick weigh in as well.
I had struggled a little bit about these two different options, and I really lean towards giving it to the LEAs and to the schools.
I think it gives them flexibility.
It follows along the local control concept that we've been pushing and pushing, and it gives them more flexibility on how they want to utilize it.
And it is a disadvantage to small districts and small schools with these types of competitive grants.
Okay.
And while I like a good competition by nature, I'm fine with that approach.
Keeping in mind that they can keep it in Title IV.
Some may choose to transfer it to other titles for some reason.
But anyone that, any LEA that gets the funding can keep it in Title IV and choose to use it.
even though the titles that you showed up there, the three categories are very broad, the kinds of things that you described as more detail examples of what could be included in there are all worth LEAs choosing something that correlates with those and putting that funding toward that.
Board Member Sisson.
I just had a question about the two options for the grants.
So for option one, for example, it says that we can spend no more than 15% on technology infrastructure.
And I was just wondering, I think that the issue of technology infrastructure in different LEAs is such a crucial problem because there's just so many differences between certain schools and certain school districts.
And I think that 15% on option one and even the 25% on option two
I think that if LEA needs to spend that money to up that infrastructure, especially if they're at a deficit right now, I'm not sure why it's limited at that percentage.
Is there a reason why they can't spend more than that, especially if, I mean, with the $10,000 minimum grant money, that's not even
It's only $1,500 for technology infrastructure at that point.
So I don't know exactly how much you can even do with that.
So is there a reason why it's so low for that one?
It basically comes from, those percentages do not come from us, they come from the feds.
So, you know, I'm assuming that it's the intent that the funding be spent on services to students as opposed to hardware and infrastructure.
But we'd have to ask the Department of Education and Congress.
Okay, we need a break.
And what I want you to think out over the break, because we're going to take public comment, is if we go the route of sending the money down, what do we do with the state administrative money?
Because you don't need all that money to crank the numbers through your checking operation.
So let's talk about that when you come back.
We might transfer that somewhere and put it in, say, the Title II pot for leadership, or I don't know.
We will give you a chart that shows where that those funds can be transferred over the break.
Okay, thank you.
Now we're breaking and we will come back at 20 of three and take public comment.
Okay, the State Board will reconvene and we'll call the roll if you're... We're calling the roll for public comment.
Go ahead, call the roll immediately.
Would the following people please line up?
Fidelio Morales, Esther Corrubias, Semais Morales, Janice Ray, Anthony Caro, Ifeany Onobags, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz, Marsha Turner, Carling Aguilera-Fort, Lynn Ayohe, Vicky Ramos-Harris, Shelly Spiegel-Coleman,
Lane Olson and Judy O'Halloran, Martha Hernandez, Michelle Sotopena, Maria, Tony and Liz, Doug McRae and Roberto Baramontes.
And I'll call more in a moment.
Okay.
Come up, please.
First person.
Go ahead.
Microphone.
Does this one work?
OK, great.
Hi.
My name is Jafet Diego, and I'm here from Parent Revolution.
And I'm actually going to be translating for our parents today.
So I'm just here to translate.
Buenas tardes.
Mi nombre es Fidelia Moraes.
Vengo del subcentro de Los Angeles.
Good afternoon.
My name is Fidelia Moraes, and I'm coming from South Central LA.
Y estoy representando a los padres de la ley de empoderamiento de padres.
And I am here representing the families from the Parent Power Network.
Decidí venir hasta Sacramento por un motivo.
Me interesa el tema de la educación de los niños.
I decided to come to Sacramento for a reason.
That is because I believe that the education of our children is important.
Soy una de las madres que tiene una historia triste a la vez porque tengo dos hijos, los cuales... I am a mother that has a sad story.
I have two sons that... El más grande llegó hasta sexto grado sin reclasificar, pasó hasta el grado ocho sin reclasificar y como era mi primer hijo yo no sabía lo importante que era reclasificar.
The eldest one went to sixth grade and was not reclassified from being an English language learner.
And he continued as that until eighth grade.
And she didn't know what was going on.
When he was in ninth grade, that's when I made the decision to switch him to another school because they had told me that if he continued that way, he wasn't going to be able to go to college.
So instead, they taught him a craft as a gardener so that he would know how to defend himself.
After 23 years, I had my second child attending the same school, and this time I was more attentive.
She involved herself in the parent engagement at her school.
Yeah, parent engagement in the school.
Yeah, advisory council.
In the second grade, he reclassified from being an English language learner.
But then to her surprise, as he was in fifth grade, he had gotten an award in math.
And so she took him to get a pizza party.
And it was to her surprise that
And so he showed her what this test was, and it was multiplication, two times two, three times three.
And it was to her surprise that that was what the award had been, even though he was in fifth grade.
And so she felt disappointed.
Because those were skills that he learned in second grade, and so it was to his surprise that he was still getting that same test in fifth grade.
I went and talked to the principal, and I told him that it was a joke for my son.
He told me that he didn't know that the teachers had given him that exam.
So she went to go speak to the school principal and told her how disappointed she was.
And he said that he wasn't aware that the teacher had given that test to her son.
But for her, she felt just really disappointed.
So then she was advised to... So then he was changed to have another teacher, and so he started getting fours and threes.
But then when she changed him over to a charter school, she realized that he wasn't doing as well as she thought he was doing.
And so again, the disappointment of finding that out.
So they accepted him into the charter school because he had high grades.
Yo no quiero que siga pasando esto con los niños de mi comunidad.
Que haya una acción y una solución de que las escuelas van a estar bien.
So she doesn't want this to continue to happen to other kids in her community.
She wants to make sure that there is a plan where there is an improvement so that kids aren't, that more kids aren't going through this.
Que no solo se mire que la escuela está baja, sino que les den un procedimiento y que vean que si la escuela está avanzando.
So she wants to make sure that there is some sort of measurement so that we know which schools are low performing and that there is some sort of plan of action to see that they are actually improving.
She no longer has any of her children in district schools, but she is very concerned for the other kids in the community and that's why she's involved.
Time, thank you.
Good afternoon, board members.
My name is Esther Covarrubias and I have one son, Armani, who goes to a Head Start program in the area of Compton.
Today I am here representing the families of Compton and the Parent Power Network.
I decided to come to Sacramento because we need the state to design a strong ESSA plan that will improve the lowest 5% of schools in California.
These schools have been low performing under the old system and now under the new dashboard.
Yo emigré a este país a los 12 años y entré como estudiante de aprendiz de inglés a Washington Middle School y después a Long Beach Polytechnic High School.
I immigrated to this country when I was 12 years old and was classified as an ESL student at Washington Middle School and then at Polytechnic High School in Long Beach.
I graduated from Washington Middle School without being reclassified.
Neither my parents nor I were informed that I had not been reclassified.
Yo viví lo que es estar estudiando en una escuela de bajo rendimiento y donde los adultos tienen bajas expectativas para algunos estudiantes.
I experienced firsthand what it felt like to be a student in a low-performing school and to have adults that had low expectations of some students.
Year after year, I was passed from one grade to the next instead of receiving an intervention and being asked what kind of support I needed.
The expectations in school were low.
And even though I came from another country with the dream of being a criminologist, I never received the support I needed to be proficient in English.
Mi hermano pequeño fue a la misma escuela y tuvo la suerte de tener un maestro que le recomendó a mis padres que optaran por una mejor escuela aunque estuviera fuera del área.
My younger brother attended the same school but was lucky to have a teacher that recommended that my parents move him to a better school even if it was not in the area.
With the hope that my brother would have better opportunities outside of our area, my parents decided to send him on the bus to a public school in Palos Verdes, California.
It is because of my brother that I am here today to let you know that there are large differences in the quality of public education depending on the area that you live in.
Right now I live in Compton and there are a few high performing schools.
I want my son Armani to have better opportunities than what the public school system gave me when I was a student.
I ask myself, how is it possible that our state lets students graduate?
Thank you for your time.
Good afternoon board members of the board.
My name is Tamayez Moraes and I am a 6th grader at No Design Starter School in South Los Angeles.
I'm the youngest of four kids and we all attended 20th Street Elementary.
This is a local elementary school and it needs a lot of help because too many kids are behind in English and math.
I am here today to share with you my experience as a student attending a school that needs an emergency plan of action to improve.
I knew that something was wrong at 20th Street.
Some teachers went the extra mile to ensure that we had more activities like PE and library time.
Not all of my teachers were like that.
Some of my teachers didn't really believe in us.
But I knew that I could do the work if I got a chance.
I don't know why our principal changed so much.
I don't know why I was giving tests on things we had never learned.
I don't know why I kept getting the same math homework in fifth grade that I got in second grade.
I do know that I am lucky that my mom is stubborn and persistent and not afraid to speak for me.
But when my mom and other parents started to speak up I heard teachers say that I was placed in a different class because my mom will complain.
I always get my chin up.
I knew there was a finish line.
But my experience at 20th is not uncommon.
Today I wake up at 6 a.m.
take the city bus to go to a public charter middle school.
It's hard to realize that I was advanced at 20th and now I am not at grade level.
It isn't fair that students like me
need a lot of help because we're not taught the basics.
I know I have to work extra hard to learn the things I was supposed to learn at 20th.
My dream is to one day be governor of California and I will work hard to get to a university but it is frustrating and hard when you're missing the basics.
My mom makes a lot of sacrifices to make sure I get extra tutoring but I'm lucky many parents can't pay more money to do this.
I'm here today to ask you to put yourself in our shoes.
There needs to be a plan A plan B and a plan C to make sure schools get better.
Too many students like me are doing our part.
Now we need your help.
Thank you.
Hello my name is Janice Ray.
I was born and raised in Richmond California.
I am a student, a mother, a member of Students for Education Reform and here to support Parent Revolution.
I would like to urge the members of the board to provide a transparent and easy to understand structure on how we will proceed with change.
I am here not as a victim but a product of our school system failing our children.
I have a learning disability and I didn't learn how to read until I was in the sixth grade.
My teachers had failed me.
A woman by the name of Sue Luterman instructed me to play games on her personal laptop.
Unaware at the time I was learning intrinsically.
Growing up my maternal grandmother who had a second grade education I bared the responsibility of filling out applications and money orders to pay rent.
By age 13 I was misplaced.
Although I was homeless I still graduated.
I asked, if you could have met me at age 11 knowing that I couldn't read, would you have encouraged me to stay in school with the hopes that I would become something in life?
After all, how else can we break the cycle of poverty stricken children?
I currently volunteer for 10 Books a Home that helps kids learn through play.
These matters don't just affect my community.
They affect the many people who can personally relate to their education system failing them.
What part of my future is supposed to be determined by my family's income?
I am here to hold everyone accountable who has the power to implement change for their procrastination.
You are now forced to deal with your lack of action that intentionally tries to set our children up for failure.
What can you say to that little girl who was not able to read in the sixth grade because she was not made up but present today?
I ask for you all to have a clear menu of action for each district to be required to address low-performing schools that does not meet their improvement target within two to three years.
I look forward to meeting with you all again with the hopes that next time the children at Ravenswood School District will be set up for success and not failure.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, ladies and gentlemen of the board.
My name is Ifeanyi Onobogo.
I'm currently a student at San Jose State University, a representative of ESFER, Students for Educational Reform, and a supporter of Parent Revolution.
Standing here in front of you, I know from my life experiences and the fact that I'm here in front of you addressing this board, I know that a child does not choose where they're born, but has the opportunity to identify or plot their destiny.
And it's not fair that these children, that the educational system that's supposed to serve as a solid foundation for them, fails them.
So for the opportunity to create a perfect, or to give these children the opportunity to create, to have, I'm sorry.
But how could you choose your own destiny when the education that's meant to be their solid foundation fills them?
For the sake of the younger generation, we need you to present a solid plan for the ESSA that will directly address the shortfalls of the bottom 5% of our schools and a plan that will provide the children that we love with the support that they need.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, my name is Anthony Gatto.
I'm a member of the Richmond community and a student at UC Berkeley.
West Contra Costa Unified Students for Education Reform and I have been working really hard to provide a quality education for our students.
But we can't do it alone.
We need you, the State Board of Education.
We want to have high expectations and high supports for our students and teachers.
But how can we do that when our low income schools are not receiving the necessary resources?
We want to have excellent teachers, more excellent teachers, but how can we do that when we aren't giving them a living wage or the proper training?
We want to serve every child, but how can we do that when our undocumented, minority, low-income, at-risk youth are being left behind?
We want justice in our schools, but how can we do that when instead of hiring a guidance counselor, we're now hiring school police?
We want more quality choices for our parents, but we can't do that without your help on improving our schools.
So I ask, do not settle for a satisfactory but an exemplary plan on how to improve our schools.
Time.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
I'm standing in for Martha Zaragoza-Diaz, who had to be across the street at the Assembly Education Committee meeting.
My name is Xiloni Cruz-Gonzalez, and I'm representing CABE and Californians Together.
We would like to thank the board, CDE, and staff for agreeing to meet with us on the issue of the California Spanish assessment and its inclusion in the California accountability system.
The meetings that were held were productive and the pros and cons and practicalities regarding this issue were clearly defined.
Additionally, we were given an opportunity to provide a perspective and discuss how we can make this happen.
We appreciate the agreement to meet with CDE to continue talking about the design and components of the CSA necessary for its inclusion in the state's accountability system.
We support the proposed CSA language found on page 14 of attachment 1 memo and in its inclusion in the ESSA state plan and as well we respectfully request your support of this proposed revision to the ESSA state plan.
Thank you very much.
Hello, my name is Anya Hurwitz.
I'm with the Sobrato Early Academic Language Model.
I urge you to support the inclusion of the California Spanish assessment in the state accountability system.
This is an essential element to a system committed to biliteracy.
I would also like to underscore the comments of member Ortiz-Lacon.
In addition, as we define interim progress and growth goals for each student indicator, it is essential that there be a differentiated
growth target for subgroups historically underperforming.
So we focus on closing the achievement gap.
The language of ESSA plan should mirror and be comparable to the language related to closing gaps in the current LCAP directions.
Let's be sure this is a plan for equity.
And finally, this plan should focus on P-12 notions and systems of professional development that align and invest in early childhood education along with the K-12 system.
And given our demographics and our track record, we need a strong focus on dual language learners.
Thank you.
Lynn Aoki, representing Californians Together.
We argue that the progress of long-term English learners should be reported separately in the English Language Proficiency Test results.
LTELs are an important and distinct subgroup with 59% of all secondary California English learners so designated.
Currently, no LTEL subgroups are available, subgroup results are available, which both skews overall EL results and mutes LTEL needs.
For more than a decade, we've reviewed achievement data as a whole and by significant subgroups.
The reports help us to focus on and better meet the needs of specific subgroups that might require more assistance.
A similar outcome could be achieved for LTELs with the disaggregation of an LTEL subgroup in English language proficiency results.
With a state accountability system that provides specific reporting for LTELs, districts would find accessible focused data on that group that would encourage them to make informed instructional and programmatic improvements centered on the unique and specific needs of LTELs.
Thank you.
Hello, I'm Judy O'Loughlin from CATISO.
I'd like to encourage you to support the inclusion of language proposed in this item to continue working to consider the inclusion of the CSA in the state accountability system.
What I would like to address right now is Title II, supporting effective instruction.
Every teacher in our California public schools is more than a teacher of math, science, social studies, or special education.
Every teacher is a language teacher.
And to have all these teachers trained to teach not only their content, but also the language of their content, this doesn't simply mean teaching vocabulary.
That's almost really the easiest part of teaching language.
It means teaching the language of content in terms of speaking,
reading and writing about the content beyond just the vocabulary.
Specialized professional development through Title II funds can help all the teachers in a school learn how to help English language write about, speak about, and read about the content.
English language learners spend a lot of their time outside of bilingual or ESL classrooms.
The remainder of their school day is spent with content specialists.
Okay, thank you.
Hi, Marsha Turner, Assistant Superintendent, retired 12 days today.
And please support the including the language regarding the Spanish, California Spanish assessment in the accountability system.
And also regarding the state ESSA plan, it would be helpful for districts, for CDE to include in that plan a description of the process and tools districts should follow for monitoring interim language proficiency growth during the school year in addition to monitoring growth in the LPAC.
This will greatly enhance our ability to make sure English learners are making the desired growth throughout the year without waiting until the end of the year for the LPAC results.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
I'm Marta Hernandez, Assistant Superintendent for the Fillmore Unified School District in Ventura County.
I was also a member of the EL Progress Indicator Workgroup.
And again, I want to echo the words of appreciation regarding the new language regarding the California Spanish assessment.
But my remarks are focused on Title III support for English learner students regarding the English learner exit criteria.
I urge the state to continue its multiple measures approach.
An annual ELP, English Language Proficiency Assessment, which of course is the ELPAC, which is designed specifically to measure English learners' proficiency in the English language
and aligned to the ELD standards, as well as a reading language arts assessment that measures students' knowledge and skills in the specific academic content area of reading language arts, as well as teacher and parental input.
We know that this is an era of rigorous and challenging standards, curriculum, and instruction, and it is not a time to water down the EL exit criteria.
It is not yet certain that the LPAC can carry the heavy load of serving as both the language proficiency and academic assessment measures.
Time.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Michelle Soto-Pena, and I'm a fellow for the English Language Learner Leadership Initiative where I work alongside educational practitioners as an educational researcher in the field, and I'm also a graduate student at Claremont Graduate University.
I would also like to thank for the inclusion of language to consider for the California Spanish Assessment Language as a qualifier for statewide academic accountability.
And I would also like to add to my colleague, Martha, to please consider including into the ESSA state plan a validity and reliability study after two years of data to measure if there's a correlation between the LPAC and the SBAC.
This will provide enough data to measure any patterns to verify if the LPAC is sufficiently aligned as an academic measure for English language learners.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Honorable Superintendent Torlakson and members of the board.
My name is Maria Villa, Director of Family Engagement for CABE Project to Inspire Parent Leadership Development Program.
We know through our work in building leadership capacity with our families that the more informed our parents are on policies and understanding of the U.S.
system of education, they have a better role in taking, having a voice for their children.
which meant which for their children and English learners.
This then leads to helping close our current achievement gap as well as supporting their education in their schools.
Next, my colleagues Antoine Hernandez and Laura Diaz will share lived experiences shared by our parents going through our program.
And we ask you to please consider that the development of templates and tools are thought with parent voice and teacher input.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, members of the board and superintendent.
My name is Antoinette Hernandez.
I'm a parent program specialist throughout the state of California for CABE.
And as we know, there is a positive correlation between parent involvement and a child's success.
Parents want to be informed about how they can support their child's learning.
Providing access to more resources and providing more ways that parents can help to support their children at home will help us reach the heights that we seek.
As a parent program specialist, one of my many repeated experience throughout the state that I can share is when one of my participants was able to help her child reclassify from EL to FEP once she became more informed about the language reclassification requirements through attending the workshops.
As a result, she took it upon herself to make an appointment with her child's teacher and ask questions on how she could better support her child at home to obtain this reclassification.
The parent read with her child every night she was able to achieve this.
We urge the support to increase resources for ELs.
Good evening, board members.
My name is Laura Diaz, and as a current parent specialist for CABE, but more important, I am a parent who immigrated to this country, so I share the frustration that I encountered when I had no understanding about the system of education for the U.S.
But also, I didn't know the policies or even though more extreme, I didn't know the programs that I can get for my child to learn English so he can be doing better performance in school.
So I have to dive in the school system in order to know about programs that will support me.
It was until I was part of the DILAC as a president that I had the knowledge and requirements of the different programs for the reclassification process.
That allowed me, in collaboration with the Department of EL,
at my district that we empower the parents to, they will have a better understanding of these programs, their role, their responsibilities, so they can achieve diversification in the children.
So, just let me close with this.
On this, we include the voices of the families and decision-making in the process of providing necessary toolkits or resources to help them to have a clear understanding of their role
in supporting EL students, we will not be able to reach the high expectation that we have for reclassification.
Thank you so much.
With the following people, please join the line.
Mabel Dagbarti, Jordan Ward, Mahogany Allen, Keisha McGee, Edward Brantley, Brandon Watts, Aaron Walker, Patty Herrera,
Liz Guillen, Colleen Pachter, Mary Lee, Colin Miller, Marth Alvarez, Ralph Porras, Liza Malms, and Christy Sinclair.
Good afternoon, Shelley, Spiegel, Coleman, Californians Together.
We're encouraging you to adopt the language that the department has submitted in terms of the California Spanish assessment, but I'm here to talk to you about the identification of the 5% lowest schools.
This is one of the areas that we believe needs serious revisiting in the ESSA plan.
In a state with significant academic achievement gaps for many student subgroups and an LCFF law that calls for three subgroups as unduplicated students, it is very disconcerting that very few school districts are designated as the lowest performing inclusive of these subgroups.
We understand that students with disabilities are a diverse group, that they represent the whole spectrum of students.
But addressing students with disabilities who are African-Americans does not compute as addressing all the needs of a whole African-American subgroup.
And so for us, we believe that the proposal that board member Lincoln Ortiz presented about having an additional filter for the 206 additional schools really needs to be through the lens of these student subgroups to make sure that all of our subgroups are being addressed who have needs.
And I think what's really important is if you look at table five on page eight of your June agenda, you'll see that 139 schools are identified for solely one subgroup.
So it's not multiple identifications.
Thank you very much.
Hi, I'm Lori Olson.
I'm on the board of Californians Together.
And again, we strongly support the language on this item about including the California Spanish assessment in the state accountability system.
But I'm here to talk about the recommended revision to Title II in reference to the bilingual teacher shortage among other critical shortages.
We want to share with you this new report released just yesterday based on surveys we conducted with ACSA from 111 school districts in the state that together educate 39% of California's English learners.
And that data indicates that half of those districts currently are experiencing a shortage of bilingual teachers.
And with plans to expand and initiate new bilingual programs under Prop 58, it's expected to grow to 86% of those districts facing a real shortage of bilingual teachers.
We also did a survey, a teacher survey with CTA and CFT, where we identified as kind of the low-hanging fruit in response to this problem,
about 6,000 bilingual teachers who are teaching in English-only settings right now, but with support of professional development, would be willing to and able to fill our bilingual classrooms.
We have specific recommendations in this report we would like to see included in the ESSA plan.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
I'm Vicky Ramos-Harris with Advancement Project California, representing Early Childhood Voices, who signed on to this letter, as well as who informed this policy brief that you're getting handout right now.
We appreciate that the plan calls for integration of early learning into an articulated preschool through 12th grade system and support CDE's recommendation to change the language of the plan to a P-12 plan, as well as other recommendations CDE has for including early learning in the plan.
This will build on the child development principles to strengthen instructional practices for students beyond preschool.
We urge the board to include additional P-12 language including use of Title II funds and offering state guidance for including early childhood educators in professional development,
providing professional development on supporting dual language learners, offering state guidance for coordination and alignment between preschools, Head Start programs, and LEAs, and we request your support for the proposed language to include the California Spanish Assessment in the State Accountability Plan.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
I'm Carta Herrera, retired bilingual educator from preschool to IHE levels.
I'm here, I'm a former IQC member, thank you.
I'm here to request your support for item three, the ESSA state plan to include the California Spanish assessment in the state accountability system.
Additionally, please include the following language in the ESSA state plan regarding
school support and improvement.
Under targeted and comprehensive support include the offering of preschool for underserved underachieving subgroups at the identified schools and districts to prepare for and accelerate learning for our youngest dual language learners.
These early learning opportunities need to align the program services and professional development between preschool and TK3 and offer state guidance for coordination with state preschools and Head Start.
Further, I appreciate that the plan calls for the integration of early learning into an articulated P-12 system.
Thank you for this opportunity.
Good afternoon.
I'm Doug McRae, retired psychometrician from Monterey.
On the lowest 5% of schools topic, there's a one-page handout on green with five points on it that's come around.
Your discussion earlier indicated that parts 2, 3, 4, and 5 of my memo are no longer good for today, likely to be delayed until January.
But I would like to say a word or two on point number one on the quality of the different indicators.
Some of the indicators, the seven indicators on the table, are very robust.
Some are very shaky and untested as accountability indicators.
This begs for weights for the higher quality data.
For equal weights for all seven indicators, it risks havoc when untested indicators take over any kind of an identification process.
Finally, a different note, I recently learned in Arizona, ESSA permits a menu approach for high school state assessments.
Has California considered this at all?
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Roberto Vida-Montes with the Learning Policy Institute.
We'd like to thank CDE staff for engaging stakeholders on equitable access to excellent educators.
With reporting data on teacher credentialing, LPI supports the proposed direction laid out in item three on reporting data on teacher credentialing status.
Research shows that the share of teachers who have not met subject matter and teaching qualifications is strongly associated with teaching ineffectiveness as measured by student achievement gains.
In addition, research on the teacher performance assessment shows that teacher candidate scores on the assessments predict student gains on state standardized tests for this reason as well.
The percentage of fully credentialed teachers is an appropriate data point to help measure access to effective teaching.
Also, we also strongly support the plan laid out in item three to report these data at the school level as well as the district level.
And we think the best place to do this would be under priority one on the dashboard.
Lastly, on credentialing, we recommend that over time, California collect and report additional data, including teacher survey data, which can assess school leadership, teacher collaboration and professional learning, teacher turnover and teacher absences.
One last comment on early learning settings and teachers that work in those settings, because early learning educators often left out of PD opportunities.
We strongly encourage the state plan to include a vision for supporting the EC workforce by encouraging both specialized and joint professional development.
Thank you.
Hello, good afternoon.
My name is Jordan Ward.
I'm an academic advisor with the Blue Educational Foundation, and today I'm here with COPE advocating for redefining and articulating teacher effectiveness in the ESSA plan.
According to the ESSA, the state is to ensure that students will not be disproportionately served by ineffective teachers.
We're just wanting a methodology and a criteria in which to determine the effectiveness of teachers in this regard.
Thank you.
My name is Erin Walker, and I'm with Blue Educational Foundation and COPE.
For ESSA to work, for students to truly succeed on all accounts, A through G courses need to be a requirement for high school students to graduate.
High school is supposed to prepare you for college, yet the Public Policy Institute says that over 50% of students graduate without having A through G courses completed.
Now, this is a problem because A through G courses are the minimum requirement for Cal State and UCs.
So I ask you, what kind of education system do we have if our own students can't attend our universities?
Hello.
Hi, I'm Mahogany Allen.
I'm here with Blue Educational Foundation and COPE.
I currently attend Cal State University East Bay.
And ESSA states that we want to have effective teachers, as they had just said.
But it's really hard for me as a student.
This law is affecting me directly.
It's really hard for me as a student when you have teachers who
come in and they don't seem like they want to do their job or who aren't positive.
It's hard for me as a student to want to even learn.
So I know we all have things that we are going through, students and teachers, but I think in order to have effective teachers, we need to have teachers who want to be there and who are loving their job and who want to inspire students to do better.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Keisha McGee and I'm a parent and community member from Highland in the San Bernardino County.
I am here with COBE and Inland Valley Advocate Group.
We urge you to consider how the state plan should consult with a variety of stakeholders when developing the state plan.
We appreciate the additional stakeholder input session offered by the CDE, which allowed for more stakeholders to engage in the development of the state accountability plan.
While the dashboard is still in the pilot phase, we strongly urge the CDS to make additional enhancements to the dashboard so that it is more user friendly for parents and for the community.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board members.
My name is Brandon Watts.
I am a junior at Howard University in Washington, D.C., and I was born and raised in the city of San Bernardino, California in San Bernardino County.
Today, I'm here to talk to you about the purpose of an effective teacher.
I grew up in a single parent household and having a teacher who having teachers
that really cared about my education, having teachers who took that extra time to teach me problems after school when they didn't have to do that.
That's what an effective teacher is.
An ineffective teacher is a teacher who comes there, does their job, and if you have a problem, well, they pass you on to the next person in the next class.
So there's a big difference between an ineffective teacher and an effective teacher.
An effective teacher can save your life.
An effective teacher can send you to Howard University.
Thank you so much.
Hello board members.
My name is Mabel Morris-DiGuardi and I am a senior at Summit High School in the city of Fontana.
I'm here with the Blue Foundation and COPE.
I just wanted to say that I hope that ESSA could really build could help to build an effective teachers because with effective teachers could result in better better test scores and it could result in better learning.
I was a junior last year, and our AP scores just came out for our APUSH class.
Our teacher was not very effective.
Every day he would come in saying he wasn't really teaching.
All the students would feel the same way.
And the scores came out, and I'm telling you, they were not great at all.
I'm not proud at all, but with ESSA's help, hopefully we could build effective teachers that would improve these test scores.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, everybody.
It's a pleasure being here.
We've come a long way for one minute.
So, my name is Edward Brantley.
I'm with Youth Action Project as well as COPE.
I also serve as Juvenile Justice Commissioner for San Bernardino County.
Our organization, yeah, we provide direct support to the local school district there in San Bernardino.
We're in all the high schools.
We employ over 50 college students.
This talk about school climate and accountability plan is excellent.
There are some suggestions that we have.
Transparency, greater transparency.
in relation to where those funds are going, the LCAP funds.
Do more to address targeted underperforming subgroups, please, as well as restorative justice.
And please provide, you know, agency or capacity building funding for those agencies that are providing support for our local school.
Thank you.
I'd like to call the next group of speakers to please line up.
Jason Henderson, Giselle Viveros, Catherina Gregana, Richard Jaffe-Cohen, Julie White, Angela Deramos, Eric Premack, Allison Osono, Leila Fahimuddin, Carrie Hanel, Brian Rivas, Brian Lee, Jordan Thiry, Sarah Lillis, Samantha Tran,
Brian Gabrud, Rodney Van, Art Cruz, Mari Sol, Ray Rucha, and Leangela Reed.
Good afternoon, Mr. President, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board.
LeAngela Reed on behalf of the Small School Districts Association, SDA.
I just want to, one, thank you for how frequent I heard the recognition and acknowledgement of the situation relative to smalls mentioned in the conversation.
It's really important and I so appreciate that the board recognizes that.
And to that point,
I want to echo the comments relative to waiting for another year of data and also to looking at the volatility of information for the smalls.
One student can send a small into REDD.
And I think it's important to recognize that.
Also relative to the competitive grants, although I really appreciate the geographically diverse language that was offered in the recommendation by CDE,
It grants are notoriously very difficult for smalls.
We don't have grant writers because they're driving the bus and serving a superintendent.
And so it's important that to recognize that capacity issue.
And I think the recommendation by member Rucker is something that would be more effective for smalls.
Thank you.
Hi, Colleen Pachter on behalf of Los Angeles Unified School District.
In response to the proposed approaches for aligning the identification of the lowest performing schools with LCFF, LAUSD recommends identifying schools regardless of their LEA affiliation and ensuring that LEAs with a concentration of identified schools are eligible for state support in addition to those that currently qualify under the adopted LCFF criteria.
LASD believes that the state's lowest performing schools need supplemental supports and any approach whereby schools are not eligible for such support simply because of LEA affiliation would be inequitable.
LASD believes that it is more important for the appropriate schools to be identified first and then align the supports for those schools with LCFF and their related priorities.
In addition, the intern credential teacher pipeline encourages the hiring of highly capable and diverse teachers at a time when attracting and retaining new teachers into the profession is of
critical importance.
Because of this LAUSD asked that the reference to intern credential teachers be removed from the proposed definition of ineffective teachers.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Martha Albers on behalf of AXA, the Association of California School Administrators.
I'll just start off with the last comment by LAUSD.
We had expressed concerns in our letter regarding the ineffective teacher definition.
We would point you to those comments so you can have them in more detail.
But we have concerns about using the definition as any interim credential teacher because that does not mean that the quality of the instruction is there.
Regarding the 5% of schools that have to be identified for ESSA purposes,
We have a lot of questions about the data simulations.
Good questions, if anything.
It's triggering conversation within AXA.
We would like to encourage CDE for the August memo that will be coming out to provide greater clarity about where those 298 schools fall within the 181 LEAs.
We want to see that concentration or the distribution of those schools just because we want to ensure that it's aligned to the regional support structure that was discussed in item number two.
So we want to see this alignment of these conversations, not in isolation, because our concern would be that we're concentrating the support in only 20 LEAs or 181 LEAs when schools may be all over the state.
Thank you.
Hello, Liz Guillen with Public Advocates.
We also support the comments around delaying the identification of the methodology for identifying the second set of the lowest 5% of Title I schools.
In terms of the ineffective teacher definition, we support and recommend that you begin developing a plan so that we have additional data, additional measures like teacher turnover,
teacher attendance and teacher survey data that measures teachers opportunities to collaborate and engage in learning and also the level of support that principals provide.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Colin Miller with the California Charter Schools Association.
I do want to join a small minority, including Mr. McRae, on concerns about using the all-ethical indicators methodology.
We do think that academics need to have a higher weight.
Some of these other metrics, while they're very important, also are very troubling for small admission-driven schools because they're so volatile.
and could trip schools into intervention at the risk of over-identifying schools and not getting at the right schools that really truly need the intervention.
Overall, we are concerned about the ESSA plan and the lack of any real acknowledgement about the specific
the specific requirements of ESSA to include accountability for charter schools to be overseen in accordance with state charter school law.
That seems to be completely absent from the plan.
We've talked about the credentialing issue a little bit today and we have a letter that addresses some of that.
but also in terms of the selection of the 5% and how charter schools are included in that.
We think that's very important to address that.
We would encourage you to use your ACCS, your Charter School Advisory Commission, to vet some of these charter-specific issues.
In your attachment 3, there's no recognition of any charter school organizations that have participated specifically in that input, and your ACCS is at your disposal for that.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Julie White and I am here on behalf of the core districts.
The core districts are urging you to create an innovation zone as part of the ESSA state plan so that interested districts can work with the state to explore indicators that are helping improve student outcomes.
I brought language here today on the innovation zone so you can consider it as part of your discussion.
Several board members have raised concerns about lacking data and research to make informed decisions.
As you dive into the Innovation Zone language, you'll see that the Innovation Zone purposely creates space for innovative districts to share data and research with the state to improve the evolving accountability system.
The Innovation Zone should be part of the ESSA plan because it sends a clear signal to the feds that California, and to the state, and to local districts, that California prioritizes local control, innovation, and continuous improvement.
Hi, Angela de Ramos with CTA.
We recognize and appreciate that federal requirements may prove irreconcilable with the California way.
In this light, CTA wishes to express appreciation for the board and their adherence to guiding principles in creating a single coherent system.
In our last state council, nearly 800 CTA educators poured over the draft ESSA plan.
Our feedback and recommendations are detailed at length in our letter.
I know you're excited to read this letter, but I'll give you some highlights.
First of all, some kudos.
Specifically, we commend staff on progress towards defining ineffective teacher for the limited purposes under ESSA.
Furthermore, we appreciate new options for identifying the lowest 5% of Title I schools.
CTA is studying these options carefully and looks forward to engaging with staff on these options in the next few weeks.
In general, we support the direction of the board in adopting baseline methodologies, but do ask for clarification in what is being approved in Attachment 1.
The proposal revisions are vague and we want to avoid a blanket approval for yet to be defined times driven by federal peer review criteria.
In addition, we request further details on how staff will provide a transparent process in developing this plan from now until September.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Allison Osorio and I am here representing UnidosUS, formerly known as National Council of La Raza and CLR.
UnidosUS has been working to close opportunity and achievement gaps for Latino students and English learners.
We believe California, which is home to more than a quarter of the nation's Latino student population, can and must be a leader in this effort.
The plan must explicitly set goals and describe the state's long-term goals and measures of interim progress by considering the improvement necessary to make significant progress on closing achievement and graduation gaps.
The goals should be clear, achievable, and ambitious.
These goals should be clearly communicated to parents and the community.
California needs to be clearer about the outcomes for which all schools and districts should aim and how the goals will matter.
We truly believe that this is the next step.
This is the step that needs to be taken to close the achievement gap in California.
Thank you.
Hello, Leila Fahimuddin with the National Center for Youth Law's Foster Ed California Initiative.
As you work to finalize the ESSA state plan and ensure that it flows with our commitment to centering high-need student groups under LCFF, we urge the board and CDE to keep in mind the foster youth education stability provisions under ESSA.
ESSA requires the state to ensure that foster youth are able to remain in their school of origin when in their best interest.
And to make that a reality, LEAs receiving Title I funds together with county welfare agencies must establish how exactly they will get students transported to their school.
To date, many LEAs have not yet established these procedures despite a December 2016 deadline.
While we're in ongoing conversations with CDE staff, in keeping with the board and CDE's commitment to ensure that California implements ESSA with student equity front and center, we urge the board to support CDE in issuing state-level guidance in partnership with the state's Department of Social Services to LEAs in meeting these requirements under ESSA, including conducting
a transportation procedures checklist for use when conducting Title I Part A monitoring.
We have further recommendations in our letter to CDE and appreciate your attention to this matter.
Good afternoon, Monique Ramos standing in for Katharina Gargana, representing First 5 LA, First 5 California, and the First 5 Association.
First off, we'd like to appreciate the changes to the current version of the state plan with the integration of early learning into the plan.
We request that you adopt the recommendations in the addendum to further integrate early learning and the P-12 concept throughout the plan.
In addition, we request that you add early learning and a dual language learner representative on the California Practitioners Group.
And finally, encourage that you encourage school districts to use Title II funds for professional development for elementary principals and preschool administrators so that they can have training on the effectiveness of teachers teaching our earliest learners.
Thank you.
Afternoon.
Jordan Theory on behalf of the Alliance for Boys and Men of Color.
We think that the draft ESSA state plan should include steps that the department will take to consider and include new data and indicators to look at school climate
including teachers and staff that are trained on restorative and positive discipline practices, the percentage of those teachers that are, teacher and staff attendance, teacher and staff retention rates, as well as pupil arrests and referrals on school sites.
Additionally, related to the assessment section, we recommend that to better support English language learners for the statewide exam, there are only 10 languages translated in the glossaries, while for the instructions on the exam, it's translated into 17 different languages.
We recommend expanding the glossary translations to all 17 of those same languages.
For accountability, we think the ESSA plan should be more clear in strengthening the reporting requirements on school site expenditures for each school in the state and have those expenditures disaggregated by funding source.
Thank you.
Hello, Brian Glossary with the Juvenile Court and Community Schools.
To open, it is recommended that much of the language contained in Title I, Part A be considered for Title I, Part D. Additionally, Title I, Part A does not acknowledge the delicate topic of students transitioning from confinement to community, which includes the transition from alternative-based education and justice facilities to potentially the student's home districts.
Assessments identifying familial needs for the students are necessary to address factors that typically lead to further delinquency, truancy, or re-engagement in the justice system.
Current assessments tied to education-related needs and obstacles are inadequate as many familial-related issues can be overlooked.
Proposition 47 was a strong step forward in mitigating the consequences stemming from the trauma experienced by formerly incarcerated youth.
However,
The necessary funds to both effectively assess youth exiting confinement and to provide them with opportunities to transition into circumstances that encourage self-sufficiency are severely lacking.
In closing, the alternative accountability tool associated with Title I, Part D needs to acknowledge the unique variables experienced by families of at-risk youth transitioning from confinement to community schools.
Thank you.
Greetings, Superintendent Torlakson and board members.
My name is Rodney Vann, former at-risk student, retired probation officer, and currently with the San Diego County Office of Education within the juvenile court and community schools.
I'm also the parent of three children, two of which are graduates of UCLA.
With respect to Title 1A within the ESSA state plan school support and improvements, I found that all students have gifts and a desire to learn.
The key is assuring we present them with effective educators and leadership to bring them to their full potential.
Additional funding should be allocated to teacher training and or retraining within the guidelines of Title II.
We must have districts that are willing to be progressive in regards to culturally responsive curriculum.
academic credential, excuse me, academic credit for all students for career technical education classes, as well as more opportunities for parental engagement.
Let's meet the students where they are, not where we are.
Thank you.
Art Cruz with the Juvenile Court and Community Schools in San Diego.
The continued recruitment and retention of teachers of color and professional development in the areas of socioeconomic differences for all teachers is of utmost importance.
Our students are challenged to see their faces and hear their voices in the teachers and staffs around them.
Many if not most of our students live in a very different economic and social situation from the staff they encounter in school, whether it's gang involvement, lack of housing, economic challenges, or simply not knowing where their next meal is coming from.
The disconnect between socioeconomic pressures on our students and their families and the academic expectations, excuse me, is vast.
Continued and consistent access to professional development, addressing cultural diversity and socioeconomic differences for teachers and administration would help to bridge the divide and help students feel safe to be heard and understood.
Thank you.
Superintendent Herlixson, hello, and board.
I am Marisol Quevedo-Ruche, Parent Educator Advocate.
I represent practitioners through the lens of teacher, traditional, charter, and now county office of education administrators.
My passion is ensuring the best education for at-risk youth in our international border region of San Diego, and that includes those in the juvenile community school.
It is time that we value the voice and language of our youth.
We must have CSA included as a required option to SBAC in Title 1 Part A accountability.
We must use the ESSA State Plan to provide truly comprehensive supports in the mainstream system to truly prevent our precious youth from entering this alternative at-risk status.
You need to include common definitions and expectations of cultural responsiveness, trauma-informed care, and equity and diversity training.
in all of the plans for school support and improvement, access to educators, school conditions, prevention and intervention for at-risk youth, and supporting effective instruction.
It is time for us to save our youth.
If you want to save lives and keep our kids out of prison, then we also need to start addressing the needs of their families.
So when you're talking about mental health supports and training, you need to include families in that.
Thank you very much.
President Kirst, Brian Revis speaking on behalf of the Education Trust West.
Two issues I want to share with or comment on.
One regarding school identification and differentiation of schools.
We would urge the board to avoid a methodology that does not identify schools as low performing if they're outside of a district that's identified as in need of assistance under the LCFF rules.
We think that's very problematic.
We need you to be honest with the community and parents when there's a low level of performance in a school.
We would run the risk of treating students similarly situated differently if we did that.
With regard to educator effectiveness, we agree with some of the sentiments expressed by member Holiday.
Ultimately, we would like to see the plan address which teachers are likely to help students and who has access.
But at this stage, we would like you to consider a multiple measures approach that is sort of like a dashboard showing the teacher workforce by school site.
Good afternoon, Sarah Lillis with EdVoice.
We just wanted to make sure first that you'd seen the letter from Senator Ben Hueso and Dr. Shirley Weber and several other legislators expressing their concern that the intent of LCFF was still not totally reflected in the SSA plan and the accountability system.
And just returning back to what the legislators expressed and what we heard from Governor Brown when he talked about his
Aristotelian justice is not just about getting resources to low-income school students, English learners, and foster youth, but actually increase and improve services to change the outcomes because we have a history, a shameful history, of achievement gaps that need to be addressed that we can't deny when we look at assessment data.
And when we looked at the LCFF methodology for identifying LEAs, we were surprised not that students with disabilities were at districts serving students with disabilities were identified, but apparently we don't really have a problem with low-income students, English learners, and students of color and their subgroups.
And that reflects either we misunderstood the assessment data or there's something with our LCFF methodology.
And we would encourage you to look at that and we would find more coherence with the ESSA plan of identifying schools if we were to review that methodology in LCFF.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Samantha Tran with Children Now.
We submitted some background materials with the board item and analysis of the identification of the lowest performing schools and just wanted to raise that we have a concern as we're looking at the data that we're losing a lot of information when we move to the color coding system and in fact it's creating some
outcomes that when you look at the data, you're like, how can this be?
It's very counterintuitive and could lead to a dynamic where when the public starts looking at the identification of schools, that it could feel arbitrary.
And so wanting to be very careful about how we determine this methodology.
In our materials, we actually included a strategy that could bring back a lot of the data that's underneath the color coding system while still trying to stay within the framework.
that the board has adopted.
And we know that the time is short and that we're all trying to figure this out and want to be a resource as that happens.
In addition, as you've heard from many of the testimony and our letter on this front, there's still a number of issues within the plan around teacher equity, transparency, interim goals and the like that we are hoping will be addressed in the near term.
Thank you.
Eric Premack, Charter School Center.
Still have a number of questions or concerns with the ESSA plan.
Conflicts with charter law in two areas.
First, with respect to teacher credentialing.
We need it to explicitly reflect both subject assignment flexibility and credentialing flexibility for non-core, non-college prep courses.
That's not reflected in the current draft.
It also doesn't reflect any of the flexibility accorded to charters under the eight state priorities and the selection criteria.
Third point, we support the use of formula-driven distribution of all of the federal funds, not just the Title IV, but even getting down to the homeless money, you name it.
We really find the nickel and diming of the way the federal funds are distributed to be problematic.
And my last point is, and I may be crazy, but I still think we should just tell the feds we want the mother of all waivers and we want to use the dashboard to drive this process.
believe me, this is not a unified system.
I'm going to have a hell of a time explaining even what you think is a unified system to my members because it's still very different.
It's just like the old system where we had A1P and API, really.
So let's just give it a whirl, see what DeVos will give us.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Superintendent Torlakson and board.
I'm Richard Cohen.
I'm one of the board of directors of Restore the Schools Vision Project.
And also we are members as a group of the Fixed School Discipline Coalition.
And you have letters from us.
You have submissions that we made, which outline in great detail our concerns about how we're going to implement ESSA and on a state level.
I take
President Kirste comments from the very beginning at 8.30 this morning when he said that we didn't want to really get into the details here dealing with the federal government.
We thought we'd just stay more general and not talk about programs or specifics.
We have some trouble with that.
And the reason we have trouble with it is to do with the students who came in here today and made wonderful performances.
They were performances, but presentations and performances.
One in particular, the group that came in from, I think, San Bernardino.
Oh, already, huh?
Well, we'll just say this.
There is an urgency here, and I do not believe that we can afford to let this opportunity slip.
We don't have the time.
Now is the time.
So I'd urge you to be more specific.
It's laid out in our submissions.
Thank you.
Hi, Brian Lee on behalf of Fight Crime Invest in Kids, Mission Readiness and Ready Nation.
As to the 5% of lowest performing schools, I'm really excited that you guys are going to wait and take a look at the data because I think you really need to and I think that you can move better than the recommendation that was before you.
I just recommend that to pick the lowest 5% of performing schools, pick the lowest 5% of performing schools, not the lowest 6.5% and then take 5% of those.
The department gave three arguments why not to do the option three, which just looked at all schools.
They said it wasn't aligned very well.
But as my remarks earlier in the day suggested, we have some gaps from the LCFF accountability system.
We're missing a lot of subgroup problems.
And I think that this may sound crazy, but maybe ESSA compliments LCFF because it allows us occasionally to look at schools where there might be concentrated subgroups and say, hey, those people need assistance.
Because if we aggregate things at the district level, you sometimes miss that.
Also, they said, oh, it's going to triple the number of districts.
It's going to go 49 more districts, 80 more schools, on top of hundreds of districts and hundreds of schools.
It's really not that much more.
Thank you.
Martha Zaragoza-Diaz representing California Association for Bilingual Education and Californians Together.
The proposed revision regarding the definition of an ineffective teacher is tied to California's ongoing efforts to implement LCFF priority one, which recognizes that LEAs should be accountable for having teachers who are fully credentialed.
In light of the passage of Proposition 58, it is recommended that this should also include teachers who are not only fully credentialed, but teachers who also hold a bilingual authorization.
In addition to the data identified on page 7 of Attachment 1, it is recommended to include data on the percent of teachers with bilingual authorizations.
Thank you.
Terry Burns, California School Boards Association.
We appreciate the dialogue about moving to a richer and more timely data set.
We think that's really very important, particularly for the small school districts, those schools who will have a red indicator only on suspension that is tied to one event that happened after one crazy football game.
I just don't think that it builds great credibility if that's otherwise a great school and their scores are strong and if you're going to put them on a list of the worst schools in the state.
So to build, we think it'll be more helpful to have the richer data set as you build credibility for the system.
Thank you.
Okay.
Well, I think the board needs another break.
So we'll reconvene at 4.05.
Okay, the State Board will reconvene.
Thank you.
So I'm going to turn to Board Member Sun to begin our discussion by framing, by presenting a motion.
And her motion would include all of the
elements of the presentations that we heard today, including the presentations by the Department of Ed, all three on, all three parts of the presentation made by three members of the CDE.
Board Member Sun.
Okay, great.
So we're going to try to move through this as logically and clearly as we can, because we've been presented with a lot of information and there's so much in each of these sections that have been discussed.
So I'm going to bring forward two separate motions.
The first that addresses all proposed revisions except for the Title I, Part A accountability.
We're going to put that aside.
The second is going to be related to Title I, Part A accountability section, which was addressed separately in Attachment 2.
So the first part, the first motion is related to the access to educators.
So I, when I made my comments earlier, I felt like it didn't give enough of a little bit lead.
So I,
Just to go on record, the whole ineffective teacher definition gives me heartburn, and I've expressed that several, several times.
And we certainly know that there is much more to that definition than simply by a credential.
Nevertheless,
We need to move forward and we're not going to be able to come to some consensus around what effective teacher is at this point in time and we need to move forward.
with that and I do want to also say that as it is aligned to while my recommendation is that we align it to LCFF definition under priority one, I do feel that California, we need to do some work around this area and flesh out and some of the CDE PowerPoint
did indicate about looking at additional information.
So with that, I'm going to move the staff recommendation to approve the revisions to the State Plan proposed in Attachment 1 and Attachment 4 with the exception of the proposed changes to Title 1 Part A Accountability Section with the following two changes.
One, for Title I, Part A, access to educators.
Approve the proposed revision, but include clarification that the definition and approach to reporting data will account for statutory flexibility afforded to charter schools under state law.
The second part of that first motion is then include option one for the title for part A in the revised plan instead of option two.
Option one is the flexibility is to entitle.
Yeah, title four.
Sorry.
Yeah.
OK, so those two pieces, any.
Yes.
Okay.
Question.
Yeah.
Do we have a second for the motion?
I'll second.
Okay.
We have a second.
Question.
Ortiz-Lacombe.
I have a question about the motion.
And I know that we took Title 1A, Part A. But this attachment here, the only thing that I found that had concrete language that we would be adopting is Part 3 around the Spanish assessment, which I obviously agree.
And I do agree that we need to incorporate feedback from the CPAC and stakeholders.
But when you look at some of the comments and align it to the peer review criteria, but as I was looking through some of these comments, some of these comments contradict each other.
And I have no idea what actually will go into that plan that will come back in August as a memo.
So when something comes back as a memo, it's not a public comment period.
It's a memo.
It's a FYI.
This is what we're proposing.
So I still don't know what would actually be included in that plan because what I have is a list of
raw comments that have been synthesized as best as possible, but that still don't tell me which one you're going to incorporate.
Is it going to be the person that wants to recolor the grid?
Is it going to be the person that wants to make it a five, a three year versus a seven year?
So that level of detail, I don't know what I, it's like signing a blank check.
I don't know what I'm actually approving.
And it comes back to us as a memo.
Again, it doesn't go out for public comment.
It comes back as a memo where people could try to find an avenue to provide feedback, but it's not clear to me how somebody could give feedback on that memo.
So can you please clarify that?
Sure.
Thank you.
Thank you for that question.
So our intent is to make the plan available, the revised plan reflecting your direction today, as an information memo early in August so we have plenty of time for everyone.
As I mentioned, we've had a lot of stakeholders walking alongside us for the last 18 months as we've developed this plan, and we want to make sure that folks have enough chance to review.
We do not intend to go out and do ESSA stakeholder engagement phase five.
I don't think we have the time to really do that properly.
But what we will do and include in as part of the memorandum is encourage folks to share their feedback on this draft with us at ssa.cde.ca.gov.
And we will take letters and emails and any comments and synthesize those and present them, take them into account when we bring you the final plan in September.
Is that, do you want to follow?
I mean, I'm... Well, I followed up with the patient section.
I know, I saw a lot of... Yeah, well, there's nothing in the plan now.
I'm sort of lost.
I mean, it sounds like there's no language.
There's a whole, there's a whole plan.
Yeah, well, that's what I mean.
There's a whole bunch of quotes.
No, so, yeah, there's no specific language.
We haven't written specific language yet.
But what we do have for each section is additional proposed revisions.
So we're not planning to integrate all of the public comment, which, as you said, is often competing.
We're planning to move forward as proposed in the section underneath the summary of feedback that goes to additional proposed revision.
So if there are specific sections you wanted to look at, I'd be happy to look at what those specifically are.
Well, that's exactly what I went to.
I went to the recommendation.
And again, the only language that I thought was concise and I had an understanding of what was actually being proposed was the Spanish assessment.
Everything else, alignment to the peer criteria or the peer reviewer criteria.
I've read it.
I know what they're asking for.
But, you know, I'm not sure we're going to align it.
I don't know what parts we're going to align.
So there's still that absence of language, concrete language.
we do not have a whole new draft for you today.
Our intent is to go create that whole new draft so everyone can see the new language and make that available as an information memorandum.
That's the best we can do at this point.
It is the motion because the motion is to accept the edits that will come back to us in May for all the parts except.
No.
to get input.
But what's what's coming back to us is a memo in August.
And then that will essentially will get some feedback if people submit.
And that essentially becomes the plan that we will be approving in September.
So, yes, we're going to go out and align it.
So the motion is to go out and align it with some of the comments, some of the recommendations which don't are not specific there.
Okay, well then can you please repeat the motion because, you know, when I first said, is this what we're voting on?
I got a yes.
So the motions are on some of the more substantive changes from what the draft is.
There's a several parts of the draft that need additional language and CD staff because they haven't had the time.
They just got all of the input to to actually draft specific language in some of those sections.
So what but there are decision points that we are making under this motion.
so that they can then fill out and fulfill the rest of the draft.
So, I guess part of what I think member Laconis, Ortiz-Laconis is asking for is how will this be presented so that stakeholders have an opportunity to be able to provide more input.
Is that what you're asking?
That's part of it, but you said it yourself.
They're going to go back and add detailed language.
So there is no detailed language other than the sentence around the Spanish assessment.
And the other thing that we are adopting is we're option one of title four.
So you're right, we don't have a full plan that we're looking at.
It might be helpful to really look at attachment one for a minute because I think there's actually more there than you are seeing right now.
So I'm just looking and clearly for the assessment place there's very clear language that's been worked out in the collaborative process.
We're going to talk a little bit more about accountability in a minute because that one was much more broad where, you know, we say we'll take into account the conversations you all had today around accountability and we'll talk about that a little bit more in a minute to get more clarity on specifically what we will include in the accountability section.
For school improvement and support, we're looking on page 5 of 19.
It says that it'll be updated based on board discussion regarding the emerging statewide system of support.
So some of the things that you discussed earlier, like maybe beefing that up around root cause analyses and the other things that you recommended be included in the state system of support.
And then to align it to those peer review criteria where again, staff will go through the peer review criteria and try
to the greatest extent possible to meet but not exceed those criteria.
For access to educators, there's actually a relatively long section.
It starts on page 6 of 19 and goes through page 7.
where that's actually some of the language and then we added a little bit more there that said we're going to get more specific in that table that's right in the plan so it's more clear what each of those terms encompass for school conditions starting on page 8 and going on to page 9.
That's the language.
that we want to include to augment that school conditions section to make it more clear about specific things that the state will do.
And in addition, we'll go in and look at the peer review criteria and beef it up.
So I could keep going through, but I think if you look at those proposed revision sections, wherever possible, we've tried to be
as explicit as we can, because we are not starting from scratch.
We have the plan.
Our intent is to augment it, refine it, streamline it however appropriate to get closer to finished.
We're not starting from scratch.
We're building upon the draft we currently have.
Is that helpful at all?
I understand what you're saying.
I also understand what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is that I would, at this point, there's still a lot of questions that I would have.
And so I personally do not feel comfortable voting on something that will come back to us in August where I don't know exactly how this will shape up.
Right.
So you're not, we're not asking you to approve a final plan today.
Okay, I just want to be clear, you will see this plan again in September.
You'll see it in August, but you'll have another chance to approve it before we submit it five days later.
But as I said at the beginning of my remarks, just a few minutes ago, it serves us all well to get as close to final as we can around some of these big decisions today because
If it's feeling like a lot of pressure now, I can't imagine what it's going to feel like on September 13th or 14th when we need to submit on the 18th.
Yeah, just we're on a motion that concerns Title I, Part A, access to educators.
It's the beginning part of the motion.
Okay.
All right.
It's the beginning part of the motion.
Okay.
Thank you.
I think board member Rucker was, I saw her first.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I want to, first of all, thank you for all of the work that was done to get us to this point to be able to look at a draft and to have a long conversation about what our intentions are on doing the draft.
I appreciate Board Member Ortiz-Lycone's concerns.
She's, even though she's under the influence of mind-altering substances today, she definitely did make the, she is making the effort to stay woke on this conversation.
So I appreciate that.
I think that I want to clarify what we what the motion is saying.
We have a draft plan and what the staff did today was an excellent job of looking at and articulating where there were some gaps not only between your understanding of what the peer review process has surfaced so far and what you've learned so you already know based on the feedback you've heard from other places in the peer review process
There are some sections of the plan as drafted that needs to be punched up.
So part of the motion is saying, based on what we're learning out of the peer review process, there will be some explicit revisions made to the plan draft.
to align to that criteria.
The second piece in what's in here is, as you went through each of the sections, and that was the attachment we got in attachment four, there were some specific recommendations for revisions that were enumerated
in this blue memo.
Some sections said no additional revisions are recommended and some sections said these are some of the changes we're going to make.
So as it relates to attachment four, those are the revisions we will also see added to the memo.
Now, in approving this, there were two additional changes made.
For Title I, Part A, making sure that there's a clear, explicit recommendation concerning flexibility under the state law for teacher certification for charter schools.
That was added.
It was not something in the draft and it was not something enumerated in Attachment 4.
And then for option, I mean, in Attachment 1.
and four.
And then for considering Title IV Part A, the recommendation for the staff that's in writing in our attachment recommended a competitive grant.
The motion that is printed here is recommending the formula grant instead.
So, if we vote on this motion and approve that, we are approving direction to the staff to revise the draft that we saw today so that the draft can be sent back out to the public
as a memo.
Now, and so this is the part that I think is not clear because it's actually not contemplated in the motion.
Two things that you just said are going, well, you said one thing, but there's actually two things that are going to happen.
Part of the reason why the memo in August is important is because that memo, which could be the draft that is submitted to the board for approval in September, still has to be reviewed and vetted by the governor's office.
and there's a requirement for the governor's office to have 30 days.
So it is important that the memo is prepared so that the board can send a draft for vetting for the governor's office.
That additional vetting time for that memo
gives the opportunity for stakeholders who have been monitoring this process to also give some feedback to the department through their submission window.
Now, it does not mean that everything is going to be thrown out with the bathwater.
It means it's another bite at the apple for one more opportunity to give some feedback.
That feedback also includes the people on this dais as well when you receive the memo.
Seeing the information memo in August does not mean the plan or draft itself is a done deal.
Because the one real reality we need to remember, when we come back in September, the governor's office will also have given his input.
And I'll just make the motion now, I accept any input the governor wants to give.
Like you're really going to tell him no.
So.
So that's the other thing we have to recognize in this process.
He will all his staff in his office will also be vetting the draft and also be giving their input and it will inform some changes that we will likely see in September.
So that additional feedback loop is not contemplated in this motion, but it is still a step in the process.
And I would suggest we actually don't need to enumerate that.
in the motion, but I just want to make sure people understood that that's the next step in the process.
Okay, thank you for that clarification.
Board Member Holliday.
Because this is not a new document that has gone through many iterations that we've worked on it forever and ever, I doubt that in September we will see something dramatically different than what we've seen today.
However, in September,
correct me if I'm wrong, we will have the option, even though there are only five days after the board meeting before we have to submit it, to say this particular line does not work for us.
This phrase doesn't work for us or this piece doesn't work for us and be able to change it up at the last minute.
So there still is a catch opportunity for us if there is something that steps out of line with what we've been talking about.
But I certainly doubt that that's going to be the case.
OK.
Any further discussion?
We're going to do everything.
Yeah.
So in the motion, it is just, it's nudging us along.
So while you may not be completely satisfied with everything that is currently in here, the first part of that motion was, OK, this is enough to keep moving forward.
So that is what the first part of the motion.
And then I've got two sub-bullets under that for the access to educators and then for the Title IV Part A for Option 1.
Okay.
Any further board discussion on that?
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay.
We have one no vote.
That's one abstention.
Okay.
That carries.
All right.
Board member Sun, next.
Okay, so the next one.
All right, so this is on the title one part eight accountability section.
I'm incorporating number one and number two of the staff recommendation reflected in attachment two to my motion with the additional direction to specify that we will consider plan.
supplement to our January 2018 meeting to include additional details on the school identification methodology informed by the updated data in the fall 2017 dashboard release.
So what that means is that
We're approving the all applicable indicators option in Attachment 2.
And we're approving the proposed baseline methodology for identifying the lowest performing Title I schools described in Attachment 2 as follows.
Everyone's got this right, so you're following along with me.
Okay, focus the identification of the schools under ESSA within LEAs identified for support under LCFF using the criteria that SBE adopted at its September 2016 meeting.
add a new criterion to LCFF identification criteria, which would identify LEAs that have at least one very low performing school.
The current definition of very low performing is all red and all red except one orange on the state indicators.
So that was that baseline methodology that we initially we discussed.
The next piece, three, is direct staff to prepare revised draft of the ESSA state plan that reflects number one and number two above and states that the SBE will consider a proposed plan supplement at the January 2018 meeting for submission to the Federal Department of Education that describes the approach for identifying schools beyond the baseline methodology.
So that's that second tier that we need more baseline information on.
The plan supplement will reflect more current data that will become available through fall 2017 dashboard release expected in early December and in early December, which will reflect the LEA's actual identified support under the state accountability system.
Then four, approve the recommendation to revise the state plan to specify that California will use multiple
icons to report the participation rate in the dashboard discussed by CDE.
Five, approve the recommendation to revise the state plan to specify that.
A, long-term goal will be set at a high status and maintain change green cell for all, for the required indicators with all blue cells and green cells to the right goal exceeding, right goal exceeding the goal and the very high and declined green cell meeting the goal.
And then, and specify that the timeline for meeting long-term goals will be seven years.
Second.
Okay.
Board member discussion on this one.
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
So for the LCFF criteria that would be used as the baseline methodology to filter, we're only looking at priority areas.
We're not looking at the state indicators, correct?
I'm sorry, can you, I'm sorry, can you repeat that?
For 2A and B. So it says focus the identification of schools under ESSA with LEAs based on the criteria that's only through the priority areas, not through the state indicators.
Correct?
That's how we identify the lowest performing, the two red.
Under LCFF, right?
Right.
So that would be for both, for A and B. As we're using LCFF criteria.
Council has a comment.
David Sapp, Deputy Policy Director for State Board of Education.
So 2A in the motion, which talks about beginning with the districts or the LAs that are identified under the LCFF criteria, that's based on student group performance across the priority areas.
2B in the motion then looks at the state indicators only using the all indicators approach that's been approved in one, sort of to identify that layer of schools, the very high need schools as Carrick described them.
So that defines those schools using just the state indicators at the all student level.
And then it looks up to see, okay, what LEAs are those schools located in and adds them.
So it's basically the, we do the LCFF identification based on the existing criteria for student groups across priority areas.
And then we look at the schools based on state indicators only and then bring in additional districts that those schools are located in or LEAs that those schools are located in.
But all students, not subgroups?
Correct.
Board Member Rucker.
So I want to make sure that I understand this based on and I'm going to make sure I understand what I think I'm voting on using a real-time example.
And I'm going to use this district because I used to teach in this district and it no longer exists.
So, this says that when we start looking for to identify the lowest performing schools, if the all applicable indicators option says the Del Paso Heights School District is a low performing district, it will be placed on that list based on that, based on the use of those indicators.
Now, what two says is if the neighboring district like Washington Unified
has, most of their schools are performing well, but we've identified a single school in that district that has the same kind of problems that we've identified.
They meet this criteria.
They're all red or all red except one orange.
That one school in Washington Unified would be, would flag Washington Unified to be added to this list.
Is that correct?
The second part of what you said is correct.
Okay.
The Washington Unified example, the first part of it, though, isn't the all applicable indicators.
Right.
It's just the LCFF.
It's just the LCFF criteria.
And then just a final point to the question of looking, it's the all applicable, all
applicable indicators at the all-student level at that second step, that's required by ESSA statute.
It says the comprehensive support is all students.
Targeted support, which is you apply whatever criteria get you to 5% at a minimum to student groups, but you have to start with the all-student performance for the 5% comprehensive support based on the ESSA statute.
So that's what we've been sort of tracking is the federal law.
So what item two in this motion does is it does not allow districts that are normally those high-flying districts that do very, very well because they have large groups of schools or students that perform very well, but there's a single school or a single collection of students that remain regularly underperforming.
This indicator will flag that single school and as a result will flag that district.
Correct.
OK, that's that's the motion I think I'm voting for.
Any further discussion?
And I think just to say that by making this motion, we're I am not saying that this is the best thing since sliced bread and this is what it's going to be.
Right.
We made a commitment.
We have to put a stake in the ground to move forward.
So this is stay in the ground to move forward.
I think we've all made a commitment to continuously review
our processes and refine our indices, look at data, and we are all very open to making those changes if we need to as we get more information.
So this is the start.
It is not the end.
Thanks.
Okay.
Superintendent wants to come.
Just a clarifying question under the motion number four on the median and 95% participation rate.
Is it already in the guidance in the current draft?
Or is it something that's assumed as part of the motion?
There'll be communication with the district as inquiring as to why they didn't make the 95.
So we get some kind of dialogue going to establish the basis for action on the icons.
I know Carrick mentioned that the idea of corresponding with the districts that have not met the target inquiring as to what happened and what to do about it.
Right, so in our discussion we talked about having a differentiated approach.
depending on what percentage of participation they did have.
That's not specifically, that won't be specifically spelled out in the ESSA state plan.
What we'll put in the ESSA state plan is exactly what we need to put in the state plan according to our deposition rules.
And, but we can have further conversation outside of the ESSA state plan about how we're going to address each of those.
Okay, good.
Thank you.
Okay.
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
So again, under motion two, then this is still goes back to the earlier conversation where we're essentially having an asterisk and saying, make sure you close achievement gaps.
But we're not telling them in motion two based on this methodology.
We set our long term goals here.
We identify our methodology for identifying the bottom five percent.
We set our state determined timeline of seven years, but we're still not saying
for in terms of narrowing achievement gaps, which is something clearly stated in ESSA, this is what we plan.
Correct?
Just making sure.
Thanks.
What I heard, yeah, yeah, I mean Carrick can come back up again if he wants, but what I heard Carrick say when we talked about this was the interim goals will be different for LEAs, but they'll be able to calculate it on their own knowing where they need to get in seven years.
And we will provide guidance with how doing that.
how it should be included in the LCAP, potentially how it's included in the addendum for the LEA plan.
So it's not that we're not addressing it, and I get a little bit concerned that when we're having public conversations like that, that somehow we don't care about it.
Of course we do, but it's different for each LEA.
And so we're going to provide guidance for them to get to the long-term goal.
With that guidance explicitly the goal of narrowing achievement gaps where they exist.
Okay.
Any further comments?
It's not that we don't care, but if the language is not there, then that perception is reality for some.
Thanks.
Comments?
All right.
All those in favor say yeah.
One abstention.
That's a no.
Okay.
All right.
That concludes the item.
Thank you very much.
Okay.
Good.
Yeah.
Go ahead.
Back to motion one, it seems like we, I don't know for sure what we are doing with the state set aside for title four.
Because we, I think Glenn started to talk about that when we said, well, let's give flexibility at the local level.
And he actually handed out a document about where it could be.
And I don't know if that's something we need to decide or that you have to describe that in the plan.
Yes.
So do we have any recommendations?
That was some of the technical stuff that really didn't get a lot of attention in the public comment.
But it is in, you know, some of that stuff does need to be drawn or made a little bit clearer in the plan because... The plan specifically asks how do you intend to spend your Title IV-A state level... Right.
And so you're going to spell that out in the memo.
Glenn, go ahead.
If there is board direction now, I'd be happy to take it or else board members would like to send us comments and feedback.
We could, you know, articulate a proposal in the memo.
Well, no, no, no, no.
So Glenn gave us a memo that explained about the issue of transferability for state level activities.
And the question I believe that's being asked is, are we going to give the staff guidance about whether or not we want to transfer those funds out of Title IV Part A?
into one of these other titles as enumerated on the handout or do we want the staff to just address the criteria that's established for the peer review.
And I do want to stay on this part.
I heard somebody during the public comment make a comment about transferring or moving the language concerning Title IV and including it.
also in Title I. There was statute, there was bills that were signed by the governor last year concerning providing support for students who were incarcerated students who were transitioning in.
So, I believe that that's already covered in the section concerning at-risk students and there's already responsibilities that LEAs have to address in their LCAPs if they have those students in their program.
So the flexibility to do that is already something that's not only an existing state requirement, but I believe we can do that.
But the question of what we want to do with the state funds, no recommendation has been made by this board.
Okay.
Speaking on the transfer, this just came up.
I don't think we should settle this now.
I think we have September.
People have pointed this out.
This is a brand new issue.
I don't think at this point this is a good time to decide.
It would be a little bit ad hoc to do it now.
Yeah, and I think it's sort of complex and there's a lot of options and I'd like some time to think about it and not be forced here to decide it.
The current draft of the plan, I believe, says that we would be using our Title IV Part A funds
to support standards implementation, kind of to build on what's already happening in Title II and to support our state system of support, which is evolving.
And Title IV-A is kind of, it's a little difficult to manage at the LEA level because it's a relatively small amount of money.
So I think a lot of LEAs will take advantage of that transferability option.
But for our state level funds, Title IV-A has a lot of flexibility around how you use that money.
Right.
So I, you know, I don't know that what's currently in the draft is necessarily the wrong way to go, but certainly we can bring it back to you for more conversation.
We'll work with you on that.
Bring it back.
Thanks.
OK, so that's the clarification.
Now we can move on.
OK, we're now on to item four, the California assessment of student performance and progress.
Good afternoon.
I don't have to say good evening, so that's the good news.
Superintendent Torlakson, President Kerr, members of the board, I'm Michelle Senner, the director of the assessment division here at the department.
I have before you today an item four, an action item that asks the board to direct the CDE to begin the process of approving a renewal of the Educational Testing Service, or ETS, CASP administration contract for an additional two years.
Exercising the CDE's option to renew the current contract would allow for completion of the test development work for the California science test, the California alternate assessment for science, the California Spanish assessment, and also continued preparation, administration, reporting activities for the comprehensive CASP system for the 2019 and 2020 test administrations.
Renewal of the current contract will include an amended scope of work, a timeline, and budget that will incorporate changes to allow the current contractor to administer score and report 2019 and 2020 CASP tests.
The recommendation is to amend the contract end date from December 31, 2018 to December 31, 2020.
and to negotiate in conjunction with board staff and Department of Finance staff an amended scope of work to add those two testing administrations and to increase the overall budget by an amount not to exceed $157 million subject to appropriations.
We also within that motion want to ensure the following activities are administered in the, are addressed in the amended scope of work.
Ongoing administrations of all components of the CASP system.
Technical work associated with preparing and administrating the operational assessments that are currently under development.
Enhancements to the reporting system that will include increasing translations of student reports.
We also want to research the option of adding paperless reporting options for our districts who are ready for that.
Also additional enhancements to the technical hosting solution to allow us for future growth and scalability as we bring our new assessments online.
The CDE anticipates presenting a draft of that contract that includes all the components I mentioned consistent with all of these recommendations to you for consideration no later than January 2018.
I make this recommendation to you today because ETS and its subcontractors have met their existing contract requirements in terms of test administration and have successfully administered three operational summative assessment cycles.
The recommendation is consistent with the current contract language that allows the CDE and the board, in collaboration with the board, to exercise an option to renew the contract for additional years as long as the costs are negotiated with the CDE, the SBE, and the Department of Finance.
So that includes my summary, very quickly, because you've got a lot of work still to do.
And I'm here to answer any questions.
Oh, darn it, I meant to try and add wonk somewhere in there.
But she's she's not at Hey the board member questions discussion on this we I'm sure we have public comment Okay, we'll take public comment Doug McCray I
Good afternoon, I'm Doug McCrory, retired testing specialist from Monterey.
I'd support the two-year extension, but I'd remind the board of the recommendations made for changes in the scope of work that were discussed at the May board meeting.
Timely availability of technical reports has become more and more of a problem.
Technical reports to the 2016 test administrations have yet to be released more than a year since completion of testing.
Generally, such technical reports are available six to eight months after completion of testing.
I suspect the delays are due to CDE reviews rather than ETS drafts, but in either case,
The delays result in an unacceptable lack of transparency, as well as failure to make information available for accurate interpretation of CASP results.
Board attention to this aspect is needed, including the coming scope of work.
Thank you.
All right, any further board discussion?
Motion?
I move the department's recommendation.
Second.
No further discussion.
All those in favor?
Raise your hands.
Okay.
Well, that's approved.
Now we're on to item five, English Learner Roadmap Update.
Oh, okay.
Superintendent, do you want to?
Thank you.
As Veronica Aguila is coming forward to make a presentation this time, I just thought I'd take a moment to review how we got here.
Short preface to looking back to the ELA
ELD framework, which we adopted in 2014, which was cutting edge at the time and is still cutting edge.
It's a nation-leading good strategy in combining those frameworks.
And then the blueprint for great schools in 2015 called for a master plan.
English Language Master Plan, which is now the EL roadmap.
There was no funding, so we went to look for that funding.
We went, took a visit to a great school, a dual immersion pre-K school in Redwood City, and met with the Sobrato Early Academic Language Program and a representative from the foundation.
That led to discussions which led to the funding for this in 2016.
So it's been a journey to get here, but I want to thank all those who helped along the way, especially the Sobrato Foundation and the English Learner Division, working with the larger community and education stakeholders to focus on English learners.
Success.
Veronica?
Good afternoon.
My name is Veronica Aguila.
I'm the Division Director of the English Learner Support Division.
And today I'm here to present item five, as Superintendent Torlakson mentioned.
And I know it's been a long day, but hopefully this is one of those items that bring joy to the day.
I am here to present the work of the and the recommendation of the California English Learner Roadmap Work Group.
With me are Dr. Kenji Hakuta and Dr. Lori Olson, who co-chair the workgroup, and they will be coming up in a minute.
Each will be presenting a few slides, as they both were co-chairs of this workgroup.
I also would like to mention that we had the great privilege of having member Felisa Ortiz-Lincon as a liaison to this workgroup, and her input was invaluable, so we truly appreciate and are very grateful for her participation.
With the State Board of Education leadership, with your leadership, California has met critical issues facing public education with strong leadership and teamwork.
And as Superintendent Torlakson mentioned, this is the California way to work collaboratively, to work with a team approach.
And I think after listening to the news, I am so glad that I live in California.
I'm sure many of you are.
The California way engages parents and communities as part of a collaborative decision making process around how to fund and implement this improvement efforts.
The public relations that you see on this slide and many more are evidence of that collaborative process that you as a board have approved and provided guidance with.
In 2015, the state superintendent published a blueprint for great schools 2.0, which led to this work group.
In that blueprint, strategic priority 3.1 stated that we needed to have an English learner master plan.
The word master plan has connotation for those people that have been around for a long time, like me, 31 years, of some types of compliance.
And so instead of using that word, stakeholders, in the spirit of collaboration, decided the division of this work needed to have a different name, and it was renamed English Learner Roadmap.
The design of this project was to harness the research, the practices and examples of evidence-based programs and services for English learners in one place to guide local education agencies.
As Superintendent Torlakson mentioned, the California Department of Education successfully reached out to the Sombrero Foundation.
And actually, the representative of the Sombrero Foundation family is here, Kenji Treanor.
Somewhere in the back, I do want to recognize him for the funding this work.
The department then developed an application process to identify representatives from the field to become partners in the development of the English Learner Roadmap.
The department also invited other critical stakeholders to represent specific populations of English learners.
And in December, you, the board, were provided with an update of the first meeting of the workgroup, indicating a link to the list of the workgroup members.
The workgroup represents teachers, administrators, superintendents, and organizations whose mission includes the education of English learners.
The composition of the work group was representative of key stakeholders.
And you can see all those representatives in this slide.
And I think everyone would agree that we had a fabulous think tank.
The English Learner Roadmap Workgroup charge has been to provide guidance and recommendations to the development of the English Learner Roadmap, strengthening comprehensive education policies, programs, and practices for English learners.
During the discussion, the group agreed that the EL Roadmap has to include a current policy regarding English learners, especially since the passage of Prop 58 back in November of 2016.
It has to be supported by research and other guidance documents, and it has to feature or highlight effective practices from the field which are already successful and can be used as models that can be replicated.
So the English Learner Roadmap Workgroup has met three times already, and the dates are on the slide.
And during those three dates, the vision and mission statements were developed, the overarching principles that will guide programs and services for English learners, which are in your attachment one.
and also the elements to enact each principle.
The elements will be in the guidance document.
The workgroup also developed the format for the forthcoming guidance document and the proposed policy, which is attachment one of your item today.
And it's also here for your, the recommendation is for the board to adopt it.
So to gather further input, the content of the English Learner Roadmap was shared with many in the field, in the Title III Accountability and Leadership Institute, at the public sessions and conferences and network meetings, the Bilingual Coordinators Network, and also presentations at the California Teachers Association.
And the general consensus was really positive.
Feedback concluded that the roadmap was needed
a needed tool to move the needle forward to improve English learners.
The input recommended that English Learner Roadmap include tools, crosswalks to other published documents, legal citations, and a crosswalk to the state priorities addressed in the local control and accountability plan.
So all those recommendations and suggestions were incorporated.
Based on the input and recommendations of the English Learner Roadmap Workgroup,
Again, in comments from the public, the department recommends the State Board of Education adopt a proposed policy for English learners, as it's stated in item one.
Now, I would like to introduce co-chair and lead writer of the proposed policy.
As you're all aware of him, Dr. Kenji Hakuta, he's known expert in the English learner world.
And to me, when I first became a teacher, and even now, he's still a rock star.
Kenji?
Yeah, it's a pleasure to welcome one of my faculty colleagues at Stanford.
Yeah, it's the only time that we're in the same room, both wearing ties.
Yeah, that's right.
Well, mine's from a rental agency.
So good afternoon, not yet evening.
I really admire your stamina, fortitude.
It's really remarkable.
My name is Kenji Hakuta.
I'm a professor emeritus from Stanford University and founder of the Understanding Language Initiative.
I also have the honor of co-chairing with Lori Olson, the English Learner Roadmap Workgroup, and is the author of the document before you today.
Having been around long enough to see changes in laws, and I guess I should emphasize I can't
I can't figure out whether I should emphasize the long of the long enough or the enough of the long enough, but having been long enough to see changes in the laws and practice and thinking regarding how to provide English learner needs, I can honestly say that what was brought to the English Learner Roadmap Workgroup was the most current
thinking available on the topic.
Reflecting back to 1987, when I first came to California from New England, this is really night and day.
We've really come a long ways from both the policies, the laws, the controversies, and the research underlying this work.
Do I advance this?
Yes?
Let me try it here.
There we go.
Yeah.
Whoops.
Sorry.
There we are.
To undertake this project and to, I should say, go there, and to prepare the workgroup to have discussion on what to include and how to provide information in this document, we had to bring the research and practice, the law and guidance documents to the group.
And this chart is a sampling of all the work that has been done recently that has been put forth for improving what we do in education.
It was used to set the foundation for the working group.
I won't belabor all of the points here, and we could actually make this even more complicated.
And if you layer the history of where we've come, you can sort of see that it's a very complicated picture, but that really underscores the importance at this moment in time to really have a policy and guidance to pull this complicated picture together.
Prop 58, for example, that you'll be discussing next on your agenda.
The legal foundations on which all of this is based, the Castaneda principles.
Clearly, the work that California has done in both the ELD standards and its correspondence and alignment to the Common Core, Next Generation Science Standards, all
really important work in fully including English learners in this work.
We considered all of that as well as the research foundations that undergird this.
Back in 1997, I chaired a National Academy of Sciences committee that issued a report
Most recently, the National Academy of Sciences issued an updated report.
I was on this committee as well, somewhat shocked that 20 years had passed, but also pleased that there was a lot of research in there undergirding the work that went into our recommendations.
The work group members were clear when they indicated they wanted to bring all of best thinking to a single usable tool.
The resources of this tool needed to be presented in a way in which professional learning could best make use of content.
The final English learner roadmap, sorry, to, oh.
Where are we?
Here it is.
Okay.
The final meeting of this work will primarily review and provide comment on the structure and refinement of the guidance portion of the English Learner Roadmap
whether it be in print or an online tool.
Currently, it's envisioned to be an online fountain of resources, and most importantly, case examples of actions taken by local education agencies that have made a difference for English learner achievement and well-being.
Our final English Learner Roadmap Workgroup public meeting is scheduled for September 26th of this year at the Marriott Sacramento in Natomas.
lovely location, and specific information can be found at the California Department of Education English Learner Roadmap webpage.
We picture this guidance portion of the English Learner Roadmap to be developed, to be organized as indicated here.
Here it is.
Oops, sorry.
Part one would be the conditions that ripen the timing for this project.
Part two would be the policy statement on what we as California believe about schooling English learners, meeting their needs, benefiting their diversity.
And part three not only introduces the principles that guide and the elements that define our approaches, but would also provide case study examples of practices that local education agencies have instituted that are making a difference for English learners as the evidence-based practices we seek.
And to give you further information, I'd like to introduce Dr. Lori Olson, who co-chaired this roadmap workgroup with me.
Okay, great.
Good evening.
I'll just say it.
First, to Tom, thank you very much for appointing me to co-chair with Kenji.
It's really been an honor and an extraordinary journey of this past year.
So what Kenji was presenting to you is basically the policy, and the policy is that vision, the mission that really sets California on the road toward
towards serving our English learners in a way that is built around these four principles, the assets-oriented, needs-responsive schools, intellectual quality of instruction and meaningful access, system conditions that support effectiveness, and alignment and articulation within and across the system.
And while that's the real meat of what we're asking you to pass today, which is the policy of the roadmap, in fact,
What was very, very clear in all the input from the working group and from the field is that a policy is important to sort of set where we're going, but there's got to be good guidance that goes with it or this cannot be implemented.
It is such a comprehensive view of what has to happen.
We need real guidance for the field, guidance that's going to connect us to
the work we're doing on our LCAPs and the kind of planning that's going on locally.
And so we've envisioned this guidance piece as crucial and what we're asking of you today is to both adopt the roadmap but also then to direct the department to develop a guidance document.
We want to share a little bit with you about what the nature of that is because it makes clear how this roadmap can work in the new California.
So, this is the online version, just we're playing around with what that could mean, but you could see that it sort of lays out both the vision and the mission of the roadmap.
It also has in it an invitation for people to be able to submit some of their practices locally that they feel are enacting the roadmap and can be shared with others.
And you can see across the top that there are tabs for the research background, there are tabs for each of the principles, et cetera.
So what they said was, we need good examples.
We want to know that there's research behind it.
We want to know how it maps onto the legal requirements for English learners, et cetera.
But we want to know what people are doing that really is working and what are some good examples.
And so you'll see here, this would be the tab for Principle 2, Intellectual Quality of Instruction and Meaningful Access, and it includes a set of elements that get more descriptive about what that policy and what that principle means.
For example, on this one, the elements include instructional scaffolding and language development integrated across the curriculum, and access to the full curriculum, and a set of things that get more specific.
But then what they can tap on from there is, what is it people are doing in the field?
In addition to that, there will be a very clear cross map, cross walk to the LCAP principles.
And this was both something that we used in the development of the roadmap, the design of the roadmap, and something that will be a very intentional tool for the field.
So you could see
People can approach this either way.
We're working on our LCAP priority around school climate, which are the elements and the principles in the roadmap that really speak to that, that we can click on, get the research, get the examples, etc.
Or it might work the other way.
We're working on principle number three on system conditions.
what needs to be appearing across the LCAP priorities to really build that.
And so that was very intentional and it was very clear request and need from the field because this roadmap needs to map onto the work people are doing locally.
I'm just going to skip because of the interest of time.
And finish by saying, taking one little moment to mark what I believe is this historic moment.
And Veronica said this might be a moment of joy for us.
It's also a deeply emotional moment in some ways.
There have been times in the past when California has stepped into national leadership in English learner education, including more recently, things like the CELA Biliteracy, our groundbreaking combined ELA-ELD framework.
I believe that the adoption of the English learner roadmap
which supersedes the 1998 policy, is such a moment for our state.
And we should take great pride in that.
It is finally a turn away from the English only, deficiency oriented approach to English learner education.
And it breaks new ground by providing real asset based, coherent, comprehensive commitment to our English learners, providing both for our own students,
real equity, real access, and at the same time being able to offer to the nation, as we've done before, a real groundbreaking vision of what could be.
We're offering them the California way.
I could not be more thrilled and honored and moved to be at this moment and to be part of this effort.
And I want to thank you, Tom, for your leadership in getting us here and to the board for what I hope will be your adoption of the roadmap.
Veronica.
Thank you.
Veronica, you're going to close it out.
Yes.
I would like to restate the recommendation that is before the board.
The California Department of Education respectfully recommends the State Board of Education adopt as the English learner policy, the California English learner roadmap policy, educational programs and services for English learners, which is attachment one.
Upon approval of the policy, the department will continue to complete the guidance document and resources and incorporate the policy in the guidance document.
And no further action would be required on the guidance document from the board.
If there are any questions, the co-chairs and I are happy to answer them.
Thank you.
Thanks for the presentation and board member comment.
Board member Ortiz-Lacon.
I think this is such a great way to close a very intense day.
I was a part of this work group, and I want to just add a personal note to this because I think it's pretty surreal.
And I've shared this with some of the members of the committee of the work group.
I was a student at UCLA, a student activist, protesting Prop 227.
when it passed in 1998.
And so it's humbling and it's an honor to now sit here and be part of the decision-making to pass a policy that would supersede that policy that was adopted in 1998, which really, as a Latina, as a bilingual learner, as an English learner, tried to strip me of my language.
And it just brought me stronger to this place.
Excuse me.
I'm sorry.
To have that personal connection to policies that aim to really engage in subtractive schooling of who I was as a student and not validate my experience and my assets.
I'm so grateful to God and to everyone else that allowed me to be at this place to now reverse that.
And it was done in such a collaborative way with a cohort of high caliber EL experts in a very in-depth way.
We sat around, we talked, there was respectful disagreement, and I think it was
a very thorough process so I want to congratulate the department and I want to thank everyone the co-chairs and everybody that participated in making sure that we bring we reinstate dual language opportunities for our students including my two kids who were here earlier just couldn't hang beyond 45 minutes.
And I'm very excited for this so I wholeheartedly support the recommendation.
Public comment?
We're ready for public comment.
Would the following people please line up?
Judy O'Loughlin, Carly Aguilera-Fort, Carla Herrera, Vicky Ramos-Harris, Marta Hernandez, Shelley Spiegel-Coleman, Martha Alvarez, Shalonen Cruz-Gonzalez, and Lorraine Richards.
Before they start, the State Superintendent would like to make a statement.
Thank you, President Kirsten.
Thank you all who've been part of this process.
Veronica, you and your team and the English Learners Division are just fabulous, A+.
Felicia, thanks for your participation and bringing the voice of the board and your own experience to bear.
Lori, Kenji, Kabe, Californians together, just a lot of teamwork and a lot of real thoughtful visionary work that I'm grateful to see this moment to where we have the public to interact and then we have action to take with some real good guidance to move it forward.
So thanks all around.
Hello, I'm Judy O'Loughlin for CATEISL.
We're no longer in the era of English only, which is encoded in Proposition 227 policy.
We're no longer in the 20th century in the era of No Child Left Behind.
We need to bring California policy and programs in alignment with the new ELA-ELD standards and framework 21st century goals.
This is the most recent research on effective and evidence-based practices.
The interrelated alignment of standards
forms the basis for instructional practice promoting literacy through critical thinking, problem-solving, collaboration, and communication.
It provides guidance to educators to help build depth of knowledge on a range of topics.
Proposition 58, a mandate for language programs leading to literacy in multiple languages, addressing a wide range of language needs, flexibility in curriculum, lessons, and classroom assessments.
So we support this.
Thank you.
Buenas tardes.
Good evening.
Carlin Aguilera Ford, bilingual special ed teacher.
I was in the classroom teaching bilingual special ed when 227 passed.
And I'm currently assistant superintendent in the San Francisco Unified School District.
And I am representing the CABE Board of Directors and the immediate past president of the CABE Board of Directors.
Definitely, I am speaking on behalf of CABE to support
the English learners roadmap.
As an English learner myself, I know exactly the importance of having guidance and having clear perspective about the research that support the best practices for English learners.
So we actually urge you as CABE to the board to actually adopt this policy.
We also would like to ask you to actually direct the staff to provide guidance, specific tools, case studies that will support the local agencies to implement this policy with fidelity and not something that it will be misconstrued, but having the research, having the policy, having the examples, having the templates will help us at the local level.
So, thank you and CABE supports the EL roadmap.
Thank you.
Hello, Vicky Ramos-Harris with Advancement Project California.
Board member Aitu was out there protesting Proposition 227 and this is an important day for me as well.
So we're here to support the work on the English learner roadmap and how it leverages the research on early childhood education and the need to invest in early learning as an aligned and articulated pathway for English learners.
Over the past decade, California has worked diligently to build investments in early education, and we have also learned tremendously about the neuroscience and research on the critical window of language learning in the early years.
So it is imperative that we meaningfully create aligned, articulated pathways for English learners across this crucial developmental period of language development between birth and age eight.
The Roadmap explicitly does this and builds connections to early childhood in its vision and its principles.
The Roadmap promotes the very articulation and alignment that is called for in the recent National Academies of Science and Medicine, and we give our full support.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Carla Herrera, retired educator.
As a passionate bilingual educator and specialist for over four decades, I participated in multiple state, county, district, and local initiatives to support English learners, their families, documents, and programs.
I am an alternate to this work group, and I've been following the work.
And I'm thrilled to ask that you please adopt the EL roadmap as policy.
This is very emotional.
As a former IQC member while California developed our historic combined ELA-ELD framework, I appreciate our nationally recognized seal of biliteracy building the focus of English learners into the local
control funding and planning system and engaging in multiple exciting initiatives to support 21st century global education.
What we need now in the field is a comprehensive approach to build coherence across all of the separate pieces.
The four principles of the proposed DL roadmap policy are important because they connect all the important separate efforts into an integrated set of principles, tying together a commitment to meaningful access
And I just want to thank you for this opportunity.
Thank you.
I'm Martha Hernandez, assistant superintendent of Fillmore Unified School District, also a past president of the California Association of Bilingual Education.
And my dirty little secret is that I was on the board when Proposition 227 passed.
It was on my watch.
So today is a glorious day.
I'm also the president of the Yorona club, so you have to.
And so I, of course, urge the adoption of the EL roadmap as board policy.
The English learner roadmap clearly moves towards operationalizing the vision of the California state seal of biliteracy, the intent
of the EDGE initiative and research about the benefits of biliteracy.
This is a vision and bar appropriate for California, one of the most diverse states in the union.
And so I thank you and urge your adoption of this wonderful policy.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Xiloni Cruz-Gonzalez.
I'm a school board member in Azusa Unified School District.
I'm also the director for Californians Together, a project entitled Educator Support for Immigrant and Refugee Students.
Now more than ever, this roadmap is needed because of its asset-based approach and call for welcoming climate and commitment to English learner access and participation.
I especially want to recognize Superintendent Torlakson and his staff for taking the lead eight months ago, sending out a letter and just being very vocal about safe haven school districts.
I know across the street, AB 699 is working its way through that would offer protection in all school districts for our students.
And finally, I'm very proud of my own organization, CSBA, who offered legal guidance, sample resolution, and policy on this issue.
So the adoption of the EL roadmap symbolizes in many ways a further step of our state leadership by framing the EL education as asset-based.
being explicit about building a welcoming climate for our driver's climate communities, and clearly stating a commitment to meaningful participation and access.
So I thank you.
Have a good day.
Shelly Spiegel-Coleman.
Couldn't have passed my name.
Anyways, Shelly Spiegel Coleman, an alternate on the roadmap committee.
Who would have thought that we would have lived to see this day?
that California would rescind the English learner policy stemming from Proposition 227 and replace it with a policy in the form of an English learner roadmap, guided by research, evidence-based, and successful practices, and that looks at languages as assets and not as a barrier.
For many of us, your vote today is going to be a very historical moment.
We want to thank Superintendent Torlakson, who for seven years has been advocating for English learners and had the wisdom to go to the Sobrato Family Foundation to help create the roadmap that we have before us today.
We also want to thank Tom Adams, Veronica Aguilar, and Elena Fajardo for their inspiring, inspiring leadership to a very capable committee that created this document.
And lastly, Drs.
Lori Olson and Kenji Hakuta were the most amazing co-chairs.
They brought their expertise, their years of experience, knowledge of research and practice to bring us here today.
Schools and districts will be able to look to the policy and the guidance materials as they review their LCAPs and find direction for improving and increasing services for English learners in California.
Thank you.
Hello, Lorraine Richards, California Teacher Association.
My next 26 words are not going to be tear jerking, so I will allow you to dry up for a bit.
So CTA recommends the board adopt the California English Learner Roadmap State Board Education Policy.
We strongly support providing more opportunities for students to learn in their native language.
Good afternoon, Marta Alvarez on behalf of AXA.
As a long-term and forever English learner, I'm very pleased to be here today to express AXA support, strong support for this staff recommendation.
We thank the city staff for taking the time in engaging stakeholders in developing this policy.
And we echo the comments made by prior speakers regarding the importance of ensuring that the policy gets turned into practice to ensure that the practitioners can really take it into consideration at their local level.
ACCESS stands ready to lend our support in making sure that the policies and guidance gets out to the field.
So let us know how we can be of help.
It's important.
More than 1.2 million kids are out there, and hopefully one day they can be here like myself.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Martha Ceregoza-Diaz representing CABE and Californians Together.
Having lived through all the years of Proposition 227 and representing English
and representing English learners before three different state boards of education since that time.
Today is a very historic moment for all the reasons given by my colleagues.
This is indeed a historic moment and I request your adoption.
Sorry, it is very emotional for me.
Those were very turbulent times.
I request your adoption of the EO roadmap and the directive to the department to develop guidance for the field regarding English learners, especially in light of the passage of Proposition 58.
Thank you.
I'm Andrea Ball.
I'm here today on behalf of the Central Valley Education Coalition, a coalition of county superintendents and district superintendents in the part of our state with a high proportion of English learners.
We support the policy and the guidance and urge your adoption of moving this forward.
The policy is really clearly written.
I think it's accessible to educators in the field as well as state policymakers.
And I think it's a great combination of research and practice and will really be helpful to the schools and districts in the Central Valley and really across the state.
And I also want to say I want to thank the department staff, superintendent, the co-chairs for the workgroup meetings.
I attended them as a participant.
They were very open.
We did have respectful disagreements, but in a tone that was so positive and I think really resulted in a very valuable document.
Thank you.
Terry Burns for the California School Boards Association.
I want to express our enthusiastic support for the policy and want to pledge to you our commitment to help disseminate this and any recommendations you have on implementation to all the school boards throughout the state of California.
Thank you.
Well, that was memorable public comment.
I've been here six and a half years and no public comment like that.
That was really something.
So any more board discussion?
I think we've had some great words.
All right.
Well, I just want to say since everyone has been talking about this, so many of you mentioned 227.
I was an English learner before there was any such thing as an English learner.
We were just simply invisible children in the back of the classroom.
So I'm very, very, very happy to see this and will enthusiastically support.
And I don't want to take the motion away from you, so.
I motion to move the department's recommendation and I will second.
Okay.
It's moved and seconded and seeing no further discussion.
Here we go.
Raise your hand high.
Yeah.
All right.
Thanks for sharing that.
I didn't know that.
Okay.
Well, now we have the item six, which is more of administrative and formal of getting this process going.
Go ahead, Veronica.
Trying to bring the PowerPoint up, but... Yeah, it's the California Education for Global Economy Initiative.
Right.
So if I can't bring it up, I'll just speak to it.
Where is it?
I'm sorry.
Yeah, it's also here.
I could just speak to it.
So I have the great pleasure to speak about item six.
Again, for the record, my name is Veronica Aguila, Division Director of the English Learner Support Division.
Today, it's monumental in two ways.
The Yale Roadmap and now Prop 58, we're commencing the rulemaking process for Proposition 58.
That's the recommendation that we're making to the board to open that process.
As I mentioned before, I became a teacher about 31 years ago and the reason
Let's see if I move over here.
The reason I became a teacher was to make a difference in a child's life.
And I'm sure a lot of you, that's why you became a teacher.
And not just on the bilingual child's life, but every single student.
And I think Proposition 58 is also doing that because it recognizes the value of multilingualism.
So, as you know, in November 2016, California voters approved Proposition 58, which is better known as the Global Economy California EDGE Initiative.
This initiative was passed in the legislature by over 70%.
The voters voted on November 8th of 2016.
Over 70% of the voters approved that initiative.
And so what we're bringing to you is the initiative is amending Education Code Section 300, 305, 306, 310, 320, and 335.
But it is also repealing Section 311.
Section 311 was a result of Proposition 227, which actually asked for a waiver.
A parent needed to fill out a waiver for a child to be able to enter into a bilingual program.
So that section of Ed Code, it was completely repealed.
The initiative defines programs for English learners and embraces multilingualism for all students, not just English learners, for all students.
It also repeals the requirement of the alternative waiver, but it does keep the requirement to know who would like to have those programs because that needs to happen in order to implement them.
The California Edge Initiative specifies that parents of English learners may choose a program that best suits the needs of their child, and the local education agency must provide a structured English immersion as the one program choice.
The proposed regulations aim to clarify the statute by providing definitions and clarification and processes to assist districts in complying with the statute.
So as a minimum, when districts offer language acquisition programs, they are to offer structured English immersion, but they are also to offer other types of programs, dual language immersion, transitional programs, developmental programs.
And there's also a provision for language programs, which are for English only students or students that would like to learn another language on top of their English with the goal of developing proficiency in both languages.
The California Edge Initiative provides for the inclusion of parent and community member input as part of the process required to develop a local control and accountability plan.
the LCAP while considering the establishment of language acquisition programs and language programs at the local education agency.
That's one of the key areas the regulations attempts to clarify.
As you know, regulations only clarify the law, they don't create new law.
So, the regulations attempt to clarify what's required of the local education agencies
in terms of providing notice annually on the types of language programs in accordance to Education Code Section 48980.
And this information assists parents in choosing a program that best suits the needs of their children.
The initiative specifies that parents may choose a language acquisition program at their school and the school provides that program when the threshold in law is met to the extent possible.
So the threshold in the law is 30 in a school and 20 in a grade level that request those programs.
So the proposed regulations are intended to provide clarity and direction to local education agencies for the purpose of complying with the provisions of the California initiative.
The regulations are designed to guide local education agencies and school sites towards a process that incorporates parents and stakeholders into the process of establishing language acquisition programs.
We are asking that the State Board of Education take the following action to open the rulemaking process for public comment period so members of the public may provide comment.
And the slide would have provided you with the fact that there's a 45 comment public period that would begin July 29 of 2017.
There would be a public hearing to be held September 11 of 2017, and that would be held here at the California Department of Education.
We also have an email address where people can email comments, regcomments at cde.ca.gov.
And all comments will be reviewed and taken into consideration during the revision of the proposed regulations.
This is a common process that we take once an initiative of a law is passed and regulations are undertaken.
So if substantive amendments are made to the proposed regulations at the end of the 45-day public comment period, an additional 15-day comment period may be required for consideration.
Hopefully not.
Hopefully we can pass it after the 45-day.
And once revisions to the proposed regulations are complete, the State Board of Education considers revised regulations for adoption.
You have the proposed regulations in your item as an attachment.
Upon adoption, the regulations are submitted to the Office of Administrative Law for final review and approval.
And additional information on the California EDGE initiative is available in the California Department of Education, California EDGE webpage that we have created.
And the link is also included in that PowerPoint that didn't show, but it is in the link on our website right now.
Thank you.
Okay.
I think we're ready then for board discussion.
Board member Rucker.
Okay, so I was still a teacher in California, just beginning my career in a different venue when the UNS initiative was passed.
And I was, if somebody had told me that that was going to happen, I would have been surprised.
And what has gotten me through all of this time was a quote from Maya Angelou, when people show you who they are, believe them.
And so,
today, people can believe us on this with the action we're going to take.
But how well I remember what the impact of that simple initiative was.
This board was defunded by the legislature.
We did not adopt an English Language Arts curriculum.
We had arguments about the content of the English Language Arts
framework.
There were people who were appointed to this board whose appointment was not reaffirmed by the legislature because of arguments over these issues.
I met a young man named Tom Adams in a legislative meeting.
So we have come a long way, but the fact of the matter is within this community, we have also changed the way that we have this conversation.
That through all of that bitterness and all of those conflicts, we've gotten to this point and we took action on that previous item.
So to be able today to follow up that action with this step is quite significant.
So I'm going to quote Maya Angelou again.
When people show you who they are, as we're about to do today, you need to believe them.
Okay, any further board comment on this?
State Superintendent?
I'll just be very brief and mention one slight amendment to Veronica's great presentation and Patricia were with you in the same feelings and all the board, but 73% passed.
I mean, when do you get three out of four people agreeing on anything, especially something that was so controversial, so divisive?
So it's been an enormous mindset shift.
and understanding shift.
And we know language is a way to understand other peoples and their culture and their aspirations and values.
And so, yay, this is a great step forward.
Yeah, and the proposition passed in every California county.
That was even more astounding to me, you know.
So, we'll... Okay, no further comment.
Is there any public comment on this side?
Yes, would the following people please line up?
Cheryl Ortega, Peter Shilla, Carla Herrera, Lori Olson, Vicki Ramos-Harris, and Martha Alvarez.
Good night, I mean good evening.
I'm Cheryl Ortega and I'm the director of bilingual education for United Teachers Los Angeles, a bilingual educator for 47 years and a Prop 227 warrior as well.
Can't do it.
On the day after the election, the multilingual department of LAUSD was ready to act, and we applaud their outstanding proactive efforts to support language learning.
The executive director gathered her team and began planning how to implement language learning.
From the start, it was determined that broad collaboration with learning partners was the way to ensure success.
So in January, the Prop 58 transition team was born, meeting biweekly throughout the entire semester.
The goals collaborate with various departments, including administrators, teachers, parents, labor partners, and external experts.
Consult CDE regulations to align to district policy and develop policies and communication plan to implement the Multilingual Education Act.
Also partnering with higher education institutions.
We're asking you, the transition team is asking you for guidance through the state regulations and we hope that this model of collaboration will be implemented statewide because it's a really, really good way to get things done.
Thank you.
Good evening.
I'm Peter Schilla with Californians Together.
We strongly support the department's recommendation for your action today.
And I have to say my first reading of these regulations is at least a thousand percent better than the ones they're supposed to be improving on.
I'd also like to say that I think the field needs the guidance of these regulations.
And we appreciate that you're going to move forward and put them out for public comment.
And we enthusiastically will be consulting with the field and providing our input.
Thank you very much.
I just want to say thank you.
Hello again.
I'm Carta Herrera, a retired educator, bilingual educator.
In 1974, when the Laud decision passed, I was doing my student teaching, and I went from an idealistic, bilingual, passionate educator during the case studies with Veronica's predecessor's department to being mid-career, just so demoralized when Prop 227 passed.
with many people in this room.
So I just want to say thank you and that we look forward to providing input on the regulations for implementing Proposition 58 during the comment period.
We believe that regulations will provide the critical guidance needed to the many schools and districts that are interested in initiating and expanding their current bilingual programs to support the opportunity for all students to develop proficiency in English and another language.
Supporting schools and districts wanting to develop multilingual programs is consistent with the results of the recently released study by the National Academies of Science, Engineering, and Medicine with states promising results for English learners and dual language learners.
Thank you.
Good evening.
Hello again.
My name is Vicky Ramos-Harris from Advancement Project, as you know.
We want to say thank you and also we look forward to offering input with the regulations for implementation of Proposition 58.
As others have said, this is going to be critical, important guidance.
Also, given what you've heard me say before, given what the research shows on early childhood education, there's a critical window for language development in the earliest years.
And we've seen this in the research with the National Academies and much progress over the last decade.
So we want to make sure that the guidance also includes support and guidance for including early childhood in the implementation of Proposition 58.
We've seen what this looks like at LA Unified who just passed up a dual language learner early childhood pilot that's being implemented.
implemented this upcoming year.
Long Beach Unified is also implementing.
So there's some examples of early childhood dual immersion programs.
We need to see a lot more and the guidance from the state is needed.
Thank you.
Okay, that's the end of the public comment.
No further board comment.
All those in favor of the motion.
Oh, we have to have a motion.
Sorry.
Thank you.
I motion to move the department's recommendation to begin public comment and everything else.
So I'll just motion to move the department's recommendation.
Who was second?
Thank you.
Okay.
Now there's no further comment and we're ready to vote.
Raise your hands.
That passes unanimously.
Thank you.
Now we're...
We're on to the waiver process, and I think all waivers are on consent.
So I'm going to move.
Yeah, I know some have to recuse.
Yes.
So waivers, we're going to do waiver consent votes on W1, 2, and 4.
through 19.
So we're going to have a consent vote here on every waiver except waiver three.
And board members Ortiz-Lacon and Ting have recused themselves.
I move the consent.
Their public comment.
Okay.
Yeah.
Is there a second?
He's moved.
Second Rucker.
Public comment.
Shalon Shalon and Cruz Gonzalez Colleen Pachter and Angela de Ramos Come forward, please
I did not expect to speak on this item.
So I actually came up here to speak on the previous items, but I was really surprised to see an item here contemplating a waiver to San Gabriel Unified on an option for youth charter school that operates within our boundaries of Azusa Unified School District.
I'm just here to express our opposition to this waiver.
We have never been formally informed of the fact that they're operating within our district.
They have never reached out to discuss anything with us.
And we were not even aware that this was going to be on this agenda item today.
So I wanted to express our concern about that whole process and the transparency of this.
And again, express our opposition to this waiver.
Thank you.
Okay.
Come forward, please.
Hi, Colleen Pachter on behalf of Los Angeles Unified School District.
We respectfully ask the State Board of Education to deny the request submitted by San Gabriel Unified School District, William S. Hart Union High School District, and Acton-Agua Dulce Unified School District on behalf of their respective non-classroom based independent charter schools.
Each of these three schools seeks a waiver of the geographical and site limitations set forth in the Charter Schools Act in order to continue operating one or more resource centers locating within LAUSD's boundaries for one more year.
In addition to the objections presented in the letter and attached materials submitted by LAUSD, we wish to highlight our continuing concern that approval of these waiver requests would compromise local control and marginalize the central role of LAUSD's democratically elected board, ensuring that students living and attending public school within the district's jurisdiction have an equitable opportunity to receive a high quality education.
We therefore urge this board to deny these charter school location waiver requests.
Okay, that ends the public comment.
Any further board discussion?
I'm ready for a motion.
You have one, okay.
All those in favor of the motion?
Thank you.
Okay, now we have waiver consent vote three, Rucker recusal.
Okay.
I move staff recommendation.
Any public comment on these, on this motion, on this W-3?
No, no public comment on W-3.
Okay, we're all ready for the vote.
Those are your hands.
Yeah, okay, that W-3 carries.
Okay, now we're ready for proposed consent.
These are our consent items, and they are items 7 through 17.
So.
I move the consent items.
Okay, there's a second by Sandoval.
Is there any public comment on these?
Yes, Eduardo Aguilar.
Don't forget her, yeah.
Okay, it doesn't appear this person's here?
Sure, the person signed up is Eduardo Aguilar.
Okay, no public comment.
We have a motion.
All those in favor, raise your hand.
Okay, then we have one person who wants to do a public comment for one minute who can't come tomorrow.
a general public comment.
Thank you for the courtesy of letting me make this comment today.
I am Doug McRae, a retired testing specialist from Monterey.
Two quick comments on June information memos that were not on the agenda.
First, one of the memos for LPAC revealed a change in how to establish cut scores, namely to use LPAC field test data for this aspect of test development.
It's very poor educational measurement practice since field tests are not designed to produce data for valid standard setting.
More on this in your electronic folder.
Second, the CASP memo included a number of points that need your attention, including unwarranted delay for release of statewide test results from mid-August until September.
And second, still no information on the adequacy of Smarter Balanced item banks.
This item, this information is needed to determine if the computer adaptive future feature
is capable of measuring the low spectrum of achievement and hence supplying accurate achievement gap data.
It's also needed for evaluation of the quality of the interim tests, which is being challenged by AB 1035, now making its way through the legislature.
Again, thank you for hearing my comment.
Okay, the board is adjourned for the day.